e
e e
come
good morning I'd like everyone to please
take their seats so we can get started
and resume the budget hearings uh just
one change in the schedule uh this
morning uh the treasury Department which
is supposed to testify what was supposed
to testify at 11:00 a.m. the treasurer
has a last minute unavoidable
appointment she has to make so she's
going to be uh moved from the 11:00 slot
to the 1:00
slot other than that uh we're ready to
begin and i' like to call up the office
of professional lure and
certification I like to congratulate the
executive director on her appointment
and this is her first uh budget hearing
so welcome thank you yes uh thank you so
much and good morning to all the members
of the committee um my name for the
record is D jurus and the executive
director of The Office of professional
lure and certification Which is far too
many syllables
but I'm getting really good at getting
it out um and then to my right is
director of operations Heather Kelly who
uh speaks Finance much more fluently
than I do so um have her here for
additional support in any questions that
you may have that I cannot answer um so
thank you so much uh for having us this
morning I will uh try to lead off
briefly
um the oplc um the principal mission is
to safeguard public health safety and
and Welfare and the public Trust of
citizens of the State of New Hampshire
so we have in the presentation you will
see um starting on slide three we
oversee the administration of over 50
occupational licensing boards councils
and commissions um seven of those are
advisory boards as opposed to
Independent Regulatory boards uh other
than the actual the size the number of
members they function very similarly um
in a role so an Advisory Board is
advising the executive director on
ProMag gating rules and other
regulations related to the profession um
the regulatory board does much the same
um it's a little bit more formal and
historically there's a larger number of
members um we have a number here over
200,000 occupational licenses we use
nice round numbers because it's easy
we're pretty soon going to have to
adjust that up I believe uh because I
think we're right now closer to 240,000
licenses in the state of New Hampshire
by my back of the napkin ma that's uh
about 20% of the state holds an
occupational
license um in addition to assisting
boards um we have the function of
Licensing individuals who wish to
practice in New Hampshire and ensuring
compliance with those laws through
investigations and inspections we
average about 100 complaints a month and
we conduct about 2,000 inspections
annually um just for a sense of that the
formal inspections that are done by
staff members you'll hear mentioned a
little a little bit later we have U
mechanical inspectors so Plumbing gas
Fitters um oil heat installers
electrical inspectors Pharmacy
inspectors we and uh cosmetology
inspectors so that's um there
significant changes there but that is um
embedded staff who are out in the
community in doing inspections in shops
on job sites and and such um our budget
here you will see on slide four for
fiscal year 2026 is uh 15.1 million and
then 27 15.7 million uh again round
numbers um that is well within the
Target that we were given by the
governor's office um it includes a
request to move eight temporary
positions to permanent in the area of
operations hearings and
investigations um in the last budget
there were six temporary positions that
were converted to full-time um on the
next slide I'll talk a little bit about
kind of the some of the history of the
structure of the office and why uh the
continuing to add positions there um
worth noting that we have defunded all
of the mechanical and electrical
inspectors from in to meet the
efficiency budget but it's it's below
well below the Target and the goal is
actually to bring those back as
unclassified positions which happened um
with the pharmacy inspector so we're
trying to compete with Market rates so
uh the the idea is is to try to move all
of these inspectors to that unclassified
position um to allow for that salary um
and flexibility so again we started it
with Pharmacy or it happened a few a few
years ago and the goal would be to move
the mechanical and electrical to the
same space um I've heard in other pieces
that would talk about how um an hb2
request would not have any money
attached to it this coming budget
session or that may be the plan uh this
would be an hb2 request but it would not
requ require any funding because oplc is
a self-funded agency so there would not
be any dollars attached to that would
just be the language to create those
positions so on Slide Five you will see
just a little bit of a timeline um the
oplc as an agency has not yet existed
for 10 years so it is a fairly new
office agency within the government um
the state of New Hampshire uh in fiscal
year 2019 oplc became a self-funded
agency so it no longer receives any
general funds to support
operations um in 2020 then the executive
director was granted authority to
promate rules for all boards that
participate in the professional health
program that is this um a dedicated fund
that we administer um specifically to
support professionals who need help
around mental health uh substance use
abuse um there's a portion of that fee
that goes to certain professions that um
we manage and contract for that service
in 2021 there was an establishment of
the enforcement Division and then also
notably covid-19 emergency licenses were
issued um that plays into the budget
because there was just a significant
volume increase in the number of
licenses um in 2022 the statutory fee
Authority for boards was eliminated so
that is solely at the um the authority
of the executive director um whereas
previously each individual board was
setting the fees for their licenses and
then in 202
three there was um HB
594 which is also known as reciprocity
which where the outof state applicants
are licensed in another state if they're
substantially similar can be licensed in
New Hampshire also that year with the
dedicated
and that decision was made because it is
99 maybe even 100% of our our revenue
and uh the the office was starting with
with zero in the um in the budget
basically at the start of the fiscal
year so this is just a more efficient um
more effective way to run the office um
we have a a balance right now that is
largely the result of low Staffing and
high number of licenses in the those
pandemic years where there were a number
of emergency licenses coming in
so the fund is large uh larger than
we've ever had before which was Zero um
but there's some some money there that I
think could possibly tempt someone to
create a a lapsing fund again but we
would respectfully request that we
consider um continue to use that for
operational purposes um again as we're
completely self-funded we were planning
to um we have a fee package that is um
nearly ready to propose because again
this the budget is set by you all um but
the the fees are just in administrative
rules that we were preparing and so we
are looking at setting those fees
accordingly uh my predecessor began that
conversation with each individual the
consultation excuse me with the boards
and we are moving forward in um in that
way with a proposal to hopefully have
the the revenue side through fees to
match the budget that that um will be
passed in June for the next two fiscal
years
um I will leave the other slides in
terms of our um structure and the
organizational structure for your
reading I guess the the biggest thing is
I because I'd like to leave time for
questions
um I guess I will just highlight the
personnel and benefits cost ends up
being about 73% of our budget so similar
to many agencies we're we're an agency
of people and hoping to um continue to
meet the needs of New Hampshire
well um the office again like I said is
new so there are new positions coming in
as the legislative um mandates change we
are we are adjusting accordingly uh but
it's it is very fluid and staffing needs
within each division has have changed
over the last nine years and I
anticipate um some more fluidity moving
forward as we figure out where to
allocate resources um effectively in
terms of Licensing and enforcement so
I'm with that I'm happy to take any
questions thank you uh you mentioned you
had a fund balance or how much is that
currently it's roughly four and a half
four and a half
million we have not added to that in the
last fiscal year I'm just looking at
Heather again she speaks fluent Finance
um I believe that is a balance that has
mostly rolled over we have not added to
correct that those funds have rolled
over two years ago the agency operated
at almost a loss last year and is
currently operating
at a loss this
year okay when when did you grow the
fund balance to be 4.5 million how long
have you had that that it's been rolling
over uh last fiscal year 22 when it
rolled over
okay I think you could talk a little bit
how you derive your income I know it's
it's obviously through fees but how
would how would the rates
set so we have a cost allocation plan
method that we use first we evaluate to
make sure that we are under the 12 25%
so that we are not collecting a tax then
based off of those fees and our budget
we divide the operating costs of the
agency by the licensing count of the
board um any direct costs for like
mechanical or Pharmacy we allocate that
directly to Pharmacy and do not divide
that cost amongst the boards and from
there we come up with a figure for the
board and then set the fees
accordingly have you done any sort of
studies to uh see how our licensing fees
compare with our neighboring states we
have started that process this year uh
in response to our fee increases that we
will be
proposing we have some data but it's not
complete
yet okay great I think I saw in here
where you had
mentioned sorry I'm sorry I was just
going to say for the record uh the
proposal the fee proposal that is coming
out of the office shall be filed with
the joint legislative committee on
administrative rules will include
include some fee increases but will also
include some fee decreases based on that
calculation to make sure it's um
allocated
appropriately okay I'm sorry to
interrupt but I wanted to make sure it's
not it's not just fee increases across
the board I was interrupting you no no
need to
apologize um I I believe you mentioned
in here there somewhere there there are
positions created by the legislature
that you have not funded yet uh
including a chief of staff and I believe
a council position and maybe one or two
more MH uh what What's the timing of
that way to in order to uh meet the
legislative mandate to fund those
positions so the yes if on uh page 12 if
you'd like to look there we've not
funded the chief of staff Chief general
counsel um or chief legal counsel and
then a board Council position that would
be within the um we currently have three
attorneys that represent the 57 boards
so that um with the
addition of the review of board
materials passed in sen Bill 369 there
was a creation of an additional uh
attorney position to do the review of
those materials to make the um
information publicly available uh before
the board meeting not just a review
after of meeting materials for to be
responsive to a 91a request um we as
those are vacant uh and we were looking
at making position adjustments and we're
looking at our Revenue right now and
basically just it's a a decision of when
to fund them uh based on when the
revenue is there the chief of staff and
the chief legal council positions are
both unclassified appointed positions
and the goal would be to start working
with um the department of or division of
personnel um to establish those
positions and work forward and then when
the funding does come in um to to be
able to to post those interview and and
fill them so at this point our um the
with the current fee structure and the
current number of
lenses the revenue is about $8 million
short of what we are all what we have
been allowed to budget so that the
revenue does need to increase so it did
not feel prudent to fund new or to hire
and start paying for new vacant
positions where the office has already
been operating without
them representative Wilder thank
you when you have a board for a given
license um do those members receive a
stipend or travel
pay they do I I'll look for Heather for
the specifics it's small yes uh each
board member will receive if they elect
they can opt out a per DM for their
travel time to the board meeting and
then they also receive mileage
reimbursement if they request so does
that depend on like the uh the pay that
would be given in that license versus
some licenses would would produce more
Revenue some less uh it it varies based
on the board we can get that data if you
would like oh yeah and is it there a
consistent number of members on each
board it's five most have five some of
our larger boards nursing has nine no 11
now Excuse me yes so there are some
larger boards is not a consistent number
I think uh because of I don't I don't
want to use the word ad hoc but there
are there there have been lots of moving
pieces and I think as things kind of get
tacked on the boards had existed in so
many different places throughout state
government that there's not a lot of
consistency even within Healthcare
there's a wide discrepancy of number of
members um in addition to the other
professions so it is a little bit all
over the place and do you have meeting
places for these boards we do have three
public boardrooms where they can come
and generally we will we don't have the
staff to support more than three board
meetings at a time um so that is what we
have in our current space yeah thank you
thank
you commissioner I have to at least
apologize for being late and uh not
being here for your presentation I'm
sorry about that yes you really missed a
good one yes did did you say um you have
$8
million your budget $8 million more than
you raise that that's it's a projected
number but I guess if we based on the
budget targets that we were given for
the banum and then we do the math with
current lienes and current fee structure
it ends up being about $24 million over
the banum and we have been the
authorized the target was just over
32 so there is a
gap oh over the bium okay over the bium
mhm
um okay so it it sort of moots my next
question which was which is but I'm
going to ask it
anyway um in the past oplc was budgeted
differently right that that um at the
end of the year the the excess Revenue
um would would lapse to the general fund
in in the same manner as the if people
watched um Labor's uh presentation
yesterday where I think they lapsed like
2.8 million
um I was going to ask about going back
to that model um although what you're
telling me is that
you're you're 4 million a year in
deficit not a couple million a year
ahead you used to always be ahead what
this is a dumb question but what changed
and maybe maybe you don't know I don't
I'll give you my best my best
understanding of the history as you know
this is U only about my 10th week in the
office but um it's my it's my
understanding that the legislative
mandates for the office and the
responsibilities that have shifted to
the office rather than to the individual
volunteer licensing boards has increased
over the last number of years so uh for
example the um you can go back in our
slides and I apologize for this let me
just find
it um the enforcement division was
created in fiscal year 2021 so before
that there um that was not an in-house
uh operation there was a there was some
support within the oplc and within the
board structure but then there was the
administra Apu the administrative
prosecutions unit in doj so there's been
a lot of shifts Additionally the office
now is responsible for licensing um
again the professional boards provide
their expertise around the rules and the
requirements for those licenses but then
the office the staff are doing the
actual credentialing they're receiving
the applications reviewing and issuing
them in addition to that we also now
have um administrative law judges um
that do those administrative proceedings
and I and I think there's um so there
are staff doing things that volunteers
used to do uh they're doing it
effectively and and I think we're
growing in efficiencies we have some
technology projects that we're working
on there but uh staff costs more than
volunteers and which seems really simple
but I think that's a part of it I think
the other piece is there was some
consolidation that happened in the hope
that we would um reach some efficiencies
and maybe lower costs for the
administrative of the the administration
of these licensing functions across St
government I think what we have found is
that it's it's possible that there were
mandates um that we now upon review
there's more work than may have been
being done and I I'm trying to say that
graciously to just say uh we we may have
found a lot more work to do than was
being done before the consolidation um
now that it's centralized in and being
reviewed in that way so I think there's
there's more work to be done than was
being done we have received additional
mandates that require staff instead of
volunteers will the will the new
computer program at all
create I'm going to say efficiencies
which is one of those th those I'm
mindful of Neil Kirk once saying in a
budget hearing I don't think the word
means the same thing to you as it means
to me and so I think efficiency is one
of those words but
um uh uh staff um savings so to speak
I'm not saying you're going to lay
somebody off I'm saying and that that
work question right you're you're if you
do everything you're required to do in
statute it it turns out to be more work
than may have been being done before
because they were doing less than was
required in statute we we do hope so I I
think we we have 35 really dedicated
individuals who um a call center is a
bit pejorative but their their role they
answer the phone they answer emails and
they credential and license individuals
all day every day they're very dedicated
um they do very good work we're turning
around licenses now um 7 to 10 business
days um with on a on average there are
number of factors that can limit that
but a complete application of a person
who meets all their requirements is is
coming in and out the door um we do have
some applications that are still many
initial applications that are still on
paper because of uh technological
limitations uh the goal would be to move
all initial licenses and renewals to
that um to a digit digal platform that's
more user friendly and easier on the
back end for us to administer I do
anticipate that when it's clearer and it
works better fewer people will need to
call uh because the system will be more
efficient so we again we have staffed up
a large number right now to meet the
need and um we're we're addressing in
our Licensing Division I think it's on
average we're about 97 to 98% of calls
are handled which is a dramatic
improvement over the last year so
they're they're getting the work done
and and hopefully a new system will help
to alleviate the need for so many staff
on the phones I would say I hear I hear
positive things about uh I don't have a
license for anything um but uh looks up
to drive I have a driver's license just
for the record um I uh but um I hear
very positive things about your customer
service I saw a news report recently um
and I don't know the details of it the
governor Pennsylvania whose name I don't
recallo I think that's right um I was
going to say Josh something but that
could be wrong that's right yeah Josh um
I think they have an initiative where if
you apply for a license and you don't
get it and and they don't get back to
you within I'm going to say 30 days but
look it up because I'm don't don't
believe me on it you don't have to pay
for
it and it's sped up time um you think
we're probably in better shape than that
I I think they they probably did it
because they things were're really
problematic but I I think we are in
better shape than that I me again there
are a number of factors that so every
board is a little bit different but I
would say again if we have a complete
application it is not taking us 30 days
to get it out the door some of them
could be within 48
Hours yeah oh that's actually quite
impressive very nice okay all right I'll
shut up now represent
W so about a third of your employees are
in
enforcement so how much do you generate
fines I'm I'm want to look together for
that I think we probably are going to
have to get back to you on that number
we we're going to have to get back to
you on that number but we remember with
labor that's a a fairly large portion of
the the funds they generate and it would
seem like if you have a third of the
people in enforcement the the fines
don't have to be very much to to bring
in a fairly good portion if you've got
that many people and that
many things that failure to comply would
seem like a possibility of in inreasing
those fines would that have to go
through uh rules I
guess it would and I and I would say are
enforcement actions they do include
fines but uh it is often the case that
there will be an agreement not to
practice or a revocation of a license
and so the the fine is not the only
penalty and in in fact it we don't find
it's the most effective penalty and so I
I think our fines would be less
extensive than you might imagine because
again this is It's individual people in
their livelihood so there's there's
um there's a number of factors to
consider there thank you
yeah thank you very much for your
testimony like to call up now the
department of military Affairs and
veteran services
good morning and
welcome good morning committee members
uh thank you for having us here today uh
for the record I'm David mtis the
commissioner for the Department of
military Affairs and veteran services
the ad general for the New Hampshire
National Guard and with me here today is
Judy Chen our administrator in the
bottom line up front our current
operating budget submission is prudent
reasonable it meets the governor's
efficiency Target budget that requires a
4% budget reduction for State fiscals
year 26 and 27
we have not requested any new
positions however it comes with risk
before we talk about the risk associated
with the efficiency budget I'd first
like to offer to you which I think other
agencies will as well is this 4% budget
reduction is really 25 to 30% budget
reduction when you really take into
account the salary increases 10% in FY
State fiscal year 24 and 2% in state
fiscal year 25 also compound that with
additional 30% health insurance
increases for this bium this budget
reduction is really 25 to 30% of our
operating budget when you look at our
operating budget you'll see that the
state operating budget is only 20% of
our overall operating budget where we
bring in approximately $34 million of uh
federal
funds so what is the military Affairs
and veteran services military Affairs
and veteran services was incorporated in
2019 through a governor executive order
codified into law that changed the Adent
General's Department which primarily was
uh uh given the U responsibilities of um
supporting the New Hampshire National
Guard with an additional veteran
services portfolio so what is the
military Affairs the military Affairs
involves in New Hampshire Army and Air
National Guard it comprises over 3,000
service members on the Army and Air
Federal civilian employees with 80
buildings geographically dispersed
amongst 18 communities amongst the state
of New Hampshire two-thirds of our state
Personnel support that military
portfolio whether it's groundskeeping
maintenance security Force protection it
you name it uh the state employees do
that to support the 3,000 men and women
in uniform when you look at our veteran
services portfolio it is grown prior in
2019 we're responsible for the state
Veteran Cemetery we currently are
responsible for the state Veteran
Cemetery division of community-based
military Outreach and the division of
veteran services that veteran service
portfolio is just under 30 uh State uh
employees when you compound the
legislative mandates that involve our
legislative uh our veteran service
portfolio you realize since 2019 we have
received zero support in the back end we
have not requested any new positions
will we assume our risk in this current
budget is both accounting and
procurement the last two years we have
turned in federal dollars because we
couldn't execute those contracts for
either services or construction and
exasperated that with additional Federal
funding that we use our Congressional
Delegation for Congressional directed
spending projects uh we have a difficult
time in the back end supporting the
accounting and procurement of these
Federal
resources subject to your questions
that's all I
have thank you uh question about your
federal funding uh how much of the
federal funding is secured meaning is
there a discretionary component to it if
if Washington or uh uh Congress decided
that there were things they didn't like
the way we were were being done in New
Hampshire is it their discretion that
they could cut back on the federal
funds yes but generally I'm going to
going to contradict myself
um generally know that we're giving
almost two operating budgets on the
federal side one is approximately $200
million which you don't see which is the
pay allowances travel and training for
our soldiers and Airmen and the National
Guard the other piece is the operating
budget that you will see the $34 million
which comes in the utility upkeep the
maintenance and the and the services
um there's a legislative proposal out
there that is titled defend the guard I
would offer to you that it's a
catchphrase which is really defunds the
guard if that legislation comes into um
um fruition we will be in Jeopardy of
losing our federal money thank you very
much I I have just a a couple things and
first of all I it's great to see you uh
both of you um and uh uh I'm this first
budget in a long time without warrant
and and so we already miss him and he's
been going a week um um I want I want to
say something just for the benefit of
some of the people
listening um because it's it's the
notion of a 4% cut being a 25% cut and
all that and I and I think it I think
it's useful for the because there's a
public audience as well just to
understand like 4% of what and 25% of
what and all that and so there're you
know with with budget numbers there are
18 different ways to look at any
numberers you know and um and I would I
would say that the the rough 4% Target
you have is 4% of a of a post pay raise
inflated number for 25 so it's not what
was actually budgeted in 25 but it did
include the 10% and the 2% and the and
the uh and the pay race and all of that
so it so it is actually post that so for
example you spent 5.5 million in general
funds in fiscal 24 and you're post post
cut budget in 26 proposed efficiency is
actually 30% higher than that at 7.3 so
I think there's a way to describe a 4%
cut as a 30% increase and there's a way
to describe it as a 20% decrease and um
so there a lot of different ways to look
at it and so anybody out there agencies
preparing their budgets for example will
know that there are different ways to
look at it too um and I would note I
would just want to note that for for
anyone listening that's out there but um
if you had to cut more which isn't where
I was supposed to go with this is it but
um if we if we reach the point in the
budget where we look at the numbers as
they're coming in and say you know
between this tax going away and that tax
going away we have a little bit less
have you thought internally about I'm
not asking you to share it today have
you thought internally of where the next
few hundred grand would come from uh yes
we have okay I just I'd say that for
most agencies to sort of prep them for
the worst and hope for the best so um
but that's all
really thank you very much for your
testimony like to call up now the
insurance Department please
good morning my apologies good morning
my name is DJ beton Court I have the
pleasure of serving as the commissioner
of the New Hampshire insurance
department I am joined by my assistant
commissioner Jason Dexter we are pleased
to discuss the Department's proposed
budget um as with All State agencies we
complied with the governor's Target I
will be candid with you and
representative Wier probably won't find
this all that surprising I given our
history together I found it to be a very
worthwhile exercise it really forced the
department to assess uh the positions
that we needed and ultimately you will
see reflected here that we unfunded
three full-time positions and unfunded a
part-time position we also reassessed
our need and Reliance on consultants and
contractors as well as really digging
into what the department needed for
adequate training dollars for our
employees and so as a result of all that
we were able to identify a number of
efficiencies uh unfortunately for you
like a lot of the other agencies you
will hear from and have heard from
you're not going to see any of that
money uh we are a self-funded agency our
department is funded via an assessment
to the insurance carriers doing business
in New Hampshire that assessment is
based off of the percentage of the
business that they write here in the
state um that said we've also been
looking very carefully at some
regulatory reform uh you will also see
reflected here that um we have taken the
governor's encouragement over the last
many years to get very serious about
succession planning in my department in
particular I think needed to take that
seriously we had heard from uh three
Insurance Commissioners over the years
about the fact that the department was
getting older we had a lot of our core
team members who were were approaching
retirement
age the warning signs were going on we
actually took it seriously and put a
plan in place to deal with that and so
um the result of that is is that we have
filled some positions that we have not
as a department filled before so I've
put together as you'll see reflected in
the form e a proposal to be able to
obviously pay those folks but not have
the assessment need to go up and to try
to offset some of the assessment for the
industry while also ensuring as I've
said appropriate succession planning and
filling uh some key
positions um I guess I'll pause here and
you all can take this where you'd like
but I think those are the core uh pieces
that um I wanted to highlight for
you thank you uh you mentioned that you
you derive fees as a percentage of the
the business that the insurance
companies write in the State uh New
Hampshire as we know has has one of the
lowest tax burdens in the country and
certainly the lowest tax burden in New
England uh but I'm going to ask you a
similar question when I asked oplc and
have have you looked at where your fees
are as a percentage of the business they
write compared to some of the other
states in New England and and whether
are we higher lower or or where are we I
don't know if you've done that study but
if you have I would like to so in terms
of the insurance premium tax I will say
that we're probably right where we need
to be I can't imagine that we're
dramatically higher than any other state
doing business in terms of the
assessment I mean it really is a
calculation of what's the Department's
budget divided by as I've said the
calculation of how much business those
uh companies are doing in the state and
that's what we take in it's pretty
straightforward I'll just turn to I
guess Amy is that a fair is that a fair
description the person much smarter than
I says that was an all right description
so we'll go with
that um yeah I don't remember the year
we we started lowering the premium tax
and what is it 12 years ago somewhere in
that ballpark I want to say somewhere in
the range of 13 14 or 15 something like
that um I part of the part of the hope
for that was the the that a bunch of
um uh insurance companies might might
what's the term domicile here mhm um has
there been any success in that every
time I go through Hartford and look at
Etna's giant complex I think about that
this well Connecticut is kind of the
capital of insurance
and we'll do our best to compete with
them but that's fairly well established
um in terms uh I I can tell you that in
my time with the Department we have had
at least two companies domesticate here
in New Hampshire and by that I mean
actually created the company and decided
to domesticate here in terms of the
number of companies who have decided to
redomicile I know there have been some I
don't know the precise
number fair to say fair to say some but
not overly dramatic that is correct okay
you know but what I would say though is
it's not I I I appreciate the fact that
at the time the goal was to attract
companies to domesticate here what I
would say though as well is it was a
good decision though they probably
didn't realize the reason why it was a
good decision at the time because we're
currently in a hard Insurance market and
I can get into all of that but the
bottom line is companies are seeing
massive losses they are re-evaluating
their risk they are getting out of
writing certain lines of business
they're managing their risk in a tighter
way and I think that we've been able to
keep an extremely healthy Market here in
New Hampshire by having a favorable
climate both in terms of the tax burden
and in terms of a common sense
regulatory burden so we are in much much
better shape than the rest of the
country uh and I think again it's
because of the steps that the state and
the department has taken over many many
years
that's great thank you for that um
you're the the insurance taxes are one
of the largest uh larger I should say um
sources of revenue for the general fund
lately especially with the coming demise
of the one of our best performing taxes
is going away um the uh you kind of blew
the numbers out of the water last year
on your estimates which is great um and
are looking like maybe will again this
year um do we anticipate sort of
continuing growth I know the premium tax
is the is the driver of that and and I
know none of my insurance premiums went
down but do do you see sort of healthy
continued growth in in
taxes a lot of other agencies are
counting on you that's all I'm
saying we will shoulder the burden
commissioner uh it's hard to say and I
know that when commissioner nicolopoulos
put the revenue estimates forward he had
a philosophy of being cautious and
conservative and I share absolutely that
philosophy but what we were also trying
to understand is how does this hard
Market impact the revenues that come in
via the IP because typically what
happens is when premiums go up I mean
this is the hard markets a basic Supply
demand Dynamic the need for particular
kinds of coverage is at the same or at a
an increased demand but access to it is
more restricted and so therefore the
premiums go up when that happens what
you see is people will make adjustments
in their own budgets and so rather than
ensuring say the the summer car or the
antique car they'll not Ure that uh ra
you know they may start to assess all
right am I at the age now where I can
let my life insurance policy lapse
because I don't need it anymore and so
when that begins to take place obviously
the revenue begins to decrease this has
been a very very tricky hard Market
again I could talk about this all
morning I'll bore you to death I won't
do that but we're really trying very
aggressively to understand when this
Market is going to soften given the
Dynamics that are making uh making up
the current market and it's it's a
little bit of a difficult analysis at
the moment I know that uh Insurance
Regulators across the country are trying
to uh figure this thing out so My
Philosophy is we're going to be uh
realistic and I would note and you
probably noted as well that we did
revise our revenues uh based off of what
we were seeing we need to maintain our
credibility of course but we're going to
also be appropriately conservative and
cautious as well and if the market does
begin to soften then phenomenal we'll
come back to you and we'll revise those
numbers upward and it's good I for the
for the IP which is something like 85%
of
your your gifts to the general fund
um how much of it is is various line
like how much of it is Health versus PNC
or whatever well that's a very good
question Amy and ballpark I don't mean
I'm not going to hold you to this yeah I
maybe half is the health and then the
other half is all the other lines
combined
okay thanks that's very helpful oh one
last
thing uh
$393,000 of federal funds La uh last
year
what was that those I believe were
grants grants that we received for
various um is that arpa
no no I just I it's it jumped out at me
when I was looking at your your chart
I'm like hey I didn't know they got
federal funds we had a good year
attracting some some grants particularly
in our life and health division okay and
then for succession planning my last
point is this is that why Jason's
sitting next to you
and Keith he's here
too representative
wer thank you good to see you good to
see you my friend and uh in the past
we've had some meetings about complaints
from car repair places have those
lessened any have you been able to find
a way to to satisfy more of
them oh if I had that Talent uh to my
knowledge it has certainly quieted down
I will say that we do have a couple of
what we would uh label frequent flyers
yes uh but we are uh certainly working
with them continue what I think has been
a very constructive dialogue and we'll
continue to triage those issues as they
come up glad to hear that I look down
here and see that your fine uh Revenue
in in 2024 was was much higher than what
you project going forward was that a
special time was that some big uh
Federal suit or something that that
brought that no we had a couple of high
dollar settlements with some companies
who needed to get back on track let us
say and I think that we have also taken
an approach a pragmatic approach to say
all right under the statute you know
this company really ought to be fined a
million dollars but the reality of it is
we don't have the ability to chase after
the company should they dis dispute that
that would have to go over to the
Attorney General's office and they have
a very very full plate so rather what we
try to do is to negotiate the fine down
to a level that we know we're going to
be able to collect that payment and what
we'll do instead is put forward a more
thorough and comprehensive corrective
action plan for that company to fix
those problems or the problems that were
identified in the investigation so that
was likely an anomaly that you can't
anticipate happening on a regular basis
no we always like to think that our
companies and our producers will behave
themselves um I have yet to see a year
where everybody's been perfect but to
your point representative it's hard to
say it's hard to say what we're going to
uncover What complaints will come in
that generate an investigation and then
ultimately what turns up as a result of
that well I haven't heard any complaints
lately so I'm congratulations thank you
we're
trying great thank you very much for
your testimony thank you
Department of energy is next
up good
morning good
morning my name is Jared choin I'm the
commissioner of the Hampshire Department
of energy uh joining me today is Lenny
radio uh Doe's chief of
operations I'm happy to be here to
discuss the department of Energy's
budget request um and also happy to say
our agency request meets the governor's
budget targets um the department of
energy has a big portfolio of roles uh
which include regulatory advocacy before
the Pu uh utility and pipeline safety
functions uh consumer services uh a
number of assistant and other programs
and also policy work administratively
attached to the department are the
Public Utilities Commission and the
office of the consumer Advocate uh our
funding streams are a mix of federal
funds utility assessment uh and other
funds with a very minimal uh general
fund request of
$2500 and uh we send that $2,500 to the
Connecticut River Valley Flood Control
Commission and that's something that's
been in our budget it was at the office
of energy and planning which became the
office of strategic initiatives and when
the department was created
went with us so we still have that um
additionally it's it's worth noting that
70% of the Department's budgeted
Appropriations are passed through grants
um perhaps the most notable example is
our fuel assistance program which is
funded uh by the lowincome Home energy
assistance program or Li Heap uh and is
administered in conjunction with the
state's Community Action agencies uh the
fuel assistance program program as I'm
sure most of you know uh
purchases uh heating fuels for lowincome
New Hampshire uh households uh the first
page of the overview that we provided
shows the regular Federal programs that
we administer and then the next page
discusses activities related to the
Department's General utility
assessment um I do want to note that we
are actually doing well and feeling good
about our vacancy rate um uh the last
budget we're in a very uh different uh
position uh the state employ raise was a
big help in bringing positions um more
in line with the market and has helped
with retention and recruitment U we have
a lot of positions that take a
considerable amount of time to train
someone and uh to get them up to speed
and to maximize productivity so it's
really important that we can keep them
around uh our prioritized needs are
primarily two new position requests uh
one is for a new auditor for our
enforcement division we currently have
five auditors uh in a long time excuse
me um uh and that number has been able
to maintain a busy and perhaps a bit uh
strained workload um and but and and our
needs have grown I'll say that our needs
have grown um you know these positions
our audit team uh they have a a high
return on investment um they scrutinize
the utility records and filings um and
they've been very successful in finding
savings um two notable examp examples uh
would be of their work would be storm
costs over the last couple of years
we've had several major storms and those
costs are very high and our audit team
reviews those um those costs and of
course the uh Department makes a
recommendation uh to the commission uh
in those proceedings and and they
determine if they were prudently
incurred but that's the important work
our Auditors do uh another good recent
example of their work would be uh
recently we filed a motion uh to dismiss
uh Liberty rate case and um you know
that was based on the findings of and
work of that team so very important work
that they do um our second request is
for an additional utility analyst which
would be utilized uh utilizing federal
funds uh in the state energy program uh
this position is relatively flexible uh
to support policy work of the agency and
would be used for uh for projects like
the next update of our 10-year State
energy strategy
um and uh also the variety of
Investigations and proceedings um which
we have been assigned by the
legislature the state energy program
gives the agency flexibility whether to
support staff or programming Most states
use this funding primarily or entirely I
should say on staff um we've taken an
approach to fund some beneficial
programs like Energy Efficiency projects
through the state energy manager at the
department of administrative Services um
as well as a school Energy Efficiency
development program to help support
Energy Efficiency in small
schools um and however we are shifting a
lot of that programming to sep funds
received through the iig um want to make
that that clear um so with that happy to
take any
questions thank you um the Department of
Revenue with with their Auditors they
they say I think with some historical
validity that they actually generate
revenue from the state uh whereas your
aors may not do that do they pay for
themselves and what they save rate
payers I would say they do um I mean
there can be you know millions of
dollars in savings to Ray paays as a
result of their work um and that can and
and the two examples I gave are really
good ones storm costs um and rate cases
brought by the utilities okay thank you
I I would just say that if it were up to
me you should budget more for the uh
transfer to the state Energy Office of
the Department of administrative
services but that's just one man's
opinion it seems like a really good and
very efficient program um we could
review the memorandum of agreement we
have with you just saying um or
something like that um given that we
gave you Lenny that seems only fair um
that that's fair
um I have a I have a question about um
and this is the dumbest little thing
that I'm obsessed with but um
Connecticut
floodwater what's your piece of
that we don't
um I we don't have a piece of it let's
put it that way um it's it's just it's a
pass through from us and um it goes to
support the operations of that
commission um and it's it's been on the
books for decades I've looked to Lenny
on this um a very long time um we don't
have any direct workings with them um we
we send a check and this isn't related
to the property tax uh payments that we
make to the people whose land we took
for the
dams I don't know I would have to look
into that okay where's it
budgeted do you know roughly right now
we have it budgeted in our
administrative um division okay I mean
it was in OSI which basically had you
know a couple accounting units it's one
of I believe it's one of those programs
where we don't know where to put it so
it goes in the governor's office so OSI
here you take it and then it's just
never gotten rid of it since we came I'm
okay with that because normally those
come to me and so I'm very happy about
that um okay I just and it's not a thing
I'm looking to do anything with it's
just one of those uh trivia pieces they
government I would like to we'll talk
thank you very much
thank you very much for your testimony
thank
you like to invite the Public Utilities
Commission for their
testimony good
morning good morning uh Dan
goldner chairman Public Utilities
Commission joined also by uh by Mr audio
the um public Utilities Commission is
tasked with overseeing safe adequate and
reliable service adjusting reasonable
rates for our state's electric gas and
water
utilities the commission's role is the
Arbiter of the interests of um of
customer unregulated
utilities the commission regulates over
$2 billion in annual revenue and over8
billion in assets where the electric and
gas Commodities can vary greatly in Good
Times providing affordable energy for
New Hampshire citizens and businesses
and in times of high prices an area of
considerable cost and stress on the
residents and businesses of the state
which the commission Works to amarate
through its oversight work the site
evaluation committee has responsibility
for the sighting of energy facilities
the committee was reformed by the
legislature earlier this year from nine
to five members moving enforcement to
the Department of energy and combining
the SEC and pu so that resources are
fungible and uh just briefly on the
budget uh for the fiscal year uh 2026 uh
Target of 3.75 million um our agency
request at the moment is favorable to
the tune of about
$126,000 for fiscal year 27 the target
was 3.83 Million we're favorable about
$81,000 at the moment we have 16
positions at the uh fill positions at
the Pu uh an authorized Target of 17 so
that's a vacancy of of one and that's a
senior advisor position that's vacant
today so I'll just pause there and take
any
questions question M you're in the
Walker building yes sir do you know
roughly when you moved to the Walker
building um our our space was
established with the split of the Pu and
our current space uh commissioner Arling
house I I have a feeling you're going to
a different place but our current space
was established in uh in 2021 with the
split of the puc and doe no just do you
know who's in charge of the move when
you moved to the Walker building from
the heights I actually don't do you know
it's Michelle thank
you that's all I want to say that's
another piece of trivia of state
government that I'm interested I did not
know
that any no more questions thank you
very much for your testimony thank
you I'd like to now invite up the
officer of the consumer
Advocate good morning uh good morning
everybody I am attorney Donald C for the
record and since February of 2016 I've
had the honor of serving as the consumer
Advocate I happen to know the answer to
the question that commissioner Arling
house just asked uh because I was
working at the Pu at the time we might
migrated over from uh Old Turnpike Road
to the fabulous Walker building in 2004
and it was a glorious day when we got to
do that and yes Ms Caro did play a very
very important role in that project and
we are grateful to this day I'm serious
it's an excellent building and we're
very pleased to be there um the office
of the consumer Advocate has existed in
some form since uh even before that back
into the late 1970s we are a small
Scrappy state agency currently of uh six
full-time employees we are uh currently
at no vacancies for the first time in
many years we're very fortunate about
that I agree with the uh previous folks
who have uh well I agree with the idea
that the basis for that is the uh
increases in state salaries that have
helped us attract a really really
excellent team uh we have been able to
meet the efficiency budget targets with
uh relative ease and so our request
Falls within those targets our
prioritized needs are mainly only
arising out of the fact that
commissioner Arling housee is uh raising
our rent for the small space we occupy
in the Walker building sure he has an
excellent reason for doing that uh I
haven't investigated it so I can't
really comment on it uh we in the
current bium increase the size of our
office from five to six people and we
did that because were able to bring on a
director of regional and federal Affairs
so much of the action these days in
electricity regulation has to do with uh
the regional grid operator ISO New
England and its uh Infamous stakeholder
advisory body so it is very important
for us to be a visible and muscular
Presence at the regional level and that
is what we are now able to do thanks to
the change the increase in our size from
five to six people uh our job here on
the home front is to represent the
interests of residential utility
customers at the Public Utilities
Commission we like to think we make the
pu's job easier by doing that how do we
do that well the puc's job is to serve
as the Arbiter between utility
shareholders and utility customers the
shareholders it won't surprise you to
know are extremely well represented at
the Pu and so we put a little weight on
the other side of the scale and thereby
make it easier for the Pu to discharge
its Arbiter role uh I think that's all I
have to say happy to answer all of your
questions thank you uh you mentioned you
have six employees up from five but it's
it's six employees um how how is that
number derived is is six the magic
number or is that just because of budget
constraints in in the past that that's
the money we've given you and so that's
what you have to work with uh in your
budget I mean I'm going trying to find
is what's the appropriate number in your
opinion on how many employees you need
to successfully complete your mission
that's a really difficult question to
answer because as you just suggested the
the reason we're an agency of six is
really just that is the historical
evolution of the amount of positions
that the governor and the general court
have been willing to authorize my
counterpart in Maine uh now his job is
slightly broader than mine because his
agency is tasked with representing the
interests of all customers not just
residential customers and he has roughly
three times the budget that I do and
about twice the number of people so if
if I had to answer theoretically like
what's the right size of an agency like
mine for a state of our size I mean
obviously we're a lot smaller
geographically than Maine but we're
about the same number of people and I
would say that the main public Advocate
is probably more right-sized than we are
there is always more work than either my
counterpart in m can do or I can do and
so if you were to quadruple the size of
the OCA we would find things to do with
that size at six people we are able to
uh be a muscular Presence at the
regional and federal levels and appear
in almost all of the major pu
proceedings so we are able to operate
effectively at the size that you have
authorized us to
be thank
you are are you paid by rate payers
yes ultimately we're we're not General
funded we don't even have any obscure
Connecticut commissions that we're
funding we could work on that uh we um
uh we're funded via the utility
assessment mechanism that also funds the
Pu and the department of energy but in
theory I should be happy about that
because you're making my electric bill
go down not only your electric bill but
also your natural gas bill your water
bill and uh yes that that D tells into
my second question which is what what
percentage of your activity is electric
versus the other things so to speak I
would sayy that's an excellent question
I would say about 60% of what we do is
related to electricity maybe
65% I would say about 20 to 25 maybe 30%
of what we do is related to the natural
gas industry and the rest would have to
do with uh water utilities
our our electric rates um and I'm
jumping all over a bit here um you know
one of our competitive uh difficulties
isn't so much taxes but electric rates
which you know if you if you build stuff
you worry about electricity you know we
don't have hydro so we're not like
Washington State and you know the
Northeast is pretty high are we getting
better in terms of Vis A our neighbors
or worse I think we're getting better uh
we are the only state that doesn't have
a mandatory decarbonization goal and
that has freed the state up from the
need to pursue and or subsidize uh
resources that aren't competitive with
uh resources that aren't considered
renewable we do have hydro resources we
import power from Canada which is
largely generated uh via Hydro One thing
I didn't mention is that we're entering
a new era of electricity in New
Hampshire and it is the era of the
community power agregation programs so
there is a joint action or joint Powers
Authority Coalition of many many
municipalities and all called the
community power Coalition of New
Hampshire it is on its way to becoming
the largest load serving entity in the
state and keeping an eye on them is an
important new imperative for me and my
staff and if the if say the department
of energy starts to investigate
something like micro grids is that
something that you tend to be involved
with
uh yes or like in the beginning or later
uh the beginning the middle and the end
okay uh and as the department becomes
more of a regulator and opens
investigations and conducts its own
proceedings that also is something we
have to keep an eye on okay thank
you
representative are you involved in any
way with um backup
systems um we keep hearing there threat
on the electric grid do you keep track
of of any of that efforts I I think it
depends a little bit on what you mean by
backup systems if you're worried about
cyber security which is a pressing
concern for the electricity grid I I
think the answer is that we are not at
least not below the level of making sure
that the right people are thinking about
that cyber security is very technical
and uh it falls into this weird category
of stuff I actually don't want to know
about because there's no way I can
develop the expertise to uh question or
scrutinize the Judgment of the Cyber
Security Experts who protect the grid
and the more people who know about that
stuff the more security risk there is so
we try to actually stay out of that
Beyond assuring ourselves that the right
people are keeping an eye on that and I
I I do think they are and we as a result
have not suffered any cyber security
breaches or failures in the electricity
grid during my years as consumer
Advocate uh do we worry about
reliability and resilience yes that's a
big deal especially at the regional
level because we spend a lot of
resources making sure that the bulk
power transmission system the regional
electricity grid is uh impervious to
things that challenge it principally the
thing that we worry about is an extended
cold spell in the winter when
electricity generators are competing for
fuel with uh people and businesses who
use natural gas for
heat uh kind of off the subject I know
another Don creit how do you spell your
last name I spell my last name k r
i ah thank
you that was the easiest question I've
gotten so far
today okay see you know other questions
thank you very much for your testimony
yeah see we've now completed our
our uh 8:30 slate of of testimony so we
are now in recess until 10:
A.M
e
e e
hey good
morning uh we are reconvened now 10:
a.m. and I would like to I don't need to
invite up the executive Council because
they're already sitting
there welcome and we'd love to hear your
presentation good morning everyone for
the record my name is Megan Rose and I
am the executive assistant to the office
of the executive Council uh before you
this
morning you'll have the um budget book
for the executive Council Office the
budget booklet and then you'll also have
just a brief packet of an overview of
the office of the executive Council um
our staff and how it's made up our
mission statement the um districts and
their square
miles and our core functions and my
contact information I never want to
assume that everybody just knows who the
executive council is or what they do so
I figured a little bit of information
might be helpful um in my budget booklet
this morning you'll see that we did meet
the 20 fiscal year 2627 efficiency
Target um and that we are um we have a
PRI prioritized needs request in for our
part-time position in the
office um the office is a staff of 1.5
it's myself as a full-time uh employee
and then I have a part-time staff member
and then the executive counselors um
having the part-time staffer has been a
lifesaver for our office um for office
coverage and
other um just being able to provide the
assistance needed to keep the office
running well and to assist the
counselors as they need um but I'm happy
to answer any questions should anybody
have
any thank you uh how many meetings do
you have a year I mean I know they're
every other week but sometimes you skip
a week roughly how many meetings do you
have so it's anywhere between 22 to 24
um meetings per year um schedules set by
governor and counselors and uh approved
in six-month increments thank you who
actually pays for those meetings and and
when I mean with with pay I mean the
entire thing from from the breakfast is
uh that they have the breakfast meeting
and then the main meeting I know you
have uh uh you know audio teams and doit
teams and things like that but uh if you
could just go through how those costs
are allocated sure so um the the
meetings as they're scheduled each
executive counselor um and it usually
goes in order by Council and including
the governor at the end they get to pick
a state agency or office to host us for
a breakfast meeting and it is an
opportunity for the state agency or
office to kind of update governor and
counsel um on things that they're doing
or if they're running into issues with
things stuff of that nature the cost of
um hosting the governor and Council for
breakfast falls on the agency currently
so whatever agency is tapped has to pay
the cost of breakfast um that usually
when they're being when the agencies are
being told how many people to plan for
um the number is usually between 20 and
30 25 and 30 that we ask them to plan
for because it's not the responsibility
of the agency to You Know cover
everything it's their responsibility to
um provide breakfast for the governor
counselors and the state agency staff
that have to be there um but that falls
on the agency um the regular meetings
which begin at 10:00 a.m. um at the
state house or sometimes off um offsite
during the summer months and we take the
show on the road um the cost of um so
usually there's a reading or prayer um
the people that come in are chosen by
the governor or counselor that's hosting
there's no cost associated with that um
there is always some sort or not always
but there's usually some sort of
entertainment like a local school will
come bring the school kids to sing or
maybe local performers Come and sing or
play instruments
there it has been my understanding and
it has been past practice
that there is not a cost associated with
that
however um if we were to reach out to um
a state agency or to ask for help like
dncr or the arts program and there were
a cost associated with that I have never
paid that cost from our budget and to my
knowledge the governor's office has not
there could have an agency could have
incurred that cost on their own but I
don't I don't know for sure thank
you Hi how are you I'm well how are you
um I just I wanted to point out a couple
things for the record for people who are
uh listening and watching at home um the
the
council well there there a couple things
one I presume the the in your budget the
class the class 11 is you or maybe the
class 12 is you the class 11 is the five
counselors and the class 12 is um your
wonderful part-time assistant um so the
class 16 is the um part-time
assistant and then the counselors are
paid out of 11 or 12 yes okay yes
they're paid out of um
11 um and uh uh for years the each of
the counselors has a has a stipend
that's meant to cover their
expenses and I think it was two years
ago that it used to be district one
always got more because it's such a
giant district and redistricting mid
District Two also weirdly large district
and so now one and two get more three
four and five get less right that is
correct and
um when you present to the house do you
present to the house yes and do any of
the counselors ever come with you
no which is unusual I just will note for
a couple of the house members that there
are always some counselors who who find
the budget process mysterious and don't
realize that they're allowed to advocate
for themselves so if you want to Curry
favor with them there's a
possibility thank you nice to see you
nice to see
you seeing no further questions thank
you very much thank you
like to invite up now the developmental
disabilities
Council good
morning good morning
and we're good thank you so for the
record my name is isidora Rodriguez
legendre I serve as the executive
director at the New Hampshire Council on
developmental disabilities we are a 100%
federally funded state agency so our
Target was zero and we met
it um that's a fun joke I have um so I
my information that I have provided this
morning is really associated with kind
of who we are and what we do um our
Council as I said is federally funded
we're established through a federal law
known as the DD act um our charge within
that law is to identify the most
pressing needs of the um community of
people in New Hampshire experiencing
intellectual and developmental
disabilities it's very specific which
makes us um different than for example
the governor's Commission on disability
which focuses on the Ada and
accessibility for all people with
disabilities um uh our funding is
established by Congress so um our budget
that we get is a grant um and we have a
what's called a 2year project period
when we get those funds so typically we
receive about
226,000 a year um and then we have two
years to obligate those funds and a
third year to liquidate those funds
which allows us to carry forward funding
which is why our budget
um is higher than
$526,000 which is hopefully our
anticipated Grant award for this year as
well it hasn't really changed much in
many years um so I like to say we do a
lot with the little funding that we do
have um mostly we need to partner with
other groups and
organizations that help us um support uh
creative initiatives um for true
authentic Community inclusion for people
with intellectual and developmental
disabilities all around New Hampshire
and so um although a lot of our
funding is used for our three full-time
staff that's what we have um according
to the DD act 70% of our budget must go
to projects initiatives and programming
that creates an impact in the lived
experience of people with intellectual
disabilities and developmental
disabilities in New Hampshire and so a
lot of our staff we roll up our sleeves
and we're out there doing projects where
in the community supporting initiatives
and um putting on trainings we do a fair
amount of technical assistance on things
like plain language and accessibility I
like to boast that we were the first
state agency to push doit to have an
accessibility icon on our website for
people with uh different um access needs
and functional needs for accessing
information um so we are very kind of
community-based and um a lot of our uh
staff time is spent supporting Community
initiatives and projects the other way
we support our mission and our goals is
through a small grants program so we
have several small grants available to
community members who experience
intellectual and developmental
disabilities um to agencies or groups
that want to put on accessible community
events or um training initiatives to
help build capacity and access in New
Hampshire for people with lived
experience of intellectual and
developmental
disabilities um and so we depend on our
Partnerships and we partner with a
number of different state agencies by
law at least 60% of our Council
membership and we actually have more
because a lot of our agency seats are
also family members with lived
experience of intellectual and
developmental disabilities must be
people from the community and parents
and guardians of individuals from the
community so that our work is led by the
people most impacted by the initiatives
that we support
um our budget I will go into our budget
so we develop a fiveyear plan we have a
state plan um we have a fun infographic
on one of the handouts uh that it's
related to our Five-Year Plan we do a
lot of like I said um advocacy capacity
building and participate in systems
change activities we are on a lot of
other commissions councils and groups
and organizations to really bring the
voice of people with disabilities to the
work that's being done in New Hampshire
um
and our budget is pretty
straightforward um the only prioritized
needs that we had were numbers that were
given to us by doit I think it's
$16 in one year and $9 in the next um
and we are hopeful that we will continue
to be level funded that's the that's the
best case
scenario um at this point I think um and
I'm happy to answer any questions
specifically about the budget but really
like we are a program right and and our
people are on the ground really uh
creating opportunities supporting
initiatives and removing barriers for
people to access their community
thank you um question that I'm not sure
you're going to be able to answer but I
just want to get you thinking about it
you you you you said best case scenario
is level funding you obviously you're
federally funded yes uh the
incoming ad Administration has made it
very clear that they're starting this
office of government efficiency looking
to cut upwards of and if you listen to
the the heads of the commission up to
two trillion doll from the federal from
the federal budget uh how secure is your
funding for the next I know you
obviously can't say anything beyond the
the future banians but for this bium is
is this something that's baked in and
we're worried about future or or this
bium you're concerned about as well it's
not so the only thank you for the
question so the only thing for sure is
that we're funded through the continuing
resolution so we have received our
notice of awards for $16,784.23
again the amount of money that we get is
determined by Congress from one year to
the next we do have a lot of disability
affects everybody right you don't it
it's not B political party thankfully so
we have a lot of allies in Congress that
get it that understand that this is uh
this These funds are impactful and um
really change people's lives and allow
for inclusion so
Although our hope is that um we will
continue to be level funded um I the
last time that um this president was in
office there was an attempt to defund um
DD councils or significantly reduce the
funding which which is alarming to us so
um you know we're going to continue to
do the best we can with with the
whatever we've got um but uh it is a
little in unsure and we are a little
insecure about what the future will
bring um hi thank you for everything you
do um I keep moving it closer I can't
help myself um how long have you been
with the council so I have been there
over eight and a half years now okay oh
so then when we first met you were new
yes oh I didn't realize that I thought
you were a veteran um uh which is uh
telling I I would just say in the
interest of um offering security where
there's none actually available um
you're right about multiple parties so
the the outgoing Governor um came into
office with a with a mission to
streamline and cut government and pass
the largest funding of of DD programs in
the history of the state and so there is
a lot of cross party support for things
for things like that am I also right
that um by federal statute or law you
cannot be part of another agency you're
required to be independent so that that
is a great question um with the
reauthorization of the DD act in
2000 what that said was that we cannot
be part of
DHHS because that would be like our
advocacy includes challenging
supports and services that are either
inequitable or that create access needs
for people with disabilities our members
advocate for continued funding of DD
Services um and so it it is not allowed
for us to be part of a
DHHS however some councils do have
what's called a designated state agency
which is simply a pass through of the
funding so that would be um some agency
that can offer some level of
administrative support so be more like
administratively attached not that that
would be okay but part of another agency
correct okay cool thank you
m seeing no further questions thank you
very much for your testimony thank
you and Department of Transportation
please
invite it up
next we a
good morning good morning thank you for
uh um having us and letting us uh run
through our budget uh I'm Bill Cass
commissioner for New Hampshire do with
me is the Danielle shandrea Director of
Finance and uh behind us I also have a
Deputy Commissioner Andre Brier and
assistant commissioner Dave rodrig if
there are any
questions so um you should have um a
handout of the presentation in our in
our budget book um
we usually strive to uh clearly convey
you know what we do in our budget book
handout provides a little more detail of
the different
organizational um codes and what they do
and and some of the accomplishments
there but um I wanted to try to simplify
uh simplify it and condense it into our
um agency budget presentation which you
should have a copy of the of the handout
for so that's what um I will follow
along with and on page two of that
presentation
um it it discusses our purpose and and
Mission and at dot we work very hard
every day to provide transportation
excellence and enhancing the quality of
life in New Hampshire our purpose is to
provide quality Transportation projects
and services for all users in a safe
efficient and timely timely manner on
slide three uh we give an overview of
the department organizational structure
um generally I wanted to walk through
this presentation to let you know who we
are what we do and what we've done to
meet the budget targets um the
department is made up of five major
divisions and the budget presentation
and structure of this presentation is
going to kind of follow those um it's
going to be structured around the
individual uh divisions so um on that
org chart um I uh I'm I'm here as the
commissioner assistant commissioner
Deputy Commissioner and then underneath
the directors of the five five divisions
project development operations Finance
Aeronautics Rail and Transit policy and
administration and on the outside of
that are are our safety section and
asset management performance who report
directly to the uh commissioner office
and currently uh do is comprised of uh
approximately six uh uh
1650 um permanent full-time
positions on page
um four is a funding summary of the
overall Department budget and some of
the challenges that that that we have in
explaining the budget is the complexity
of our of our funding so we're funded
from four um uh funding sources
primarily uh Turnpike funds Highway
funds General funds and uh federal funds
um other funds are also mixed in there
which um includes betterment and
typically um restricted uh Highway fund
Revenue that that's categorized as other
funds but um the percentages of the
budget and there and uh each different
division each different program uses um
different types of funding ma uh funding
allocations but bottom line if you look
we've really tried to hold the line on
on our budget if you look at the overall
Department budget uh for
796.3151 milon it's it's uh virtually
the same as the current 2025 adjusted
authorized as far as the total budget on
page five is a little bit more um
granularity of of the agency budget and
we usually try to present and talk about
our budget in two major uh components um
on the left of those pie charts and blue
is the municipal Aid and
construction um component of our budget
a lot of that is the pass through
federal dollars that go to
um the uh federal aid programs our
Highway program our bridge program and
the priorities and constraints for those
programs are largely discussed um as
part of the 10-year plan process which
goes which which um takes place on an
off budget year but the funding is
obviously reflected in our budget the
right side of those pie charts which is
the operating um budget is really
represents the op you know the um what
it is to operate and maintain the
operation system and is really kind of
the focus tends to be the focus of our
of our budget presentation and our
budget discussions at this time of year
the breakdowns of that are shown at the
bottom in that
chart on page six is um uh a couple of
charts that just highlight uh a couple
of the issues one of the big issues the
challenge that we continue to have is is
Workforce Staffing uh and a continued
elevated vacancy rate the bottom chart
um shows um budgeted filled positions
versus uh versus um um budgeted
positions versus filled positions and
for the last several years we've been
running uh on average a 203 to 25%
overall agency uh vacancy rate um some
some bureaus some areas uh higher than
others um but it is a A continuing
Challenge on the top chart uh represents
a historical look at budgeted budgeted
positions um and overlaid with that is
vehicle miles traveled which which
indicates you know kind of a use of the
overall transportation system and what I
like about this chart is it it does show
that historically um we have cut um to
be as efficient as possible and we um
continue to serve increasing utilization
of the transportation system with with
few your people and um I think it
highlights an efficient organization and
we continue to do more with
less
um and as I start into the presentation
I I I'm going to kind of go through
quick in the interest of of time but
please um uh we can need take questions
at the end but don't hesitate to
interrupt me if there are questions as
as as we go if there's something not not
clear um but on page um on slide um
seven
represents uh the budget targets that we
were given so the department had three
budget targets to meet our general fund
budget Target was uh 1 Point
approximately $1.8
million um it's approximately a 10%
decrease from our FY 25 adjusted
authorized the turnpike fund and the
highway fund budget targets were um were
were were level funded targets with flat
budget targets and we'll talk through
this presentation on how we um met the
targets for each of the organizational
divisions um in the interest of
Simplicity we've kind of rolled up uh a
number of the uh budget um divisions uh
in the in in and organizational units
under the general organizational titles
and that bottom chart represents um kind
of a a crosswalk of how we've
um rolled up some of those um budget
things but generally I wanted to kind of
walk through the divisions and how the
budget targets were met um give some of
the implications of the budget but I
also wanted to highlight some of the
accomplishments because even though we
do have Workforce challenges um I do
think we are um accomplishing a lot of a
lot of good
things so on on page eight is a um is a
summary of the division of the
Aeronautics Rail and Transit and this is
a small Division and this is the only
General funded position in uh General
funded division in the department and
this represents that $1.8 million um
general fund uh budget Target that we
were given that supports this division
it's about 20 positions in the
division um and uh we met the budget
targets by a couple of things um we
um uh we shifted one one of two um uas
positions uh to be a highway funed
position um primarily that that position
serves um the highway program and we
felt it was uh appropriate and um but
that position will now be restricted to
only Highway funded needs um per per the
highway fund um restrictions one of the
other components of this uh of this
division Last by enum the legislature
funded an increased State match for uh
Transit
services and um with the budget targets
we were given we were unable to you know
continue that operating match it uh
equals about $1.7 million per year um
pass by inum there was a lot of advocacy
from the transit industry for for um um
increased State support for transit
services but with the budget targets we
had uh this is one of the budget impli
ations that we aren't able to fund that
um in this bium um and it impedes public
transit agencies ability to match
federal funds and and potentially
deliver
services so one of the factors to
consider in this um in this division
even though it's a small number it it
administers pass through a lot of
federal funds so the FAA the the
Aeronautics funding and the transit
funding that that runs that passes
through this division
um and administered by by by the by the
staff um so the escalating indirect
costs of a small of a small Bureau um
you know they have to be absorbed and
can compete with other other services
within the general funds make it
difficult to
um um address and and meet those needs
um the other area within this division
um we know that um there is a lot of
demand and for um increased um
recreational use of our un un unused uh
railroad corridors that the that the
that this division is responsible for um
and we really uh are not in a position
to uh respond to significant effects
we've had a lot of storm damage and
stuff and there's a lot of demand for um
you know use of of rail Trails um that
that we continue to have trouble um
meeting but with that said uh you know
some of the accomplishments in this
Bureau over the last bium there was a
substantial increase in federal relief
funding for for airports and Transit and
uh with the same number of people these
the the folks stepped up and had um um
administered
[Music]
um uh the additional uh relief uh the
additional funding and grants that came
through here um we are also um actively
implementing the unmanned aerial systems
uh those are drones that's the uh uas
implementation and looking to integrate
with other
agencies so that uh when you looked at
the slide the slide before of the budget
summary this $1.8 million is a very uh
small drawer on the general fund
comparatively and this is the only
division that draws on the general fund
uh within the
dot the next slide slide nine uh just
summarizing izes uh the uh division of
finance um on the right there summarizes
the uh Finance Bureau and their roles
and
responsibilities uh as far as accounting
operations payroll audit and um uh Etc
uh to meet budget targets here one of
the things we did was reduce um
positions we uh reduced two full-time
positions one permanent one
temporary um and we've also had to um
look closely at print shop equipment
purchases and and and reduce that and uh
we're looking in the FY 27 budget at
deeper Cuts in overtime temporary help
and equipment and supplies in order to
meet the budget targets um one of the
factors in this division is a been a
high turnover a significant loss of
historic knowledge um so some of the
challenges are with that lack of
experience trying to trying to keep up
with um with everything um
um so and it creates upward pressures on
on overtime and other things to meet the
budget deadlines or the financial
reporting deadlines that come along with
it but with that said um you know there
are uh a number of accomplishments in
the division um large amount of um uh uh
payroll and payments and and uh things
that have been processed over the year
um the administration and programming of
over 900 Federal projects as well as
clean clean audit opinions on both the
tumpike system and the federal audits
that we deal with so and you can see by
the by the funding charts there that
essentially you know we've tried to hold
level um from fy2 adjusted authorized
through the budget all those funding
levels and uh again most of the
operations uh costs here are um are part
of the highway
fund on slide 10
represents um the division of uh policy
and
administration and their roles and
responsibilities are highlighted there
on the right um this this division
comprises um a federal compliance office
Human Resources uh as well as public
information and the um executive office
as as well so um budget targets were met
through uh eliminating temporary
full-time position as well as reducing
budgeted overtime time and temporary
help um one of the budget implications
and you see with the um permanent
position count in the bottom right hand
corner has been some realignment of
personnel and you'll see some reductions
in other divisions one of the things we
did was put a emphasis on on safety and
made the safety uh section a direct
report to the commission's office to the
chief engineer um and have a cross
divisional focus on all things safety so
realigning the safety section does um
within this budget reflect in the in the
positions and some of the funding but
it's offset by reductions where those
positions were moved from for net um
zero
increase
um and uh you know some of the factors
again
we you know where HR is under this
division they continue to deal with
recruit and retention and and and trying
to address our overall vacancy agency a
vacancy rate of upwards of 24%
um and um you know we have really
focused on that some of our
accomplishments in this division have
been focused on implementing a CDL
training program to help our uh Highway
maintainers and help um retain some of
those positions uh implementing an
enhanced training program leveraging
federal funds and working with major
stakeholders within within the
department to um design a robust uh
employee retention
program the uh following slide slide 11
describes uh the uh division of project
development that division uh comprises
all of the design bureaus and all of the
bureaus that support administering the
Federal Aid highway program in our
Capital program um it's about 385 total
positions currently um that offset and
permanent positions in the lower right
um represents again that's where the
safety sections positions came from that
were um at least within within the
budget and the reporting structure were
shifted to report to the um um uh
executive
office some of the implications with
trying to uh meet the budget the targets
here were um an overall reduction of
about 12 positions three permanent
full-time and nine temporary full-time
positions uh the federal aid um program
funding levels have been held uh to
currently anticipated levels and again I
just reiterate that a lot of those
funding levels and priorities and
constraints are addressed and um
considered more fully through the 10year
plan development process and the off
budg
years um and I've mentioned the safety
section but um a couple of the budget
implications with with uh with this
division um is you know we have relied
more and more on Direct funding of uh
Federal reimbursements and and
leveraging as much Federal program um
funding as we can to support the
operational costs it does come at a
reduction of um funds that we are able
to put toward construction projects but
um we are um looking in both direct
funding bureaus um that that that
participate in in and support those
Federal programs as well as maximizing
our indirect costs and billing to the
federal program um to help um bolster
and support and meet budget targets um
but it does come at the expense of
having less Federal that goes towards um
needed
projects and um partly because of that
and partly because of the um the vacancy
rates and the difficulties hiring
particularly Engineers we do have a very
heavy Reliance on consultant support to
deliver the program and
um and and in the long run I believe
that that that does um you know probably
present higher costs than if we could do
it internally but
um um we do rely very heavily on
consultant engineering costs to deliver
the program the uh the last budget
implication there I wanted to highlight
there was uh SB 367 that was in 2014 a
4.2 Cent um um increase in the gas tax
that was dedicated to um completing the
i93 project for the last nine years
we've enjoyed the revenue from that to
put towards Highway and Bridge projects
um based on the structure of the
financing that went in there in FY 26 uh
that Revenue um get shifted to pay the
full Debt Service on the uh tifia loan
that we took out to complete the i93
project so in this budget while the S SP
367 funding Remains the Same the revenue
Remains the Same it is now shifted from
um Highway and Bridge work to paying
Debt Service so it is a um again as we
get into the 10year plan in the next
cycle it is a uh whole in um active work
that we will have to look to to fill
likely with with federal funds at the
expense of something
else um so that's a very uh high level
uh summary of project development um but
the funding for the construction
programs again are reflected in the
10-year plan we continue to um R very
heavily on the federal funds we put very
little State funding toward um toward
the construction program um we rely
exclusively on Turnpike toll credits to
match the federal dollars um we have
been uh fortunate enough to be able to
meet those match requirements but it
does come at the expense of of uh less
um less funding that goes towards actual
projects um and again the significant
vacancy rate but despite those
challenges like I said I do like to
emphasize that we are getting a lot of
good things done uh last year uh this
the You know despite the challenges um
we advertised a construction program of
over $350 million of uh contract value
um and that includes obligating and
utilizing um you know $33 million of
additional federal funds that that that
came um you know at the last minute in
the federal fiscal year through process
called redistribution so we do continue
to leverage um every F Federal dollar we
can and maximize its
use I'm trying to be cognizant of of of
of time and and moving through this
fairly quickly um even though we are
into operational cost uh the last the
vision um that I'll get to is our
Operations Division which is the biggest
division um uh within the department
relies very heavily on the highway fund
so on page 12 I just wanted to give a
few facts and overview about the highway
fund which is the primary source of of
um Department operating um cost revenue
revenue to the highway fund comes from
the gas tax the road toll and also
registration fees and it's collected by
the department of safety so a lot of
times we get asked about the highway
fund and the health of the highway fund
but um um you know we are we the do only
has a a part of it the highway fund is
not the do and the do is not the highway
fund as I pointed out we leverage um
several other uh uh funding uh sources
in our overall budget um and the revenue
from the highway fund is appropriated to
various agencies um primarily Department
of Transportation and safety but there
are other um um um agencies that that do
have incremental draws on the highway
Fund in 2024 the the percentages uh are
there do Drew about 57% from the highway
fund other agencies again primarily
Department of Safety was about 30% and
uh about 133% uh from the block grant
Aid uh and and uh uh you know went to
municipalities so that's a very
highlevel summary of the uh distribution
of the highway fund um but again I'd
emphasize that Highway funds are the
Dot's primary source of funding for
operations um Revenue into the highway
fund has been generally flat that's
reflected in our budget targets and it's
incrementally um we we project it to be
inter incrementally declining over the
long term and um I think the highway
fund also you know has a long history of
of one-time fixes to um address the
structural deficit with within the
highway fund onetime fixes or general
fund infusions have uh been common place
in the past in order to shore up the
highway fund and and meet and meet
budget
requirements um
within and this last this next slide
slide 13 is a little bit of a departure
from the high from the highway fund but
it represents uh a little bit of an
overview of the turnpike fund the
turnpike Bureau um is uh within the
department uh and and under the division
of operations but the the turnpike
system and the Turnpike fund is an
Enterprise System uh supported directly
by the tolls that that are collected on
that um so it's a little bit of a unique
uh uh piece of the department the three
turnpikes are reflected there that that
system represents about 89 miles 172
Bridges seven toll plazas and it's an
enter an Enterprise fund so that all
Turnpike Revenue um you know must be
used on the on the turnpike system and
the Turnpike system is um really the
waterfall is set up to pay Turnpike
Revenue first pays for The Debt Service
on any bonds that are outstanding pay
the operation and maintenance um we're
required to uh fund uh Rehabilitation
and restoration work to keep the
turnpike system in good working order
and and and after all of those other
needs are addressed any any additional
goes toward um any Capital
Improvements um the overall um quick
summary of Turnpike revenue is is listed
there for FY 24 um projected budgeting
uh Turnpike revenue is is uh uh
generally flat
targets um and we did take reductions
through through through covid
um so operationally we continue to make
progress on the turnike system the
biggest impact with the turn bike system
is with the capital program that as um
revenues are are not increasing as as
quickly as as costs are increasing and
with level um budgeting targets
um um you know we find capital capital
projects tend to be at at risk so um
revenue is generally flat costs are
going up and as a result capital
projects um you know keep getting
getting shifted probably more of a
discussion at the at the 10-year plan um
uh next year but um it it is a um it is
an issue within the turnpike
program so that's a very quick overview
of the turnike system the last division
is is the Department's largest uh
division it's the division of operations
uh there they that division comprises uh
currently um um approximately uh
1155 positions uh uh distributed
Statewide to take care of all the bridge
maintenance all the Highway Maintenance
all of the all of the winter maintenance
that that goes on and um as well as the
Operational Support bureaus so to meet
budget targets within this division uh
we ended up um looking at a reduction of
about five positions three permanent
positions two full-time positions
and um just some of the indications that
uh
we uh believe we are underfunding winter
maintenance that is intentional that has
been the approach in the past number of
years to um our our goal would be
typically to budget to a a a three-year
average um but historically we have to
meet budget implications have have uh
budgeted optimistically for winter and
if um actual costs go up we've gone back
um for um to the fiscal committee for
for discret uh transfers but um we
believe we're we're underfunding winter
maintenance in this budget by about $1
million we'll have to see depending on
the severity of the winter if that um if
that
um
transpires uh we have all we're also
underfunding underfunding what we
believe would be needed for
Fleet replacements for um for vehicle
Replacements typically we would Budget
on a 10 to 12 year replacement cycle um
of the overall um of the overall Fleet
um we've made a lot of progress over the
last several years in in in uh
addressing some of the Deferred
maintenance in the fleet but to meet
these budget targets uh again we we
would have to underfund or or cut or not
fund um Fleet replacement at the um
at the recommended uh replacement cycle
or
interval um so some of the budget
implications last year instead of
leasing um loader and back hose um
through the governor and Council we were
um requested or or required to purchase
them instead of um leasing them so we
see some shifting of cost between lease
lease lines and and equipment purchase
lines um and we also have a growing
backlog in The Salted well program
salted well program um has been level
funded for a number of years but again
um costs of replacing people's Wells
that are uh um impacted by Road salts
have have gone gone up so we can do
fewer every every year and uh we do have
a a growing backlog but um we have level
funded that program again in this budget
um is issues with the fleet as I said as
as uh if we do not fully fund the um on
the recommended replacement cycle we end
up with uh increased maintenance costs
and and an and an older Fleet and
deferred maintenance that that
potentially costs fund uh cost more in
the long run um and one of the factors
that we continue to have on the on the
Highway Maintenance side is uh again
continuing ongoing vacancies um winter
maintenance we have had a uh program to
um incentivize people to volunteer and
do winter maintenance but uh a lot of it
is Shifting people that would be doing
other things so um we are prioritizing
you know winter maintenance and and
health and safety but it comes at the
expense of some other other
activities um
but with that said uh and despite those
challenges we still are getting a lot of
of good things done in the Operations
Division um um we have in the past um
year looked at developing and
implementing an electronic permitting
system that's fully deployed and being
utilized now so hopefully we'll have
better service and better tracking of of
status of of permits and things um and
over the last bium uh especially in the
last year uh the number of uh emergency
events that operations folks have have
responded to putting roads back together
in the Sea Coast with storms last winter
and uh wash UPS wash outs especially
this North uh this uh this summer up
north um we looked at emergency repairs
to around you know 70 70 79 locations
over three declared storm events
um and again if you look at the budget
lines uh holding the line to a um very
level funded Lev funded um
budget so that's a a very brief overview
my concluding slide just a summarize
we've uh in order to meet budget targets
we've looked at uh eliminating seven
permanent positions nine temporary
full-time positions um our priorities
continue to be safety and core
responsibilities preservation and
maintenance first and foremost um we've
met budget targets but in many cases I
don't know if we are budgeting for what
we um truly need um you know we find
deferring some of the maintenance um
could lead to increasing costs in in the
future and uh potentially service levels
being being impacted uh we continue to
have Workforce challenges and high
vacancy rates and it can be a
double-edged sword some of those vacancy
rates have have allowed us to meet uh
projected lapses and given us some um
you know flexibility in terms of meeting
budget needs but uh it also somewhat
masks some of the cost increases because
they've been buffered by lack of
resources to do the work we aren't
getting as much work done because we
don't have as many people to get the
work done that we would like to do that
we really should be getting done and uh
I would just lastly summarize that we
are successful because we have an
exceptionally dedicated and committed
Workforce um Everybody across it
Department takes great pride in the
stewardship of the transportation system
that we're responsible for and I think
in summary we are getting done what we
have to do but um maybe not getting done
all that we should be
doing um and with that I'll take any any
um any thoughts or questions
or good thank you things you have uh
clearly you you do significantly more uh
than I'm about to talk about but I I
think your department is is judged
publicly at least on how many potholes
you fill in the summer and how much
plowing you do in the winter and I know
that hasn't been easy in fact you
touched on it in the supplemental pay
for for some of the the plow drivers uh
and I think the the reason for that is
there was a there's been a demand in a
scarcity of CDL licenses and that are
available to you uh I I know when that
program was put into place the thought
was it was going to be temporary because
it was during Co and things would return
to normal but they really my
understanding is haven't uh is this the
new Norm now where these supplemental
payments are going to be into perpetuity
or do you see and I'm really asking you
to forecast a little bit but that the
CDL problem easing up at some time in
the not too distant
future I I I I it I don't I don't know I
do think it tends to be more of the um
more of the new normal um I my question
and we've had this introspective
question ourselves is so this is the
third year that we're we're on um um the
volunteer track in the um retention
incentive bonus to get people to um
volunteer to fill out some of those
vacancies um my question our internal
question is that's sustainable over the
long
run um I will note since you brought up
we we had thought about and and you know
whether we would you know budget in the
spanian permanently that's part of the
winter maintenance underfunded we didn't
we haven't budgeted the um incentive
retention bonus um we'll have to take it
on a year-by-year basis and and look at
it CDL shortage is uh and CDL driver
shortage is is one of the issues I think
one of the other issues that that we
find is is um competitiveness and in in
in wages from what we pay compared to
what municipalities and others are are
ability to pay so it's it's CDL um
shortages and we're we're trying to
address that through our own um um CDL
training
program but I think it it's also uh
competitive wages that contribute to it
as
well and the positions you're UNF
funding they're currently unfilled
positions correct okay thank you
yes representative
uh years ago when I was attached to FEMA
in the military I remember going to a
conference where it was stated that if
you had three kind of low snow years in
a row that the contractors that we rely
on to fill in for
plowing when they were replacing their
trucks on a three or four year basis
they wouldn't after three years of no
very little snow wouldn't put the extra
frame on H to mount the plow and they
wouldn't you know so we almost have to
pray for snow every third or fourth
winter so that they'll be hired
otherwise they're going to say no I
didn't hav haven't made any money the
last three years and it cost me money to
put on this extra thing in in gasoline
and and an installation cost so I have
fear that we may be looking for some of
that in the future that you know that if
three or four years go by with not much
plowing that we we have a a reduction in
the number of contractors willing to put
on a plow yeah we do have we we do have
challenges not not because of lack of
plowing or lack of snow in the last few
Winters uh you know part of the industry
is uh you know hired plows are harder
and harder to harder to find a lot of
the long-term family run um companies
that we have t tended to work with over
time they're um um you know the their
kids and stuff aren't aren't taking over
the country it's some of them are raging
out um a lot of the construction
companies that we did deal with they
don't want to plow and and you know have
have the wear and tear on their
equipment that that that winter plowing
and stuff see so it is it is a challenge
uh we have had some rate increases in
the last bium I I do have a note there
was a note in the on that slide on
operations that we may have to look at
to we we may have to look at another
rate increase for the hired plows to you
know continue to um entice them to come
work for
us but I do want to congratulate you on
how good our roads look compared with
other states I might drive in and lately
in my area the the striping has all been
done looks good so thank you very much
you've uh managed to adapt very well to
the challenges thank you thank
you hey hi how are you good um have a
couple things one can you talk a little
bit about the impact of eliminating the
state match for transit services and
which transit services we're talking
about it's it's not like conquered coach
but it's the is it the
regional who are we eliminating in the
match for uh it's a it's a lot of the uh
and Andre I don't know if you want to
come up and help it's a lot of the um
small Municipal um transit services like
Coast like um uh conquered Area Transit
um like Advanced Transit up in uh the
levanon area um U Manchester Transit um
Nash Transit that that provide those um
transit services typically uh federal
federal funds match 50% of the operating
cost um and the agencies make up the
other half we have traditionally funded
a very small amount of of that match um
FTA funds have increased they increased
through um through some of the emergency
relief funds but also through the
transportation Bill uh part of the um
justification or or backup uh that
um uh warranted or looked at the
increase State match was
to um offset or to keep Pace with the
increasing um FTA federal funds but yeah
the the only thing I'd add uh is that we
we do address it in the letter um that
that prefaces this book is that uh
unfortunately you know Aviation Rail and
Transit all those
bureaus they suffer from from what we
call in here the tyranny of small budget
numbers which is they are so lean
there's no fat in those bureaus um and
positions are all one deep um that
any any cut across the board for General
funds to those bureaus necessarily will
either result in the elimination of a
position that runs a
program or
the really uh big reduction in a
program that is run by one of those
positions so it it's a zero sum question
when it comes to that now
unfortunately the only place we had to
give in in uh Transit was that state
match um we don't want to uh it's
certainly not a a an optimal situation
and it is very likely to result in in
rather extreme uh reductions in Services
by those Transit providers if this would
continue through the budget process and
be approved it is a non-optimal solution
but but it's the only way we can meet
our targets I I like the phrase tyranny
of small budget numbers I think that for
people who are aware of the difficulty
sometimes with across the board cuts um
it's it's a great expression that helps
explain that um so a couple other things
I want to I'm going to ignore CDL for
the time being um so we passed the
highway fund law in something like
2008 but don't hold me to that where
something like 70% of the highway fund
is required to go to Dot did that has
that law changed or is that
still is that still in effect and is
year 57 and the 13 to municipalities how
you get to
70 or do you know if that loss is still
in
effect yes that's likely to be the case
the the dollars that go directly to do
57% municipalities through do would be
13% and to to hit that that 70% law they
count both of those as
Transportation that's my understanding
okay good thank you that's very helpful
to me um the Tiffy alone funding shift
yes I mean you know I think we've all
seen this coming
for every two-year gimmick for 20 years
comes to an end um and this is the one
coming to an end what's the rough value
of
that all to the construction program
yeah rough value it's about $20 million
of um that's the whole 20 what 23 is the
the payment every year 23 is the payment
to to date we've been paying about one
to two% of of uh interest of interest
but now it's full Debt Service so
roughly it's $20 million that had in the
last nine years been going to uh roads
and bridges that will now be going to
Debt Service and is that is that
literally I mean one for one like last
year was two and this year it's 23 to
Deb service okay yes yeah I mean I
remember when when they did it was like
the it's like when we bought the bridge
right for 100 million and they were
going to do 10 million a year and they
did it all in two years yeah um yes I
got a great that's one of those one time
or or yeah one time things to balance
the highway fund yeah can I just say I
got a great column out of that and
George Campbell stopped talking to me
for the rest of my life which was which
was okay too um Turnpike toll credits
yes um there's always been discussion
about whether that whether that's legit
or not and isn't there always some worry
that the feds at some point are going to
not allow us to use toll credits as our
match one of the I think that's in
that's instilled in federal law I think
the challenge we have is there is a
maintenance of of effort requirement
that that the investment in the turnpike
system has to keep growing in order to
claim that credit and uh as I implied
with with some of the stresses an
increase of costs and level Revenue our
our Capital program on the turnpike
system um is probably in Jeopardy which
means projecting ahead um we may not
have um toll credit to to
claim but right right right now
currently and in this bium there is
enough of a Turnpike toll credit balance
to match the federal program but
longterm if if we don't have a sustained
continued investment
in the in the turnpike
system that's the Benchmark that's the
criteria for able
to in order for claiming that credit so
if we don't have a sustained investment
in the turnpike system we may not be
able to claim credit down the road so if
the spend goes down we literally have
fewer credits yes or none or none it it
the the formula is as the commissioner
said increasing so it has there's a
threeyear average Rule and your current
year has to beat that in order to be
able to take any of the credits so to
give you some stats for last year um we
used $58 million of Turnpike toll
credits in 24 we earned 68 million of
which 45 was in the construction program
and 23 was in the renewal and
replacement program our balance
currently is 196 million of toll credits
so we have about 3 years okay
um that's good news um sort of sort of
um I want there's there's always some
thought about um you know the turnpike
system tends to
be in better the turnpike funding tends
to be in better shape than the highway
funding so to speak um and there's
always some question people have about
why don't we just merge it into one big
giant pool of cash and let me see if I
let me see if I say this right um
turnpikes are an island and they have to
be an island because the money we
borrow is not borrowed against General
obligation but is dedicated by Turnpike
Revenue so unless we started borrowing
the money differently Turnpike must
always be its own separate shoe box is
that fair yes that's fair right okay so
just in case anyone listening is
thinking why don't we just dump that
into that um your revenues in turn PS
when you know 24 is pretty good and 25
is is there's a dip I'm looking at the
slide on
page 13 I bet eyes um is that because 25
is as budgeted and 24 is actual yes do
we expect turnpik Revenue to be ballpark
what it was in
24 is yeah okay and then you don't
really expect it to go down much in 26
27 do you from from where we are today
not unless there's a
um another pandemic something so right
don't uh but I will say you know one of
the things that that doesn't uh that one
one of the factors that we've been
dealing with is that that dip from from
covid so you know a lot of our capital
and a lot of our um Turnpike fund was
based on on on higher projections so
while the re Vue has generally rebounded
to match around 2019 levels compared to
what we were projecting it it's a it's
it's kind of a it's kind of a decrease
compared to what the uh prior
projections were so there's been a
resetting which has
um you know which has you know altered
the overall Financial
Outlook okay um I'm not going to ask you
about vehicle replacement because I feel
like um you get enough of that from the
council
um unless unless you really want to talk
about you're probably good um but uh
winter maintenance um first of all um I
signed paperwork to let somebody do
winter maintenance for you today so
thank doing my part Dan Brennan if you
know Dan um and so um it's one guy but
still yeah every little bit right um so
we underbut and this is one of those
things where we oh doing again I'm too
close right sorry um we under budget
every year on the presumption that we'll
just go to fiscal and the money comes
out of what high highway Surplus correct
and I don't think anyone's done a
preliminary Surplus statement but what
if there isn't any money in Highway
Surplus then fiscal kind of can't give
it to you right that's
correct okay one of the other areas I
will say I mean with the vacancy rate
even even though it's indirectly you
know we don't have control over over
class 10 and class 60 the Personnel
costs those savings those lapses those
increased lapses do tend to flow into
the highway fund so particularly with
the with the with the um winter
maintenance um retention incentive bonus
um much of that in the past bium the
last two times we've kind of managed
that um through through the
laps so you're you're saying an average
winner is about $40
million you're underfunding it by 11 am
I is it overs simplistic to say so
you're funding 30 and if it's an average
winner you need 40 what's the range but
that you or is it between week
winter heavy
winter do you know I don't Dave do you
know off hand like ballpark I'm not
asking for we could check I I would
think ballpark I know we've had years as
high as 50 plus million dollars in a
probably a lean a lean year is in the
order of 33 or $34 million I do have
some numbers here um older numbers
showed in the high 20s almost 30 um and
some high years were like
45 so so it could be like down six up
six but not 10 or 12 right and we're
talking about you know this doesn't
account for significant cost increases
in that time frame too so and I would
say that 11 like I said I we we haven't
budgeted the um the um incentive um
retention bonus that that that does that
I've added that into that shortfall
anticipating that next year or the
preing years that we would still want to
do that to entice volunteers to to plow
for the winter and to make up those
deficits and deciding whe whether
Winter's average is not the same way the
ski are is deci side right it's not
about snowfall it's about
events is that fair like you got a plow
whether that's 2 in or eight right right
so sort of number of plow
days average isn't necessarily projected
we base it on on pass cost so we look at
the last three years of actual cost you
know and and and um average those last
three years to project ahead yeah I
don't think anyone wants you predicting
the
weather um thank you for indulging me
thank you
how much did you spend last year on
winter
maintenance you have that right in front
of
you it looks like close to 40 39 39.7
okay what you described last year as
average below
average I'd say it was
average thank you it was weak during the
middle of the during the during during
the middle of the season but uh I know
there were a number of storms at the end
of the season and and in March and stuff
so it kind of balanced out to an average
over the year yeah okay and one point
now we we look at it here in conquer and
stuff there's there's an awful lot of
the state north of uh north of north of
the notch that um winter starts a lot
earlier and and drags on longer and even
though there are uh less density in
terms of people there uh is there are a
lot more road miles to to maintain up
there so so while representative wer is
praying for snow because of the plow
issue you're going to be on the other
side praying against him yeah I'm not
praying for snow just pointing out that
you know but I I can remember some years
we've had a pretty good Surplus because
of very little snow and uh it it left us
more money for Paving so there's always
that to look forward to correct and I
think I'm not praying for snow I don't
do well in snow
I I might add we pray for snow we don't
pray for ice and and freezing rain and
we pray for snow from 7 to 3:30 there
not not for commuters but for because we
do that with class 10 and not with with
overtime ideally if we had the overtime
we'd pray for snow every night and we'd
plow it off for you in the morning and
wouldn't hold you up a
bit see no other questions I think
councelor gasis will we uh disappointed
not one question about 4 a
but thank you very much for your
testimony thank you all appreciate
it okay uh Department of information and
technology is up next please
good morning good morning
everyone make sure everybody gets a copy
um my name is Dennis goule I am the
commissioner for the Department of
information technology and with me today
is Rose Curry uh Director of Finance for
doit and and the person that keeps me
honest on budget stuff um you'll be
happy to know I'm not going to take you
through all of this detail but it's
there for you to absorb on your own time
if you wish um on the first page I'll
just highlight that um you know doit for
the state and Hampshire is a centralized
organization and it has been for um two
decades now um which is unusual if you
look around the country a lot of States
uh I get calls uh fairly regularly from
other states asking about centralization
how it works how you do it things like
that so so we are a bit unique in that
respect and and I think that's a good
thing uh going on to page two um just a
quick uh summary of us our strategic
plan as it exist today we're actually
working on the next iteration of that as
we speak and and a couple of the changes
that we're going to make and that that
full strategic plan is available online
at the department of our website so if
you Google New Hampshire Department of
Information Technology you'll be able to
see our full strategic plan as well as
all of the uh uh things that we're doing
with cyber security Etc uh a couple of
changes we're working on for for the
Strategic plan is one is to instead of
having cyber security as a pillar we're
going to weave it and privacy into
everything we do from a strategic
perspective the other thing we're going
to do is uh in our strategic objectives
for the next couple of years will be to
um better integrate our strategic and
operational
initiatives for uh agency uh into the
agency business initiatives in other
words continue the evolution of that
process that I've been doing for almost
10 years in New Hampshire so
far um moving on to page three um I'm
not going to take you through any of
this detail other than to highlight um
in the first sentence at the top of the
page the word dynamic is there and you
know I've been doing it for decades now
and one thing that uh continues is the
the pace of change in technology
continues to accelerate and um
particularly now with the artificial
intelligence the the pace of
acceleration is the the highest I've
ever seen in my career it it's part of
what makes my job fun but it also
creates a lot of challenge for us and
and uh and I'm sure uh you know for the
agencies as
well moving on to page four um cyber
security um I i' be remiss if I didn't
talk a little bit about cyber again I'm
not going to take you through all the
the details but the theme is um and if
anybody has has you know is old enough
to remember the Mad
Magazine um spy versus spy um so you
know I get better at cyber security and
the bad guys get better than me and then
I have to keep adjusting so uh that
really is what we're doing and we're
doing it almost on a daily basis uh one
of the things that we've made big
advances in is you know we connect um
it's you know to protect the state um
it's not just the executive branch I
have to look at we collaborate closely
with the other branches of government
and our constitutional offices as well
as we're advancing our our cyber
collaboration with cities towns and K
through 12s and County governments um
they matter as well both in terms of you
know protecting the the the folks that
we represent and that we serve U but
also protecting the state because we do
connect to these cities and towns and
schools and and so there is risk to the
state if a cyber incident happens there
so we're spending more effort um that's
largely funded by uh Grant monies both
through the homeland security as well as
the state and local cyber grant program
so onetime monies that could end
um but right now we're trying to make
the best of it with those monies that we
have uh moving on to page five
um budget
Trends um we we work closely uh this
this budget does not happen in a vacuum
uh particularly the the direct part of
the budget which I'll cover uh what that
means in a minute but um we do spend a
great deal of time working with the
agencies on on priorities and the way we
do it is um there in statute there's a
requirement that agencies do a Agency
information technology plan so we'll
work with them to develop their uh uh
agency level it strategic plans and what
we hope and expect is that their budget
request and their budget priorities
would map to their strategic initiatives
at the agency
level um the budget Trends are there for
you to read um I'll I'll highlight a
couple that are particularly annoying to
me but um but I'll say not a single one
of them Trends cost downwards for it
stuff uh you know the our our friends
are in the vendor Community have learned
that um that shorter equipment life
cycles are a good thing uh for them
because it we're required to be
compliant you know many of our funding
streams and and also our the fact that
we accept payment cards in in many parts
of the state require us to keep our
hardware and software in compliance if
if compliance life cycles shorten then
you know it it helps as a revenue driver
to these technology companies so we
don't appreciate it but it's a reality
of life that we're dealing with now and
um the other thing is is that shift from
sub from you know the traditional um
Capital expenditures to acquire
technology and then paying maintenance
to a subscription uh model which is also
um has cost pressures associated with
it now finally some numbers on page six
um so uh we we took the traditional
approach uh worked with um budget
director uh Jerry on this and and um so
you have your agency Direct in the Top
Line there which is uh 32 accounting
units that's really things that are
specific to that agency and from a
Target perspective the way we look at
that is the
agency is required to make their targets
overall um but we don't make unilateral
agency business priority decisions
inside those accounting units so so for
example you see that there's uh you'll
see later that a you know some of the
agencies actually increased their budget
lines there um we're assuming that they
decreased in other places inside their
own budgets so they could achieve their
uh
targets um also for the most part there
um uh all but um DHHS uh didn't have any
AP additional prioritized needs so
that's 6.2 million you see in in 26 and
seven uh in the 6.1 almost two in 27
those were that's all DHHS uh additional
prioritized needs
um so what we did strive to do is reach
our targets for the other accounting
units you see there Central IT services
it salaries and benefits and Statewide
Telecom and I'll go through um how we
did that um how we approached that at a
high level uh for the Central Services
that's a tough one so you see that we we
did achieve a reduction there uh that's
stuff that we're running today so so the
way we got there got to the the number
we're at there it was to to remove
anything new and really really um look
carefully at what we're currently
running and see if there's stuff that we
could actually stop doing there was very
little that that the state wasn't
already depending on so that's where
that was kind of the general approach we
took there for salaries and benefits we
um we simply unfunded all of the open
positions that we had to to get to that
reduction and then the Statewide Telecom
uh what we did is we we reduce the the
the spend on uh budgeted spend on
projects that we're going to be doing um
to and we got really close to the to the
Target and we Al you'll see at the in in
a later slide where we are with those
three accounting units with respect to
Target um moving on to
page
seven
um um this is more detail on um at the
top of the slide more detail on uh the
ins and outs of of how we uh approached
the uh how the budget planning and what
the impacts were so you can see agency
direct big increase um in the first year
26 and then an incre another increase
from 20 year-over-year to
27 um the other thing to to note um is
that the although there was a for
salaries and benefits we
we um were able to achieve a uh a
decrease in the first year of the banum
the structural things step increases
things like that pretty much eliminates
that that reduction for the second year
of the
bium and you can see over under Target
for at the bottom that in that graph so
we're just a little bit over what our
Target of of 4% was for this uh budget
proposal
moving on to page eight this kind of uh
this is we like to do this the rest of
this presentation by the by the way is
analysis so I'll just highlight points
but I'm not going to go through the
detail this analysis is the entire um
doit budget um done by class line so you
can kind of see what the impacts are and
as usual um the the main impacts are um
you know Hardware software Professional
Services and salaries and benefits
that's where the you know the big
hitters always are and um and again the
hardware and software increases and and
Professional Service increases were
driven more by the agency direct budgets
than the shared centralized budgets
because of the the decisions made inside
uh the direct budgets by agencies and
we'll again you'll be able to see some
of that detail later in the
presentation uh moving on to page nine
um again that's our summary for agency
direct U there underneath that table you
can see the kinds of things that are
being purchased inside there again
agency direct we look at as it's
specific to that agency it isn't
generally something that's shared across
agencies that that is normally in the in
our shared
budget um and at the bottom of the page
uh you see the additional prioritized
needs in in previous bium we'd have a
long list of these from various agencies
uh this this time it's just a list from
DHHS and um the and I will note that
they've since this was published they've
asked us to remove the first item there
the exadata maintenance so that item
we're going to ask to be removed so that
takes a six around six almost 7,26 and
68 in 27 out of the picture there for a
additional prioritized needs for for
DHHS
um moving on to page
10 um we this is an analysis we we find
valuable for ourselves I'm not I'm not
certain if it is for you but over 90% of
our budget uh is accounted for by a
pretty small number of agencies and you
can see that um even you know if you
could break it down even further we're
looking at um you know over 70% of the
top two agencies so so interesting
analysis there see how quickly it tails
off from you know the 55% that HHS
represents to the you know to the
corrections at the bottom
so I find that you know I was surprised
the first time Rose gave me that
analysis I was like wow I didn't realize
that how you know how quickly that fell
off like that um moving on to Central IT
services again it's just that's a
breakout so I'm not going to go over it
it's a it's a repeat of what we saw
um up above um but on the top of page 11
this does get there's a pretty
exhaustive list of what sits in there
and so a lot of what we're doing there
is unfancy stuff that the state needs to
run like you know keeping PCS running
running our help you know having uh help
desk software um Network infrastructure
all of that stuff so u i call that
hygiene because you don't get any credit
for doing it but if you don't do it for
example if the Network's down then
everybody's in trouble
so um and you can see that those um
Central IT services at the bottom Broken
Out by uh by class again and you can
kind of see where some of the uh some of
the um reduction amounts were were
achieved particularly on the on the
hardware
side um
and on the uh software
side page 12 is a continuation of
that um in the middle of page 12 the
additional prioritized needs are really
um the rent and and Charlie could
probably explain that better than us but
basically what we did Is We I think we
took rent at a at our current rate um in
in our uh efficiency budget and then the
the increases were put in additional
prioritized needs so it's relatively
small amount but that's why that's
there um salaries and benefits down
below um can see that um you know we
achieved a reduction in the first
year uh which was pretty much um
eliminated in the second year by
structural um things that step increases
Etc um the the narrative below that and
on the next page page 13 is really the
the uh different
organizations and suborganizations and
what they do inside the department of
Information Technology and on page 13 as
well there's an org chart with um
counts um just to be specific um there
are in this proposal there are 37
unfunded
positions um in doit and I believe in
the current by there were 10 so it
really is a net of 27 additional
positions unfunded um
for to that that represent these numbers
as you see
them again um the uh page 14 is detail
associated with
that and the bottom of page 14 is the
Telecom numbers and and you can see some
reductions uh achieved there in in the
our Telecom requested
appropriation and then finally on page
15 the um breakdown by class line of the
Telecom and
um U just on the back of page 16 uh just
a note that will be requesting the
removal of that exad dat maintenance for
DHHS is additional priority Iz needs and
that concludes my formal testimony and
I'm open to
questions thank you commissioner uh my
my question is I wonder if you could
explain a little bit how the
direct um budgets are or directs costs
are are are are derived uh I know
they're specific to the agency but are
they all at the request of the agency or
there some departments where you say
whether you know it or not you need this
par your department needs this program
and so we're going to assign it to you
well so I'll I'll take a step back from
from and then answer that question so if
you look at the agency class 27 um
budgets it's it's made up of multiple
Parts um there's the shared service
stuff that's what we drive so that
shared Service uh centralized services
that you see there as well as any of the
staff who are in the centralized service
those get allocated to the agency and
they don't really have a lot to say
about that the target
and what the um the legislature
appropriates drives what's that part of
their class 27 number and then there's
the other part of the class 27 number
which is is very discretionary for the
agency so the agency may say we may I'll
give you really simple ex uh example we
may say hey um we recommend you replace
this many PCs this year because we see
based on our inventory that you're you
know you're um end of lifing a bunch of
them they may and and we'll give them
that number and and they may say you
know what I'm going to since I don't
have feel like I have enough money and I
I want may want to buy fewer PCS so
that's kind of how the process goes
we'll say you have this many aging out
we recommend you replace this many the
agency may come back to us and it's
usually agency Finance people right
they're analyzing what we're doing and
they're saying all right no we don't
want to do that we'll do less than that
or they might say you know what
um for productivity reasons we want to
get like banking did this some years ago
we want to actually get more we we're
going to spend more on PCS we're going
to get laptops so that our field people
are more um effective so that that's a a
microcosm of how that gets developed now
uh in HHS since they have um you know
some pretty large and expensive
applications that's that's the high end
of that like if you look at um what's in
class 27 for H HS you'll see some pretty
large applications you'll see their
electronic business intelligence uh
implementation which is um you know has
all that you know information that
that's used and shared um there so um
does that adequately answer the question
yes it does um I was wondering speaking
of of HHS one of their larger it
expenses is their their Medicaid
management information system mmis is
that in here or is that in there the lot
hardly any of that's in in there that
sits in in a different accounting unit
inside the HHS budget thank you there's
is Staffing that supports it in in there
I have I think seven people that work
only on Medicaid in
doit and that's part of their direct
cost yes thank you it's it's part of
their let me clarify so I don't confuse
people I have one accounting unit for
salaries and benefits
um and that some of the roughly half of
those people are shared like me and and
my costs get allocated out across the
agencies and roughly the other half are
direct and their salaries and benefits
get build directly to the agency so in
that case that seven people I mentioned
for Medicaid get build directly to
HHS
representative thank
you um I appreciate all the improvements
you've made in and our functioning of
our state government through Information
Technology one of the things I I would
like to see further when they come in
with a project and say this is what we'd
like to add this new function is if we
come back with where will it save not
just perhaps a person but also their
computer their desk their chair I mean
those things ought to be added in this
space that we rent those things ought to
be added in into where will this
save and I I'd like to see some estimate
of that kind of thing which I don't
think we've done in the past we've just
said it should save but what I'd really
like to see and I amazed they haven't
come up with anything yet all this cyber
security and it it's almost a full-time
job just try to track all these attacks
what I'd love to see is somebody would
come up with a counter cyber and if they
do a Cyber attack on us we can do damage
back to them I wish somebody would would
invent that therefore there'd be a lot
of fewer cyber well actually I think if
you had top secret clearance I don't I
only have secret clearance for this job
because they don't they but if you had
top secret clearance I think you'd see
that we actually do do that at the the
federal level but uh the states don't do
that and um you know I I feel the same
way it aggravates me that we're spending
all this time and effort and you know
there isn't it doesn't feel like there's
enough of a deterrent yeah going going
to your first point sir um today mostly
what we're doing is not putting in new
systems we're replacing old ones so that
that efficiency that you talk about
where you say Hey you know I automated a
task um and now you know I should have
savings we're generally not seeing that
we're seeing uh the effort of like I'll
I'll you know my my friend Charlie up
there he and I get are together going to
an upgraded version of the um system
that you know New Hampshire 1 that we
run all our finances on and so we're not
actually getting any new things from
that what we're doing is keeping it in
compliance and and and keeping it so we
can run the same things we've always
been running and and um so that so but I
agree with you that um there um there
are some you know in the case where we
might be automating something that
hadn't previously been automated that
that should be something that's looked
at is in fact I know that um Department
of Revenue did that as part of their
um their um rims their rims
implementation which wasn't a new
implementation per se but the features
that they got with their new system did
um create um some efficiencies for them
thank you good luck on finding the
counter system thank
you I share representative Wilder's um
interest in attacking people who put
viruses on my computer um I have a
brother who works for the NSA I'm going
to call him and tell him about it and
he'll threaten to tell me what he does
so he has to kill me
um so uh he keeps wanting to tell me
because he has to kill me it's just not
fair um I have a couple of
questions your agency direct seven
agencies
92% do you do you have similar data for
the other
categories I me mentioned it's not like
that for the shared costs and all
that I not with you I don't understand
the question I'm sorry you have a chart
where you say for agency direct mhm 92%
of the costs are these seven agencies
what about non- agency
direct oh for Oh you mean for the shared
stuff yeah I wondered if you had that
I'd just be
curious oh you oh I see I see yeah no
but we'll produce that we can produce
that for you yeah no rush it's just it's
more more curiosity and no yeah no it
probably goes about the same way because
the um the way most of the allocations
are we have a whole bunch of allocation
methods but the most commonly used one
is by device count which relates to
people so it's probably pretty
similar um my understanding from
something you said earlier
is that you're allocated everywhere so
I'm paying your salary so next time we
have a argument I can say you work for
me indeed okay thank you I I'll look
forward to that um agency software
requests um every agency budget
everybody wants to buy a new piece of a
case management piece of software Fleet
Management piece of software tree
management software potato management
software
you have to approve all those
technically yes do they always
ask well um it's pretty good I'd have to
say we're pretty good I have a pretty
mature process I see those things coming
across my desk every day just
about and um and and now I'm at the
point where I actually know what they
are when they you know I remember in
2015 when I joined I had to go out and
research because I didn't know what was
going on and and now I kind of do so and
if I as things go along I will you know
if if something's almost a done deal and
it comes across my desk and and I'm
inclined to say no that's a terrible
time for me to say no because all the
work's already been done so what I try
to do is get in front of that and say
gee if this goes the way keeps going the
way it's going to going I'm probably
going to say
no uh because something's wrong whether
it's the technology direction or the
fact that I
don't think that the project will
succeed or whatever you know there's a
bunch of reasons why I might say no or
or I don't feel like it's adequately
protecting citizen data from a cyber or
privacy perspective um so we have pulled
procurements before uh not very often
but again that to me that's a bad
example it's an example of me getting in
late on my
opinion but uh but I'd like but you made
me think about Enterprise stuff so I'll
share an you piece of information there
is you know one of the things that we're
doing a lot of is trying not to buy you
if we have a case management standard
case management
software let's not buy case this case
management here and this case management
here and this case management there and
the big you know the big violator
historical violator for that obviously
was HHS they had multiple Case
Management Systems they've they've
really um up their game and they're
working on you know a standardized
approach using Salesforce for for that
type of stuff now and it's and there's U
there's quite a lot of discipline there
and and I and and when I see a case
management initiative coming down the
road and there's a procurement one of
the things I'll do is and what I'm
considering influencing it uh is I apply
what I call the principle of valid
uniqueness so all all humans want to be
unique right and so they're like well I
need to get this because I'm me you know
or we as an agency are unique and that
actually may be true but also may not be
true and it just may be human nature
driving that so I try to get involved in
that way and so most of the time we're
going to push people towards whatever we
think is a standard approach but
sometimes we will see that there's say
uh uh agriculture is a great example
there was they did a procurement for
what is essentially a case management
system for dogs cats and ferrets and um
like uh and
there was a niche player out there who
could come in at a at a good price very
fast time to value that was going to do
a better job than our standard so so
that's what we picked and and it was
very successful so that's a great
example of the principle of valid
uniqueness actually being applied in a
way that would go away from the
standard so that vendor sitting in the
cat bird seat um the
um what I let me tell you what I worry
about is you know HHS is a really big
organization can impose sort of a lot of
discipline on itself because they have
one of everything they got somebody who
does this and they got somebody who does
that and you usually have six of them
and the let's say you rank ordered
agencies by number of employees as you
get further and further and further down
the food chain they'll have fewer and
fewer dedicated let's just say it leads
right um they either have a shared it
lead or sort of a shared it lead I worry
about you know we have some something
like 24 agencies that have at least 40
45 employees or more and we have another
25 or so that have 1 2 4 6 nine I mean
the number of agencies that have single
digigit employees is
remarkable
and I don't they're not likely to be
talking to somebody about it and and
they they feel a need and they I'm not
saying they don't have a need but they
feel a need very strongly but they're
not talking to quote unquote their it Le
about it cuz probably in some cases they
don't realize they have an IT lead are
are you able to influence them to the
same extent that you can influence the
department of
safety mostly yes um and
the there's a lot of places where in the
state where there's a single person who
knows everything and if they ever retire
we're in trouble and and when you talk
about the small agencies that's
absolutely the case for for my
department I have one person who does 20
agencies and she's been around a long
time and knows everything that's going
on um amazingly so and um when she
retires we're going to be in trouble but
right now um you know I'm I'm able to
lean on her and she's able to keep me
updated on what's going on and if
there's something going bump in the
night like they're going to acquire
technology or they're
looking um in large part these small
agencies don't have the money to do
anything so um there isn't a lot going
on but when there is I feel like I I I
know what's going on and it does come
across my desk and the other thing
another Factor that's interesting is
that you know sometimes there's an
impetus to hey I can do it more
inexpensively if I do it this other way
except this other way doesn't you know
like I'll just I won't use a specific
example but I'll use use an example of
of a generic example of a a small agency
who has highly regulated and sensitive
data that feels they can do it less
expensive by having a server under a
desk in their
office um which we of course wouldn't
allow and and so when you when you
compareed doing it appropriately from a
security and a privacy and a protection
you know compliant protection of data
perspective what might if came out to
cost exactly the same as what we were
going to charge them to do that work so
so that's one of the things that happens
is it you know in a smaller environment
you may say hey this is too expensive
and I want to do it a different way but
when you're looking at our
responsibility for protecting data and
systems at layers on some cost for that
whether you were going out into a cloud
environment or you're putting it in our
data center that's a compliant Data
Center and so our data center over at 27
Hazen is compliant for all of the for
for payment card industry as well as the
federal compliant standards like um you
know like sieges for criminal justice
and IRS publication 1075 for Revenue
couple
examples but even little things like
people can buy I'm going to make
something up let's say just say
doorbells and put them on a building
they happen to sit in and without any
thinking about whether or not it
connects to the state system system but
yeah well that but in theory they should
tell you well you know that that has
happened you know that has happened and
you know it's an interesting
conversation when you say oh I want
something that's physically unprotected
to be on the state Network and that's a
hard
no but everything's on the network now
when you buy like uh folks who are used
to doing cameras right security cameras
they used to be on coax they go they
were totally not a risk to the state
Network at all and so we didn't worry
about it and now we worry about it big
time because the you know a camera a
solar panel on the on the roof of a
building uh HVAC systems they're all
connected to the
network I think there's a plot in
Battlestar Galactica where that
destroyed the world
right all right thank you all see no
other questions thank you very much your
testimony Take Care thank
you hey as I mentioned earlier the
treasury Department has been rescheduled
to 100 p.m. today so I'd like to invite
up next uh elip the land and Community
Heritage investment
program good morning good morning I'm
always happy to come and speak with you
as a I call myself a pallet cleanser
because elip does not use any general
funds so my name is Paula Belmore I am
the executive director of elip and as
you know since 2009 El Chip's grants
have been generated by a $25 search
charge which is assessed by our County
Registries of Deeds on certain documents
when they are
recorded I am very proud to report that
over its 24 years El Chip's 62 million
investment has um helped 204 of New
Hampshire's 2 35 communities and has
been matched by $332 million in funds
from other sources each Dollar lchip
invests in a community supports local
jobs enhances the local tax base
produces um tourism and Recreation jobs
and overall enhances the New Hampshire
experience for people who live here and
people who visit here however I am um
disappointed to report that despite
these impressive Returns the El chip SE
charge has never been increased since it
was first adopted in
2009 as a result in its first four years
the elip search charge generated on
average $ million a year for grant
funding in the last four years that
amount increased only 10% or 400,000
despite the real estate frenzy that
resulted from covid so as you can
imagine a 10% increase in funding is
well below the increases that we've seen
in real estate increases in construction
costs the things that were funding
what all of this means is that El Chip's
dollar is just not going as far as it
used to um as a result 44% of the
requests we received in the last 10
years went unfunded and those requests
are only a small sliver of the actual
need because the recipients know that
there's not enough money and so they are
being very selective about the requests
they're making so by any measure a 10%
increase in funds over 15 years is well
below what we need but those shortfalls
we are still working diligently to make
sure every single surcharge dollar
generated is sent out to the communities
in the form of Grants 96% of the money
that has been um generated by lchip has
gone straight back out either in the
form of Grants or has been invested in
our community conservation endowment
which supports long-term protection of
our
properties excuse me I have a bit of a
cold in fiscal year 22 we were proud to
be the first as is an interest tie into
your conversation um the first of the
state's conservation Grant programs that
move to an online Grant application and
management system we don't work with
doit because we're not a state agency
but we did work closely with other
agencies um for example Parks was
working um through lwcf on similar
programs we did consult with them and
use their guidance um and uh that that
program has brought great efficiencies
we didn't free up a desk but we did free
up a lot of file cabinet space um in
fiscal year 23 we prioritized getting
our grant money out more quickly into
the communities and um in order to get
those jobs going and of course we were
coming off of covid there had been a lot
of pent-up demand you know for
construction so that was certainly a
priority and in fiscal year 24 we looked
at what else was slowing down getting
the money out of our bank accounts and
out into the communities and we
front-loaded applicant um train in
technical support and education as a
result the average time between when we
actually make a grant award and when
that first check was put out in the mail
dropped from in 2021 13 months to just
over 6 months for our 2023 grantees so
it's significant
change looking ahead over the next four
to six years we are expecting to see a
pretty dramatic uptick and demands on
our program related to long-term
stewardship and so we're working very
closely with our grant recipients to
ensure that they are responsibly
stewarding the close to 400 properties
across the state that are now under our
oversight we are also very hopeful that
a more stable interest rate environment
or perhaps um a public that is becoming
more comfortable with current interest
rates will release some of the pent up
real estate demand from the past few
years and um result in a funding surge
for
elip in summary I'm very proud to
continue leading this program a program
that does not rely on general fund
dollars but is nonetheless very
committed to the efficient and
responsible investment of the Public's
monies thank you and I'm happy to answer
any
questions thank you I I think you may
have touched in this but in the chart
you have and the funds requested it was
it was
Rising uh steadily uh from 2017 uh
through the pandemic to 2021 then it's
fallen off since then right uh just a
little you mentioned that may they
believe that there's not funding
available so they don't request is there
any other thing behind that drop off in
in the funds request so there's a few
things that definitely um impact that
absolutely they are withholding or
holding back on their request we've
gotten much better at forecasting how
much money we'll have available so we
are sending out to applicants you know
this is how much we expect so for
example I think it was in April that we
started predicting we'd have 3.3 million
available this year and we're going to
come in right at 3.3 million so that has
um has dropped some of that uh but
there's also a real capacity issue
capacity amongst historic districts and
commissions to do the work a significant
problem with trades crafts people who
can do historic preservation so the
projects start kind of backing up and um
that that's a real slowdown for us and
then a capacity in the conservation
community in terms of being able to
raise the match that's required and and
carry out the conservation projects
oh go
ahead I was just going to remark when we
established this program all these 20
plus years ago we had envisioned that
well the first few years will be getting
the best places and after that it's
going to be trailing off to the ones
that were rejected in the past 20 years
so they really aren't worthy as much as
the first tranch of five or 10 years so
some of that is is
still prevalent in many of the minds of
the of the legislature that we've got
we've done the best projects what's left
that's really great so anyway that's a
comment thank certainly I think it's an
interesting perspective although I will
say this I think we are much better at
recognizing what's important our our
mission is more focused so if you look
at the second page of your handout
you'll see we we really are looking at
for example how can we help get
buildings like the Colonial Theater back
up and running producing revenues in
their communities producing jobs and
more maybe more importantly becoming
part of everyday life that's a priority
now so those that type of thinking has
changed although I will give you if I
ran the numbers I'm betting that the
average number of Acres we conserve each
year is probably
down perhaps in part due the Connecticut
Lakes Headwaters project which was early
game but
I just have a couple questions hi
um how were you funded before 2009 um
general fund Appropriations and then not
funded and um the the initial need was
estimated at at least 12 million a year
but I think they started the general
fund appropriation was around three 3.5
and went
up okay I just I was curious about that
um land um you don't inspect land that's
all Steve Walker or do you overlap at
all we we um we don't overlap so a few
of the projects that Steve watches over
may have received elip funding but we do
our own inspections and then work with
our own applicants so I forget what his
number is 150ish properties very few of
those overlap with ours those would be
the fishing game Properties or dncr
properties and and the old elip right
right which of course weren't funded by
El chip because no he makes that point
to me all the time and L chip aren't the
same thing yeah and I said to him once I
said I'm the only guy you'll ever talk
to who knows that he's he's waiting for
a call for me he wants to explain his
endowment to me so um you go ahead and
do that I uh I'll be okay
um you do inspection and I'm I'm sort of
getting at this you do inspections who
who holds the easement there's a mix
predominantly held by if if it's we're
talking about conservation land held by
land trust where so they are the primary
enforcement entity elip has a backup on
behalf of the state of right of
enforcement for historic properties elip
if we ended up trying to centralized is
the wrong word um find efficiencies
where the people who inspect you know
because the dncr and fishing game and
like there inspections happening you are
talking my language I there's there's a
real need for coordinating that that
oversight and stewardship also um the
way we handle things from
doj where all of these entities who are
doing very similar work are have
different attorneys and we all know that
the law is yeah and that's hard for the
applicants it's hard for the land owners
it's hard for the agencies and
authorities like me and there I have I'd
love to talk to you about that well I
just think a lot of people should talk
to each other and and we should there a
bunch of little things in state
government that because they're little
nobody cares about right and they're
like oh what would we say like 50 Grand
who cares and you're like well 50 Grand
is 50 Grand yeah um it's an Insight of
mine 50 Grand is 50 Grand you can write
that down um the uh the last thing I
swear um bosan so online last night I
noticed that bosin is selling their
Library have you seen this I have not
seen that so the old historic library
that they they and so there's somebody
online going hey you want to live in a
library and it's gorgeous right and it's
like 300 Grand or something I I have a
house and I can't afford two so I'm good
but
um I'll tell you a story in Hein they
have these two cute little buildings
that sit side by side one of them was a
grange another a chapel now one is a
library and they are working to turn the
other into Community Center and they
went out to the town and said Do you
want to build a new library so you have
more space we like no we love our little
library and so we're uh potentially F we
make our funding decisions Monday
potentially helping them do that but
libraries are interesting a lot of them
were donated and have to stay libraries
and so this is a this is that kind of
thing where it hasn't been a library for
quite some time and the town has
struggled to to keep up with owning it
and uh and there'll be covenants
attached to it and you have to accept
them but it's you know it's a beautiful
building
some probably I was going to say
Georgian qualities but maybe not exactly
and um I just looked at it and I thought
you know maybe somebody's going to buy
it maybe not but I would hate for it to
fall apart and I thought somebody should
go in that who's like a you know it's
not big enough for a state agency
because it's it's a little old library
but right how big your staff I think um
I think it's in New Boston they're
talking about repurposing a building
where they don't have room to go to full
full day kindergarten so they're oh it's
a fire station and they're going to move
to the new five like we could turn that
into a preschool or you know sometimes
there's some overflow needs in a town
for something else parks and wreck a
great one to move into a standalone
building so I'm just saying if you
currently rent space you might goog go
BOS
one thank
you thank you very much thank
you okay like to invite up now the uh
cdfa Community Development Finance
Authority
thank executive director of cdfa and Ian
Hart the CFO of cdfa thanks for the
opportunity to address you regarding our
oneline item in State Treasury
departments budget for fiscal years 26
and 27 which is New Hampshire's required
match for administration of the federal
Community Development block grant or
cdbg program the Community Development
Finance Authority is a state chartered
independent non profit organization and
as such our board is appointed by the
governor and Council as a state
Authority we are among a handful of
unique entities that work in partnership
with state and federal initiatives to
strengthen New Hampshire's community
Through the distribution of resources to
municipalities nonprofits and businesses
I'm here to request continued match
funding from the state of New Hampshire
the request of
$280,000 in fiscal year 26 and
$280,000 in FIS school year 27
represents the federally required match
funds towards program Administration for
the New Hampshire's annual allocation of
the cdbg
program for more than 20 years cdfa has
provided this service to the state with
great
efficiency the cdbg program is focused
on the development of viable sustainable
and Equitable communities by providing
housing suitable living environments and
expanding economic opportunities PR
primar for low and moderate income
people in New Hampshire we are we are
focused on administering a program that
creates the greatest possibility of
community-driven impacts and adapts to
the needs of New Hampshire's communities
cdfa has awarded more than $24 million
in cdbg funds since 2003 these critical
resources have been deployed across the
state and had significant impact on
economic development Housing and
Community Development initiatives in the
past uh two years you'll see in your in
your folder there's a map that indicates
some of the projects and the program has
assisted
3,237 people and that's through either
direct Public Service which was an
activity that we administered during the
covid pandemic or public facility
improvements these are things such as
child care facilities um places for food
access Etc also created or retained 37
jobs rehabilitated or preserved 448
housing units and provided technical
assistance to 541 small businesses the
requested support will ensure New
Hampshire has continued access to the
millions of federal dollars that are
meeting these critical
needs the US Department of Housing and
Urban Development also know known as HUD
uses a formula to allocate its resources
we anticipate using this year's formula
that New Hampshire's total cdbg
allocation over the next two years will
be about $20
million this is for non-entitlement
communities so we administered the
balance of State program all eligible
New Hampshire municipalities and
Counties have the opportunity to access
up to 1.5 million dollar annually that's
resources that support affordable
housing public facility improvements and
economic development projects these
communities may also request emergency
and planning resources the projects
awarded are community-driven efforts
that local leaders and community members
say are necessary for their towns or
counties cdfa administers comp
competitive Grant rounds throughout the
years the year our staff conducts
extensive programmatic and financial
review of each applicant in addition
projects that meet all necessary
criteria are voted on by an independent
11 member Community Development advisory
committee and then confirmed by CD faa's
11 member board of directors all 22 of
these people who review and approve
these projects are appointed by the
governor and Council and they represent
various sectors and communities involved
across the state once our board
recommends funding the proposed awards
are sent to the executive Council who
reviews and approves each of the awards
federal funds as you know come with
significant requirements to ensure these
projects are successful cdfa
professional staff provide training and
technical assistance to meet these
Federal compliance requirements we offer
these Services through before the
application applies to the completion of
the project and the close out we work
closely with Partners to find Creative
Solutions and offer guidance on project
development as well as to ease the
burden of compliance and protect the
investment of the taxpayer dollars cdfa
respectfully requests that the state of
New Hampshire continue to provide the
federally required match funds totaling
$560,000 for two 2026 and 2027 State
fiscal years your support ensures
continued deployment of nearly $20
million of anticipated resources into
New Hampshire's communities for economic
velopment projects that are critical
thank you for considering your request
and we're happy to answer any
questions thank you very much I don't
have any questions from me but I just
wanted to First apologize I missed your
breakfast meeting yesterday I heard it
was very well Reed very well received
and it was a great presentation so oh
thank you very much any questions
commissioner I just want to confirm for
James that it was really quite well done
and very nice um and better food than we
normally get so so um I feel like when I
was in college there was a band or
something like that called cdbg that
people had on bumper stickers and I
every I I hear that all the time and I
think I don't know what it was but it's
hard to Google was there a band in the
80s called cdbg but um there was
ACDC no them I've I've heard of them I'm
not a complete conf uh Ian Hart CFO for
cdfa I think you're uh uh talking about
the club Punk Club in New York City CD
bgs so glad I could clear that
up wow thank you that's very helpful and
I will just note that um although I'm
very supportive of the work that the
cdfa does I will note that we tried to
hire Ian and he chose Katie instead and
I'm not bitter at
all I didn't even know that
so congratulations
I see no other questions thank you very
much for your testimony thank you so
much for having us and we are now in
recess until 1
p.m.
e
e e
good afternoon I think we're ready to
start the afternoon session um just a
scheduling note uh the treasury
Department was supposed to testify this
morning but due to a scheduling conflict
they couldn't so they've been moved to
this afternoon so uh we are going to be
pressed for time so uh just like all the
um presenters and and um committee
members to keep that in mind so I see
the treasurer is approaching the desk so
welcome good afternoon um members of the
committee uh father record um State
treasur Monica
mapelli and yes thank you for uh moving
the schedule um to this afternoon um so
I'll I'll um I just red distributed some
handouts so um I'm going to use the the
the hand out that put be put together
and also the budget book um will be
referencing both both do documents um so
um using the handout um um moving to uh
page two include submission uh included
that information for the benefit of of
the new Administration but um on page
three I'll just briefly cover uh the
structure of of the State Treasury um
that's yes on page three um so treasury
operations we are a treasure uh Central
Service Agency and so treasure
operations responsible for processing
and reconciling all the dispersements
and receipts um of the State uh also the
office of investment and debt management
um is responsible for the management um
and investment of all the operating
funds restrictive funds and trust funds
also responsible for the issuing of of
bonds and um bonds to fund capital
projects uh also the band of property
division um is part of our department
and uh the division is responsible for
um the oversight and the um managing the
unclaimed property program and um so
they uh collect and collect unclaimed
funds and return the funds to the rifle
owners um we also um as part of our um
our department we we managed um uh in
collaboration with the college tuitional
Savings Plan advisor commission we have
the daily oversight of the college
Savings Program and three scholarship
programs U so with that I'll move to the
next page and fourth P um page four has
the uh the organization chart of the
treasury we have 22 positions approved
positions five and classified and 17 uh
classified we currently have two
vacancies on page five I'll just start
with the uh overview of the of the
actual budget so so um we were able to
meet the governor's Target um the uh the
only difference between our department
and probably other agency says that we
had to separate that service uh the
state has made a commitment to pay that
service so we had to
um request that that was um not part of
um the reduction that was requested so
for the rest of our our budget we were
able to meet uh the Target that was um
requested by the
governor so um again on page five is uh
just uh briefly highlighting a few
points of the treasure operations in
that um in the budget book is page
10 and um the only um the only
difference uh with this budget is is
doing is is is proposing is we are
moving three positions from other
divisions to the treasury operations uh
Division and that's because of the anti
um some of um changes that we're
anticipating with um the upgrade of the
financial system so we are again
anticipating those changes and we we
would like to make those changes um in
this budget we also um respect
respectfully requested a uh one position
um and this is because we're we're going
to um we have plans to incorporate about
40 um trust and custodial accounts that
are currently handled off books um those
will be part of the um
implementation um of the of of the again
the the upgrade of the financial system
we have uh plans to inter incorporate
all those all those accounts in the
accounting system um so there um again
four about 40 accounts that are going to
uh be um added to the system and those
are about approximately 1,000
transactions um annually the um again
the request of this position was um was
uh considering the the the targeting uh
requested by the
governor on page uh on page six of the
handout um just briefly um I'm discuss
um um mentioning the distribution um to
municipalities uh we included in our
budget and that's on page 13 of the
budget book uh we included uh in our PRI
prioritized needs um the state revenue
sharing um to municipalities this still
in law is RS say 31- a and that's that's
the reason we includeed in our budget
with the last bayum this this this
portion of um of the law has been
suspended uh in House Bill too but we
include it in our budget uh we used the
budget for meon Room St distribution
that's still in in our in our county
unit and our in our in our department
but it's no longer budgeted but I just
want to mention that uh
briefly um moving on to page seven
that's um of the description of the
office of investment and debt management
and that's on page 25 of of the budget
book um this um this is is relates to
the administration of this office um
again due to um the just one more
highlight is two positions currently
approving cash receipts those are being
moved to the reconciliation unit under
the treasury Operations Division and
that again is is the plan is to start in
fisure
26 uh this um this part of the budget
also includes our debt service um and
that begins on page 27 of the budget
book so we have uh and the treasure we
house all the debt service that is paid
with General funds and um we include um
uh again all of De Service uh for the
state and also the Deb service for the
University C Hampshire they're both paid
with General funds um in general ofended
debt is
declining uh the way we structure our
debt is we pay approximately 60% of the
principal during the first 10 years and
the rest the other the other 40% uh
during the last 10 years and with that
allows us to have a decline in Deb
service however um during this time we
had to uh incorporate an additional
Capital appropriation that was approved
by the legislature this this this past
session uh in in that um that was an
additional 40 million in capital
Appropriations so um The Debt Service
beginning in Fisk year 27 um begins to
increase um due to that additional
appropriation so this Debt Service
includes again existant debt um that we
have and also it assumes that we will be
ising a roim 60% um not 60% approximate
60 million in bonds each
year uh regarding the um university
system we are making the assumption that
we will issue approximately 10 million
each year um this is just these are just
conservative uh conservative uh
projections of course we're not sure how
how much will get approved in the
capital budget but we typically build
those estimates in our projections of
debt service
and then um is on page 27 um page 20 n
actually page 29 we have the de service
of school Bill and a that's just being
paid off we have approximately five
years left um for that Bond and we're
just um budgeting for the existing Debt
Service on page 30 we have um The Debt
Service for the color um
community college system um they also
have um we're also just paying existing
debt there's no assumptions that we will
issue new debt they have an issue new
Deb in several years as a reason we're
not uh projecting we assuming that uh we
we will have um additional issues for
for the for the system however if that
changes we will have to adjust our our
estimates so that covered that service
and um I'll move on move now to um page
eight and that um just briefly discusses
the abandon property program um this
this this is on page 48 of your of the
budget
book and um this is this is just the
budget of the operating cost of the
division um that was um there were no
significant changes from prior years uh
we just um we were to meet the request
of the governor to maintain uh the
budget at the same level of as fisc year
25 on page uh 57 of the budget
book well we um we have the the budget
of the college servant advisory
commission there are two pieces that are
part of that um of that commission one
is uh it relates to the New Hampshire
excellence and higher education trust
fund a portion of that fund flows
through our budget
um we have the expenses the expenditures
of the the administerial costs of of the
commission and running the college SS
program and also the three scholarship
two scholarship programs um that are
part of um that trust
fund the other program under that um the
oversight of the commission and again we
have the overs sign of the treasury um I
am the trustee of of the color s uh plan
and because of that we we maintain that
administ we do some Administration on
behalf of the commission so we the other
program is the governor scholarship fund
and that's on page 58 of the budget
book um that program has been
historically funded with General funds
um that was the only program we had to
adjust in order to meet the governor's
budget we we in the past we have
received about 3 million in funding to
maintain that program this time uh we
are requesting 2.7 million to to
maintain that
program and the last page on the hand
out is uh page nine and and that uh
covers um we have the budget of the Ben
Thompson trust fund we have to um
distribute quarterly payments to the
beneficiary uh which is uh the univers
uh University of New Hampshire as a
beneficiary of this trust and we
distribute uh Cor payments to them we um
as part of this budget we are requesting
um we've been having conversation the
treasury has having conversations with
Department of Justice and the university
system to be able to um uh potentially
move those funds and that trust to be
under the oversight of the UNH
Foundation um so uh in order to to
proceed with that process um we will
have to uh repeal some of the laws the
law that requires a treasury to have
that trust and so we are um um
requesting that we include that in house
bill to to repeal the laws that
um currently related to the uh Ben thums
and Trust uh Fund in in in order to
continue our discussions and in the
process with Department of Justice to to
request and to to move that request a
petition of um deviation uh that the
courts will have to approve and if that
happens um then
um the court will decide how the fund is
going to be um managed but the plan will
be that the university uh um the UNH
foundation will manage that fund so
that's part of our discussion as part of
our proposal uh and that's what we're
asking uh in house
too um and on page nine I'm also
mentioning um the elip and the Community
Development uh block uh gr those are
just uh includ in our budget to
facilitate the Appropriations but I
believe um the agencies
those um um those agencies were able to
discuss their portion of the budget
earlier this
morning and those are just essentially
um we are just housing their
appropriation in our
budget um also the last piece couple of
requests that we are um suggesting house
bill to was the to um there two laws
that we're um requesting to to amend one
is that that we allow um is removing the
Restriction of having two assistant
treasurers um and that will allow me to
um uh reclassify uh a position that is a
classify that uh we would like to have
that as an classified position and the
other amendment is to abide the law that
will that that will assist state
agencies in meeting The Debt Service
obligation and to to allow those funds
to lapse in the second year of the vium
and not in the first year that's just to
facilitate um the the management of
service by state agencies treasure
usually has that in their foot in in the
budget footnote uh but agencies will
also benefit from that um the ability to
to lapse the funds in the in the second
year of the banum and that concludes my
presentation I U be happy to answer any
questions okay thank you uh just a a
real quick question here the you
mentioned that the debt service is
expected to increase in the next bium
and you mentioned the Men's prison
that's from the 40 Mill million doll
that was approved by the legislature for
that and it doesn't include anything the
other hundreds of millions that's going
to come because it hasn't obviously been
authorized yet that is correct we did
not assume any additional debt only the
40 million um that was already
authorized by the legislature okay thank
you so you have about a 10% increase
over the from 2004 to 2007 in the in the
general funded Debt Service um Line Is
It that's not entirely from the prison
right we are we borrowing more or
interest rates going up we're not it is
really it's really the addition
additional debt is has to do with that
additional 40 million it really is just
it's all that other than that it will
just we will again we've been assuming
that we will issue 60 million each year
and again because of the structure that
we have with our debt it typically
declines um so I again that's primarily
the reason for the increase and then it
will continue to increase after that
okay cool um two other questions
interest and um abandoned property
they're Revenue questions so we used to
get two or three million a year in
interest payments and we're get we got
94 million last year um thank you
because without that we might not have
made budget um well that and something
else um it's going to start declining
your your projections in in the budget
document or for decline in the 40 to 50
r range how confident are you in that
number and and I know it's cuz we have
all this giant arpa thing hanging over
our heads and we're starting to spend it
like it's going out of style um is that
number a fairly realistic number are you
conservative are
you guessing uh uh so that I think that
number was uh it was because of the time
when I was that you know I was um asked
to produce that
number the market is changing constantly
so in my confident I think what I can
say is I should probably update that
number like frequently just because the
market has changed significantly whether
it was uh you know the expectation that
the rate cuts are going to happen in you
know more quickly now it doesn't appear
that's going to be the case so all of
those changes um you know I weren't
incorporated then now I have to um again
my expectations I'll be updating those
those estimates regularly especially
every time the the the for meets to
understand again what that's H what is
happening and also how the market is
reacting to things so I'll be able to
update that all the way until the end of
the budget process do you think uh you
might have a update as soon as say the
end of the month I'm thinking when in
December I should be able to meet
there's really no additional projections
that the F Reserve produced this time so
um right now the market is up and down
so I think um mid December I should have
better numbers when again when the when
there's the next meeting how much of
that that is based on interest rate and
how much is based on the the spending
down the of all the money Taylor gave
us it really has
not um so so so both um both um arpa is
the spending is slow unless that changes
significantly over the next few months
then then then then I will have to
consider that but but right now what's
this the the cash balance is decreasing
because of the additional spending that
was approved in the last bium um so the
spending rate has increased there's no
doubt
um so again we're monitoring all that
and and trying to really estimate what's
happening but also seeing the spending
rate um again the change there's a
change for sure and then your your
cheats um the abandoned property numbers
are um projected for 25 at 22 million up
to 23 up to 26 um yet in 24 we were only
at like well let's call it 20 are we you
are expecting them to go up or we level
off it is possible goes up I mean those
numbers are again is is what we know
today we use a a 10e average to estimate
that and the you know I was mentioned
the the we know how much we have um
received in property but we don't know
as a portion that we liquidate uh at the
end of the three years that depends on
the the performance of the the Capital
Market so that's the piece that is
always available um and that has been an
average of about
four million over the last few years so
again if that changes drastically then
then obviously I will update those
numbers too but uh but again I think
those are those are pretty good numbers
I will think so yes okay good thank you
very
much you're welcome thank you very much
for your testimony thank
you like to call up now the uh
Department of Business and economic
Affairs and commissioner Caswell
good afternoon good
afternoon so I think I'll just give a
quick overview and or maybe of some of
the um issues that we deal with at ba
and then get into some
numbers um I often refer to this is
talking about ba without acronyms so we
are full of acronyms in our department
but um in order to get you know a little
bit more English speaking out um I went
through a couple of the key areas that
the funding that we have requested will
be funding over the coming by Anum uh we
do obviously a lot of work with local
businesses around the state uh both in
terms of technical support uh expansion
support I'm looking for opportunities
for recruitment uh for new businesses to
come into New Hampshire that really sort
of forms the basis of our Economic
Development activity um obviously we do
a good deal of marketing and promotion
that's the largest item within our
budget each year um it represents a
percentage of the meals and rentals tax
revenue that we then turn around and put
into a very specific and strategic
marketing strategy over a 2-year period
uh to drive tourism to the state and
ideally increase the amount of Revenue
that we see under meals and Rental
tax um we're also working on a couple of
items that are as I know we talking
exclusively about arpa today but there
are three programs that we have that are
relevant to the mission that are um are
being pursued under the arpa funding one
is the New Hampshire business Gateway uh
project which is an online digital
platform that will really change the way
businesses interface with the state
giving them an opportunity to work with
all our agencies at one in one location
um we're actually rolling out an early
version of that probably early next
month uh we expect that project uh at
least the component of the structure of
the new platform to be done by July of
next year um and I think and I and I
mentioned that because that does g to
that is going to have an impact on us
and our interaction with business
community but I think it also provides
an opportunity for efficiency gains in
other departments as we see uh the
ability to kind of keep enforcement up
the ability to uh make processing more
efficient and and and using existing
systems that they already have but to
make the whole uh interface a much more
uh pleasant experience for our business
Community but also uh I do believe
there'll be some benefit to the state
over the long period um also the housing
program that I know all of you are
familiar with the invest NH program um
we are more pretty much wrapping up the
Federal funded component of that program
um between this month and next month um
and uh uh those were I think those are
the main arpa programs we have
operational um we do International Trade
uh we have a whole team that's again
federally funded through the SBA uh that
works um literally on a daily basis
trying to find new markets and we've
seen those numbers and the trade numbers
in state go up each year over the last
six years I'm sorry the other big
program we have is the Broadband
expansion that's a that is partially an
arpa funded program but it's also funded
under the infrastructure legislation
that the Congress passed a number of
years ago um that's a significant number
we've uh We've pretty much spent down
the original arpa component of that
which was about $122
million um there is an additional pot of
funding that will come through what's
called The Bead
program um over the next year or so that
has a much longer time Horizon than arpa
but also aimed at completing the uh
fiber installations across the state
bringing high-speed internet uh to many
rural areas that are not currently
getting those speeds or any speed at
all um two other things worth noting um
we have uh the former office of planning
and development that had been at the
office of strategic initiatives that was
previously called the office of energy
and planning and before that the office
of strategic or no office of State
planning um when we uh when a
legislature set up a department of
energy all of the energy related
programming went to uh to them obviously
but the office of State planning came to
Bea um that has been a process of
integrating that activity and their
interaction with municipalities and
communities very heavily into our work
in Economic Development and promotion um
and one of the things that you'll see in
our request uh this year is more of a
technical request to just establish a
third division within ba where we put uh
both that planning operation but uh
added the the broadband and the housing
component under the new division of
planning and Community
Development and lastly um we do have a
team that that works under anou in
managing uh 12 welcome centers and rest
areas around the state uh for the
Department of
Transportation uh we have that team is
responsible for Staffing those centers
for maintaining those centers and for um
you know making them as uh getting them
to a point where we can um have a a very
uh a much more um um open um process for
those centers right now since Co it's
been very difficult to retain staff in
those centers and I think our team is
doing a good job at trying to um keep
them operational at least with staff uh
over the last two years and you'll see
that um among our prioritize needs were
two uh positions I believe three
positions within that Bureau of visitor
Services um which we can certainly
talk uh I mentioned the uh as far as
highlights go I I won't necessarily walk
through the entire handout that we have
here um but the uh the dpcd new division
um we are now also managing two state
funded programs under the housing uh
activity with dpcd uh moving to the
housing Champions program and a state
funded invest NH program those two right
now currently uh total about $15
million um we are just wrapping up the
first application around under housing
Champions this but tomorrow and um we'll
be launching this other state funded
invest NH program which is aimed at um
Municipal uh Municipal uh grants and
Loans um sometime in the next few weeks
so we're going to see a slow shift from
the federally funded arpa uh invest NH
component to these State programs um and
uh I think we've mentioned how we want
to get there in the
budget uh I'll reiterate uh on the
tourism side you there's a lot of work
that goes into uh into that activity um
both within our own staff but also with
our creative agencies our advertising
agencies that we work with uh these are
all done in very databased um strategic
initiatives uh with our team to
determine where the markets are that
we're seeing the biggest growth uh where
we want to try to grow those markets and
um how that is translating on the ground
here in New Hampshire with our industry
but also uring the re Revenue income
under meals and rentals I I I would add
another International component there is
that we have been seeing um or until
this year and the and the U exchange
rate an increase since covid in
international tourism space and so we
have had some focus on that over the
last uh over the last 18 months and we
do feel like that has had some benefit
to the industry particularly in the fall
season and um I can get into that but
those are the main areas that I just
wanted to talk about I expect there's
some questions and Kathy frederickson's
here with me from our business office to
try to get through any questions you
might have for us right thank you
commissioner uh quick question on on the
business community in in a tracking
businesses to New Hampshire what are the
major obstacles you find in in
attracting new businesses to New
Hampshire is is it is it taxes
regulation Workforce
housing um or um any any sort of
combination of those it kind of depends
on the business itself and what kind of
business it's in but I mean generically
speaking um I think businesses that are
looking to come here are looking at uh
the workforce that's available um and
how that's going how how competitive
they feel that they can be an attracting
Workforce and directly tied to that is
the housing piece so whether or not if
they're bringing people a lot of times
we might be recruiting a company to move
from one place to another um if that's
the case and they're bringing let's say
a 100 employees they need to be able to
know that there's going to be somewhere
for those employees to live if they're
bringing that many with them so uh I
would say those are the two main issues
that we really hear about the most um I
think the dedication that we have put
into into the housing issue over the
last couple of years has really created
much more attention and uh an
affirmation if you will from the state
on um how much they are willing to play
in that in that space on behalf of the
business
Community thank you and coming up with a
metric to um ascertain how tourism going
is going is is meals and rentals a
pretty good metric for that yes but I
would say that you know as much as I
would
I do harp on it in this forum I don't
think that we
necessarily um would lead with the goal
of our tourism promotion is to increase
tax revenue it is definitely a benefit
but really what we're trying to do is
promote an industry and the jobs that
come from that the tourism industry
Remains the second largest employer in
the state and it as you have seen over
the last couple years since Co has been
in a in a someone volatile State um
we've felt that the marketing that we're
able to do really supports that industry
and gives them the opportunity to focus
on uh what they need to be focused on
which is creating a good experience for
visitors that come to New Hampshire not
just because we want them to come back
but increasingly we want them to come
back and to live here and to open a
business or to take a job in one of our
uh in one of our own businesses here in
the state and we have seen some progress
under those under those banners
thank you my my two favorite categories
in in the revenue report are are the
other category in meals and rentals so
you've been doing a fantastic job on
both of those so on the on sorry the
meals and rentals so thank you very much
any other
questions commissioner I have a couple
um hi
hi um Economic Development contracted
expenditures go from about 7 million in
24 to about 113 in 25 carried to
26 um look at page 48 of the budget book
if you want
48 and I it's a big number that jumps
out tell me again where you're looking
Charlie H again which one are you
contracted expenditures toward the
bottom of the page on page 48
yes do we know what that is you know
what that is off top of yet I mean it's
not the travel and tourism contract
so that's where I started at the front
but I do know
thecr I'm gonna have to get back to you
on that commissioner I unless is an
increase in the office and Workforce
Development in terms of what the income
from federal yes in and additional
programs in oo so I guess what we're
seeing is that there was an increase in
our funding from Department of Labor for
the office of Workforce opportunity is
that what you're saying that explains
the increase oh oh wo okay oh wo oh whoo
do you like saying that I
don't okay so it's all federal pretty
much okay thank you that's actually very
helpful um the other question is when
when the agency was
created eight years ago just about um
the the vision was sort of One-Stop
shopping for businesses right that there
aren't multiple places in the state
government you have to go um I feel like
we're probably not at one stop have you
thought at all about places
that ought to be folded
in that aren't I mean I know there's a
council partner agencies and there's
that I would say that we the way that we
handle that is um yes the Council of
partner agencies is one tool that we
have but for example today going on
right now is a forum that we put on each
year with all of the various Partners
across the space of economic development
in New Hampshire so Regional development
corporations planning commissions um uh
individual municipal offices academic
institutions there's a lot of
organizations that engage in Economic
Development I don't think that it
necessarily would serve the state to try
to pull all of that into one house as a
formal entity but this department
whether it's me or whoever else runs it
going into the future it's extremely
important that those relationships and
those collaborations have to exist and
in fact it's demanded I mean when the
size of the budget here this is you look
at Economic Development agencies in
other states and they're just like these
big bahouth that tell everybody you know
we're going to do this we're going to do
that this is our plan this is how we're
going to accomplish this in New
Hampshire we do it in a much different
way where we have to work together to
accomplish the same goals and we end up
with very innovative solutions as a
result so I wouldn't necessarily change
that I would also say that uh the
digital platform that I mentioned is the
realization I think in a sort of virtual
way of that one stop that we've always
had in mind as we uh sort of establish
baa and once that's in in place I think
we'll really be able to demonstrate the
benefit of that and as I mentioned the
benefit is not exclusively to the to the
uh business businesses themselves the
benefit will be to the state and to the
state agencies that participate on the
platform what about um um I see it
happens because of where I sit I see
lots of people wandering into my
building every day and they're all
looking to register an LLC or register a
corporation they go to the Secretary of
State yeah
and is there decent integration there
and does your new platform help I know
they do a lot of stuff online now they
have they have a set of windows but they
still do a lot of stuff online yeah is
that are those things fully integrated
or will they be that was a critical
component of being able to move forward
with the whole concept really I mean
because until you can get the
organization that is has the
responsibility of uh establishing
businesses formally in the state um a
platform like this would be generally
useless so uh and that has been I think
part of the struggle in the past uh but
we've worked very closely with secretary
scanland and and they are full
participants in this initiative
oh good okay uh are there gopher I'm
asking you because you're not because
you're Bea but because you're the Gopher
guy
um are there gopher plans in the budget
I know we don't have a separate gopher
presentation um I think that um we're
going to need to address a couple of
things as it relates to gopher in the
budget um most of them are in terms of
the uh the end game for that entity
right so that is established by a
executive order U that Governor suu
established and then when we had the
arpa funds that he amended um we are as
many of you know shifting from an entity
that really focuses on the front side of
uh those programs and getting those
dollars out the door and in the proper
way and accounted for and you know all
that sort of thing and it is going to
shift more towards an entity that is
responsible for working with agencies
and awardees on completing those
projects within the time frames that are
required but also uh of working with us
Treasury and the compliance and the
auditing and the um accounting end of
the the back end of the business so I
think that that needs to probably be
addressed in the budget as to how the
state wants to um morph those functions
probably into existing
agencies and you me posted if it affects
me I will keep you very much informed
commission thank you very much for your
testimony you're
welcome up next uh is uh Department of
Natural and cultural resources
welcome commissioner welcome good
afternoon I am commissioner Sarah
Stewart de Department of Natural on
cultural resources and sitting next to
me is Chris Marino he oversees our
office of administration um as we
approach the holiday season I didn't
want to miss an opportunity to promote
our online store at nhst parks.org where
you can get all of your holiday shopping
done at once uh we have lots of of
wonderful New Hampshire gifts um for
everybody in your family with that would
you like me to make my Pres
presentation please do
wonderful thank you for having me here
today to discuss the Department of
Natural and cultural resources budget
request for the 2627 biennium I
appreciate the opportunity to share with
you the hard work our team has done to
craft a budget that reflects not only
our commitment to New Hampshire's
natural and cultural heritage but also
our dedication to efficiency and
collaboration across the
state dncr is a unique agency with a
broad mission one that serves the people
of New Hampshire in countless ways we're
the agency responsible for New
Hampshire's iconic state parks our
forest and lands historical resources
State library and even the Arts our goal
across all these areas is to protect
preserve and to promote what makes New
Hampshire special from keeping our state
beautiful to supporting a high quality
of life for our residents and attracting
visitors from all over the globe our
work touches every corner of this state
today I'm here to discuss a budget that
includes a 4% decrease in our general
fund allocation this reduction is
significant but through careful planning
and a commitment to getting the most out
of every dollar we are confident that we
can maintain the high standards expected
of the
dncr although we are a large agency only
177% of our funding comes from the
general fund which is approximately $1
million each year for the next two
fiscal years
the challenge we face and one we Embrace
is how to make every dollar of this
funding work as hard as possible for New
Hampshire the dncr is responsible for
managing more than
220,000 Acres of public land 870
buildings and an array of critical
infrastructure our team of nearly 1,000
employees maintains everything from fire
to towers and dams to septic systems and
hundreds of miles of roads and
snowmobile trails which are vital to New
Hampshire's outdoor recreation
economy this is a substantial portfolio
and I am proud to say that our team
meets these responsibilities with
resourcefulness commitment and
efficiency one area where dncr shines is
our Revenue generation New Hampshire
state parks for instance has become one
of the most efficient Park systems in
the country through Innovation and a
commitment to self-sufficiency we fully
fund park operations from the fees that
we collect we also then reinvest this
Revenue in other initiatives that
benefit the state from Federal grant
Administration like Land and Water
Conservation fund and other admin and
business functions to the preservation
of unique Scenic scientific historical
recreational recreational and natural
areas throughout the state this model
not only saves taxpayer dollars but also
enables us to maintain and expand
Services despite limited State
funding our division of forest and lands
is another example of resourcefulness
Timber harvesting and Nursery sales
generate vital Revenue that fund many of
our staff public programs and services
demand for seedlings remains robust
despite recent weather challenges which
is why we invested arpa money into a new
irrigation system and a large cooler to
ensure future Revenue
stability efficiency is the theme of
this budget to meet the demands of
increased outdoor recreation and a
growing interest in our state's natural
resources we are constantly looking for
ways to improve our operations and
collaborate within our own Agency for
instance we invested in a Statewide
Trail mapping tool with arpa with arpa
funds providing valuable public facing
information and enabling better tracking
of resources this tool supports informed
decision- making in one of the state's
fastest growing areas outdoor
recreation collaboration with other
agencies has also been key to our our
approach our recent partnership with the
Department of Justice to establish an
in-house legal council role is one
example this collaboration improves our
efficiency and strengthens cross agency
cooperation setting a foundation for
exploring similar efficiencies with
other
departments we believe this approach can
serve as a model for further
consolidating Services across the state
where do state agencies overlap with
specific constituencies like snowmobile
clubs Developers and even art
organizations at the dncr we make the
most of what we receive from the general
fund by leveraging $4 million of the 11
million we are seeking we will generate
Federal match dollars necessary to
maintain our budget's impact in the
cultural resources divisions we
strategically use the 4.2 million
allocated from the general fund to
maximize Federal uh maximize our federal
matches with we have up to 80% or 3.3
million going towards these matches this
helps us provide more grant
opportunities across New Hampshire
amplifying our reach even with limited
General
funding the New Hampshire State Library
building holds close to 500,000 books
Maps government documents and even some
rare and unusual Treasures these items
offer knowledge about New Hampshire's
history its people government and
culture and are accessible to all New
Hampshire residents and guests the State
library leverages close to 1.5 5 million
in federal funds to provide Library
services to more than 2,000 visually and
physically disabled New Hampshire
residents and to facilitate re
facilitate resource sharing between more
than 230 libraries from the largest to
the smallest in the state through an
inter Library Loan program that moves
more than 160,000 items annually
throughout the
state to further accommodate budget
constraints we propose moving the Bureau
of historic sites back Under the
Umbrella of the division of Parks and
Recreation rather than being supported
by the general fund this shift allows us
to support Historic Site management
sustainably while meeting general fund
reduction
requirements as we approach the 60th
anniversary of the state Council on the
Arts and the 90th anniversary of our
division of Parks and Recreation we
remain committed to preserving our
state's legac Legacy and ensuring these
resources Thrive for future Generations
thank you for allowing us to share our
plans and for your support of dnc's
mission I look forward to answering any
questions you may have about our
approach for maximizing efficiency and
collaboration in the Service of New
Hampshire thank you very much and I
greatly appreciate you uh the the sales
pitch for for your for your goods what
was the name of that site again nhst
parks.org okay we're appreciate the
revenue and know I actually have ordered
from that site so it's it's it's a
wonderful Service uh quick question on
on Canon Mountain uh the operation of
Canon Mountain has run into some
financial difficulties over the last few
years one of the main reasons I think is
because obviously with with the more
mild Winters we've had over the last few
years you've had to make snow that's
extremely expensive as you know and with
the forecast for this winter being
another mild one uh how confident are
you that you're going to be able to
reverse those financial trends at Canon
and get get back on the more positive
track a speak I'll take the first crack
at it and then I invite Chris Marino and
uh Brian Wilson who's um the head of our
Parks division uh so we just hired a new
general manager Jace worth um just
started he arrived here on the last day
of the ski season um in April and has
spent the summer managing francon and
notate park he comes to us from Colorado
um and has experienced running um
similar size ski mountains um he has
provided you know big because of the
timing that he started before the start
of ski season he has he has really
provided a lot of analysis um and you
know the old the old saying of well
that's we've always done it this way you
know that that doesn't work anymore um
and so I'm excited for this injection of
New Perspective and new energy you
mentioned uh snowmaking yeah snowmaking
is expensive um we were in a contract
for energy that was really high um we've
maneuvered out of that thanks to I think
our partners at Das um and and so that's
one way that we're um ensuring uh some
savings uh but I'm going to let uh Chris
and Brian piggy back off of
that uh excuse me good afternoon I'm
Brian Wilson the director of the
division of Parks and Recreation and
great great great question um all all
the whole ski industry is in New
Hampshire and the Northeast is going to
be uh you know continually challenged
with uh with what Mother Nature gives us
and doesn't give us uh a couple key
areas that Canon specifically is focused
in on is um continuing to Monitor and
enhance our snow making systems and
Technologies to make sure that that is
uh a refined well-oiled machine that uh
is is maintained and up toate um and um
a lot of that infrastructure Improvement
comes through uh the unique uh systems
that the state's created with uh
revenues and proceeds from Mount sunap
uh the least and those funds help
support the uh Capital infrastructure at
Canon Mountain so we're being very
strategic in the prioritization of our
capital projects uh over the last few
months we just got uh uh an approval for
uh some advancement in our snowmaking
system as well too for our main line uh
to make sure that that works another big
area is in um um using the best
available data in science uh for this uh
as as well too so for instance um we've
installed uh with a partnership with the
the Mount Washington weather Observatory
additional weather systems uh across the
mountain that are um that we are dialed
in at different uh um different areas
across uh francon Notch and across Canon
Mountain uh to um really precisely
measure uh what is called a wet bulb um
which is the the right formula between
the uh air temperature and um uh
moisture in the air to for for the best
snow making so we're we're looking at
that to help better strategize our daily
planning around where we're making snow
so as the commissioner said some of the
old ways of like well it's going to be
colder at the top of the mountain than
it is at the bottom of the mountain that
is not always the case um and we're
using this uh data uh for instance right
now today it's actually cooler at the
bottom of the mountain than it is at the
top of the mountain we're blowing snow
uh everywhere that we can um and also
we're taking a look at how we go through
you know the end of the season as well
too and and uh the end of last season we
made a a a decision to uh cut this what
we had projected about a week or two
shorter than uh the rest of the season
because we we felt we were hitting that
point of kind of diminishing returns uh
as it relates to our visitation and our
output of resources and then lastly the
utility cost is really the big big deal
um so that we were able to bring that
cost back down to in line with our kind
of 10-year trend of spending for utility
consumption the last couple years
the uh that contract was just
astronomically higher than it had been
which has really set us back but we feel
now that we're back in line with that
we're we're well on our way to hopefully
having a a good successful season but
those challenges are going to always
kind of remain at the uh Forefront
so I have a couple of questions hello hi
um uh before we leave Canon um
the the the parks fund pays for itself
obviously not every Park pays for itself
right the The Gardener Wayside has no
Revenue no yes not not yet it's lovely
though um but um where where are your
what are your biggest net money
makers uh The Flume uh is is uh and and
our kind of other ancillary site sites
at frankone not so frankone not state
park is our biggest Money Maker if you
combine the revenue from the ski operat
and all of the other three other three
season amenities whether it's the
campgrounds and The Flume um and uh the
Echo Lake Beach uh K Franconia Notch is
is by far the flagship in terms of
Revenue generation for the park and it's
important to note that all of those
things really tie together for four
seasons of recreational opportunity um
the winter Recreation and everything
else second to that would be the C Coast
uh and Hampton Beach and our in our
parking meter program uh generates now
over $3 million uh a year um some of our
other bigger Parks like Puckaway White
Lake um you know that have a combination
of day use and camping um our weekend
occupancy rate is uh um 86% uh um across
the whole season mostly every weekend in
uh over the from Memorial Day through
Labor Day we were above 95% occupancy at
our Campground so we're continuing to
see uh increases in visitation um both
in our dayuse and our in our campgrounds
is is Canon itself a net Money
Maker um generally the the ski account
that we managed within the park fund um
it it fluctuates so they they've had
good years they've had some not not so
good years and they've had some you know
some some balanced years there's also
been over history years where they were
good where they helped support the parks
that didn't have a good year and and
vice versa so that's part of the um the
magic of the park fund is a little bit
is that we have the ability to move
those resources around based on whatever
you know whatever it may be going on and
how much is sun and PE kicking in um
that that has been growing as well too
um I think now they're yeah it's over
$700,000 a year that that they're um
contributing to to not operationally
funded so that that just is going
towards capital
investment um and the capital investment
I mean I I organization like that needs
a lot of capital I'm sure um it's not
really creating efficiencies it's sort
of probably keeping up mostly with
deferred maintenance kind of issues uh
that that Capital you're referring to uh
yes yeah with with yeah at5 to $700,000
a clip that's that's more the Deferred
maintenance but nonetheless very very
important and crit critical elements yes
I wanted to ask about the Bureau of
historic sites moving
from I have a vague interest in historic
sites um maybe more than vague um but I
I I wonder if you could provide some
degree of assurance that um you're not
taking it from a place where it might
receive a lot of focus and putting it
into a place where it might not receive
as much focus and there might be
Financial
strapagiel um
because if you know if a bathroom at
Puckaway blows out we're going to make
that a priority if it's all under one
umbrella that said um during the covid
times when we had to cut back on the
budget we did what we're proposing and
it worked it worked well um we have um
we have only um expanded our investment
into these historic sites thankful for
the arpa allocations that we're able to
to do that but that has really jump
started a a lot of progress in that
Bureau um and and I'm confident um and
I'll let Brian speak as well I'm
confident that this shift um should not
be permanent um it should it should the
intention should be to return it to the
general fund as it was designed but for
now so we don't skip a beat and we don't
backtrack it's in a safe place under
parks and how many historic sites do we
have ballpark oh boy um I think there's
U 15 16 sites yeah okay but sites are
getting older every day Charlie so we
could be adding more that's why they're
historic yes I think just on that too I
just want to point to uh you know the
commissioner's remarks on efficiency as
well too so um what we what we find in
in in in the Bureau of historic sit
specifically is we've been doing a lot
of analysis of looking at our visitation
and when folks are coming so for for
instance we've been able to kind of
control our costs and in some cases
minimize Staffing in in areas by going
from a 7-Day a week open for business to
uh 3 to five days a week but um um
impressing we've actually seen
visitation numbers increase even though
we've we' we' reduced our hours through
through other components so we're still
seeing great visitation we're seeing
more visitation than we had before but
we're also making sure that we have some
controlled mechanisms to that and and
and the funding for the historic Bureau
isn't isn't really being touched it's
just the revenue to offset it is got to
is going to be coming from from the you
know the Pua ways and and and The Flume
uh places and things like that and last
but not least could you have Chris hold
up your ornaments and then describe what
the ones you have are I want to give him
something to
do
CHR no but I do want to remind everybody
again thank you it's the QVC hour at the
budget
hearings we have wonderful these are
locally made in New
Hampshire we're supporting local
business okay see nothing else thank you
very much for your testimony thank
you like to invite up the uh fish and
game
department and to the executive director
of the fish and game department I not
welcome you to the budget hearings but
welcome to the state of New Hampshire
good afternoon
members thank you for the welcome good
afternoon I'm step well for the record
I'm Stephanie simic the executive
director for New Hampshire fishing game
department um I'm going to apologize UPF
front I really wasn't sure what we
needed to prepare and I failed to bring
our goodies from our store from our
agency but please go online and check
out our store as well um kudos to dncr
for doing so it was a good QVC plug or
you can come to the department itself
yes yes you can please come visit
us um yeah so know be upfront uh I'm
literally Nine business days in on this
position and so um obviously being nine
days in I didn't participate in the
development of our budget um but I did
bring along our division our business
division Chief Kathy Lebon and our chief
of law enforcement um Colonel Kevin
Jordan these people were instrumental in
working with our former director in
developing our budget so rather than go
line by line through our budget I'd like
to just do a general introduction and
then uh if you have questions I'll turn
it over to Kathy she'll have a few
things to add but if you have questions
we could certainly uh have them answer
anything that you may uh want to have
more information on
uh again only nine days in but um our
agency is mandated to be the Guardians
of the state fish and wildlife and
Marine Resources our mission is to
conserve manage and protect these
resources their habitats and inform and
provide educational opportunities about
these resources to the public lastly we
are mandated to provide residents and
visitors to New Hampshire with
opportunities to use and appreciate the
diverse resources we have in New
Hampshire
these natural
resources enrich our lives support New
Hampshire's economy and well-being of
its
citizens as I'm sure you're aware we're
facing new challenges and increasing
pressure on our Fish Wildlife and Marine
Resources uh Across the Nation but
particularly here in New Hampshire we
have disease issues we have climate
change uh declining species populations
habitat changes which include land air
and water those are among the the
factors that must monitored studied and
managed to ensure sustainability of our
Fish Wildlife and Marine Resources for
their existence for all to enjoy and for
the enrichment of New Hampshire's
economy our core functions are primarily
funded by hunting and fishing license
though we serve a variety of
constituents uh we have built a strong
relationship well we built many strong
relationships with partnering agencies
and stakeholders uh this was Illustrated
actually recently in the completed final
report of the committee to study the
fish and game Department's funding and
partnership through those Partnerships
we've been able to leverage some of the
increasing demands but certainly not all
uh on average
70% um of the dedicated revenue for fish
and wildlife agencies in Northeastern
United States uh is generated through
license sales and federal grants the
remaining 30% is typically through
general fund or uh special sources such
as um permit fees or specialty stamps or
lotteries depending on the the
state my understanding is we operate on
about a 3.5% of our budget is general
fund uh fortunately for us in New
Hampshire at least the public interest
and desire for fish and wildlife and
Marine Resources continues to grow
unfortunately though uh the need and the
responsibilities and the cost of doing
business and the diversity of services
necessary to continue uh what we what we
do it continues to
increase as New Hampshire's population
increases so does the pressure on our
natural resources we have very skilled
and dedicated staff uh engaged in our
mission um they give everything they can
to uh manage the resources that they're
uh assigned to and to run this agency
efficiently I've been very impressed
just in the nine days that I've been
here these staff continue to think
outside of the box and be creative for
ways to improve our efficiency
to build collaborative
relationships and to utilize other
funding sources to support this
Mission some of the information uh about
our funding obviously was touched on in
that final report of the committee to
study the fish and game department
funding Partnerships which was released
on November 1st as a new
director uh I am surprised about how
much they can we can achieve or they
have achieved prior to my arrival um I
will continue to support our need to
examine all alternatives to support our
agency however I am realistic that we
are already operating on a on a very
skeleton budget uh we've met the 4%
decrease but I'm not sure that we're
likely to uh fill the entire Gap without
legislative support um if there are
Financial cuts to our funding uh we will
need to likely cut services and as a new
director for an agency that's mandated
to serve the public and our natural
resources um reducing Services is very
concerning to me and uh will result in
collateral and direct negative impacts
on our natural resources our public and
our economy I really don't want to see
that happening so I'm hoping we'll have
your support um I do want to take a
moment and thank you for the support
that has been provided to this agency up
to this point honestly it's it's that
work and that support that Drew me to
come to New Hampshire um so I'd like to
thank you for that and um look forward
to working with you all as I transition
into this role and we begin facing these
challenges together at this point I'd
like to maybe turn it over to our
division chief of business um
Kathy good afternoon Kathy leonti and
this is my 11th banal budget for the New
Hampshire fishing game
department just a few bullet points we
have 192 full-time employees at this
this time we have five unfunded and they
remain unfunded in the new banal budget
we did meet the governor's targets for
the use of fishing game funds however in
order to do that and maintain all
programs and services we used up the
entire balance in the fishing game fund
at the end of the bium leaving only
approximately $100,000 in there we did
hand out a onepage snapshot going back
to 2011 of unrestricted revenue and
unrestricted fishing game fund
expenditures in the variance in that and
for the last three years 25 through 27
which is the current fiscal year we're
in and the banial budget we're entering
into you can see the very large gap
between revenue coming in and
expenditures going
out and with that if the colonel has has
anything to say or we can open that up
for
questions okay thank you very much uh as
as you may have noticed we've had a few
people join our our panel I'd like to
welcome governor elect aot and Sheriff
Conley uh to the hearing and uh I think
this is this is your third third day in
a row that that governor elect aots has
uh attended these hearings I'm not sure
if that's a record but uh it's it's
greatly
appreciated uh my question for you is is
actually on on on fees that you charge
for for hunting and fishing and I've
been involved with with on the ARA side
in in in funding the
hatcheries uh that are doing and I and I
know that stocking fish everywhere
especially in New Hampshire is extremely
expensive are we charging
enough uh as far as sort fishing you
know the fishing licenses and hunting
fees to or hunting licenses to to
compensate for that and number two I'm
not sure if you if you know but how do
our fees compare to our neighboring
states
so I will answer briefly um in the
discussions I've had with our chief of
Inland Fisheries uh we probably are not
charging enough however we are looking
for other ways to fund that um
comparative to other states I'm not
quite familiar with all the New England
states however I do know across the
country we are lower on some of our
hunting and fishing fees um than most
States however again the hunting and
fishing tradition here is a little
different than it's than it is in other
states and um we do draw quite a few
folks in from outside the neighboring
states come in so I think that helps
offset some of our issues as well and I
don't know if Kathy or the colonel would
like to add to that I can add a little
bit to that we have been doing some
analysis with our surrounding New
England states and we are at number one
or or two with the price that we charge
for our licenses compared to new other
surrounding New England
states okay meaning one being that's
good or high high we're
High okay thank
you hi welcome um I'm going to ask you
about something on page 83 of your I'm
kidding um can you explain the bare
damage relief progr to me and uh no I
um um couple things I
hm in a nice way right okay thank you I
just want to make sure I'll be mean to
you in Market Basket next time I see you
um the uh I mean a couple things Kathy
in particular the sheet you pass out has
a has a projected Revenue drop and I I
presume that's mostly cuz that's what
it's budgeted at in in 25 not because
you think it's going
down my apologies this is strictly
budget figures from 25 to
27 do you think there's a chance will
will be similar in 25 to 24 I'm not
saying the Sheet's wrong
but as far as expenditures I mean no in
uh
revenues revenues are looking very
similar in 25 as they were to 24 a
slight decline but nothing I am overly
concerned about at this do we have
long-term trends on on fishing or
hunting that are uh I mean I I feel like
there aren't quite as many people who
hunt as there used to be um that is a
very true statement if you look at the
revenues in fiscal year 20 and 21 that
was absolutely 100% due to covid more
people went out and enjoyed the outdoors
our revenues from fishing sales peaked
very very high and now they're on the
downward Trend again but they have not
in any way bottomed out do you have a um
and and you mentioned that that uh the
budget is constructed basically spending
the entire Surplus um do you have a and
it doesn't have to be today but can you
at some point Prov for for the
Governor's budget team a a sort of draft
Surplus statement of kind of where you
think things are I have one right here
today I did not make copies of it but I
do have a surplus statement yes perfect
I knew you probably did
yep thank you very much see any other
questions thank you for your testim if I
may one more thing I just wanted to add
back to the fees issue um again as I
mentioned earlier in the introduction a
lot of the North eastern states are
funded through general fund lotteries
and permit fees which we don't really
partake a significant amount of any of
those here in New Hampshire and that
makes a difference in the price of their
licenses as well so just keep that in
mind as far as an additional factor that
affects that thank you very much thank
you very much have a good day thank you
thank
you I'd like to invite up now the
Department of Environmental Services for
afternoon you ready for us we are ready
all right good afternoon uh welcome
governor elect um for the record I'm Bob
Scott with the Department of
Environmental Services I have with me
our chief operating officer Susan car
Carlson uh what I'd like to do today as
you see in your handout is kind of walk
you through uh some of the highlights of
the department very briefly some of the
stressors on the work we do uh and of
course kind of parse and slice and dice
uh the budget to to help uh people
digest what we have have before them uh
the the dicing and of the the data I'm G
to hand off to sue Carlson and then at
the end I'll I'll pick up again and talk
about uh kind of wrap up in some of our
prioritized needs uh so you all
understand that also so if if I could
we'll go to slide slide number two which
is just our organizational chart um we
have as you see for full-time permanent
staff uh
493 uh positions divided under four
divisions uh we we uh have a wide range
of functions which I'll go into some of
our core functions in later slides uh
but we have uh our Waste Management
division as as uh the name kind of
implies uh we deal with uh hazardous
waste uh Solid Waste contamination
issues brownfields Redevelopment uh
super fund management of super fund
sites our water division which is our
largest division uh we deal with uh
things ranging from dams to Wetlands
permitting to uh Wastewater uh projects
drinking water uh and uh we also have
we're unique in the country if I
understand it correctly uh we have the
wabaki River Basin project so it's a 10
10 Community uh fed Wastewater Treatment
Facility in Franklin New Hampshire uh so
we're in a kind of a c certainly unique
but an awkward position where we
regulate wastewater treatment plants but
we also operate a wastewater treatment
plant so um so we we're I guess that's
in a hempshire way we're doing some
something a little bit different uh our
air our air division air Resources
Division uh manages uh typical Smoke
Stack Industries uh air toxics uh
something that may not be obvious
embedded in that division is our our
environmental health group and they help
uh all all the divisions in the uh
agency uh with uh setting health health
based standards uh there's also cats and
dogs within the in the agency we have
the state uh Geological Survey and our
state geologist is hous at Dees uh we
have uh a Pools and Spa program uh that
we run also we have uh a shelf shellfish
program on the Sea Coast where we help
that budding industry too we work very
closely with fish and game so that
that's kind of a a broad overview of
what we do with agency uh I'll skip
quickly through the number three our
mission statement but basically our job
is to protect and restore the
environment and public health and we
take that seriously some of the core
functions on slide
four uh are in in what takes a a lot of
our day is uh water supply but also
water contamination issues uh you'll
you'll hear the four-letter word past
that's Tak up a lot of our time but
there's a lot of other uh uh
contaminants in the in the in the
drinking water that we we pay a lot of
attention to of late in the past the
past bium between uh issues with water
contamination but also uh Federal monies
whether it's through arpa uh the
infrastructure Bill uh the there's a lot
of lot of surge money if you will that
has come through the agency to go back
to the
communities uh to to address uh both
drinking water and and Wastewater issues
so that's been really the the largest
between that and contamination which are
tied together uh that's been our largest
focused uh certainly since I've been
commissioner for uh starting in
2017 um so I'll I'll keep going to slide
five uh we
have as I mentioned some of the things
that keep us up and keep us busy uh are
that infrastructure part so so uh we
have the drinking water ground want a
trust fund uh which resides in the agent
is administered by the agency uh we have
the tip the more standard State
revolving loan funds for uh programs for
drinking water Wastewater again those
have been augmented with the
infrastructure funds uh we have arpa
money uh the state's been very generous
uh with with arpa money I think overall
we we've now had what over 225 million I
think uh roughly in arpa money that has
gone to Water and Wastewater projects s
and of course again we have had a very
large surge uh we have about two more
years left of it there's a 5year surge
from the infrastructure uh funding uh
which amounted to basically about a half
a billion dollars uh that it's gone to
our going to our communities uh that
we're still in the middle of of working
that uh a side note is all those extra
funds the projects that we
fund we just don't write a check and it
goes to the community we basically it's
kind of the opposite we award the
community as they do the work we verify
that the work met the criteria and then
we issue funds as the work proceeds so
we basically have oversight on the
engineering of the projects and the the
Cradle the grave as far as getting the
project making sure it gets actually
completed so what that means is there's
a there's a large tail for staff with
the great news is all this
infrastructure money is greatly helping
the communities but it also means
A A Tale of a a large large time amount
of work Associated so so to give you an
idea uh what happens within the agency
annually we have over we take over
21,000 permit actions and conduct over
16,000 inspections of various sorts we
administer 93 types of different permits
or approvals we Implement over 35 state
laws we manage over 115 federal grants
and over 4 40 dedicated fund programs um
I'll also note note that one of the
stressors it's a good news bad news
story so we have a I think a more
engaged public which is a good thing uh
but it's also a little bit of a curse so
what that means is uh probably this is
part of the informational age is with
increased public involvement we see a
large increase now of just general
inquiries from the public that we
respond to uh 91a information requests
are up uh appeals are up comments to our
permits and our rules are up all this
drives extra staff work you you know we
we take pride in the word service
services in our in our name and that's
part of being being a service service to
the public so so I guess it's a it's a
blessing that we have an increased
public awareness but it's also a little
bit of a curse uh probably the ne the
most important slide of our whole slide
deck is number six and this this is uh
highlights to our our budget so our
efficiency budget for 26 uh fiscal year
26 is $340 million
approximately uh we for obvious reasons
we we were asked to meet certain goals
we we've met those goals for 26
27 uh the 26 efficiency budget has a 12%
decrease from the 25 budget uh primarily
in loans and
reimbursements uh the 27 efficiency
budget decreased an additional 4% or $14
million uh included in this request uh
We've we are adding
six permanent staff positions uh five in
the efficiency budget so I know that may
raise some eyebrows uh and I'd like to
talk to that also so and then at the end
and after I I hand off to Susan Carlson
to kind of go through the different uh
slicing and dicing as I mentioned of the
budget uh I'd like to also come back to
our prioritized needs
uh and talk about a settlement on Pas
which is really uh the biggest part part
of that uh which which come back
hopefully come back to our communities
so I mentioned the positions in the
efficiency budget uh the first position
uh we me go back a little bit uh for you
there's been a recent study commission
at the legislature we own and operate as
a state 276 dams uh the current cycle of
rehab re rehabilitating those dams is on
a 100-year
cycle as you may imagine uh some dams
are fairly simple some some are more
more uh complex if you will some are
high-hazard and actually pose a damage
uh danger to uh human human health and
Public Safety basically or property
damage and some are very low risk but
within that obviously we feel 100 years
is not properly the the right right
cycle and we're trying to reduce that uh
as part of that we we we have a dam
Bureau where we do several things
related to those those State dams but
also privately owned dams we have a dam
safety uh program uh we actually have
our own construction crew and we also
manage outside contracts so for one of
our prioritized needs I'm sorry in our
efficiency budget one of the new
requests is for an engineer to work uh
emergency action plans for the for the
state owned dams for a vast majority of
those have not been updated since
1996 uh we really need to to augment our
our current engineering staff to get a
handle on those and make sure not only
the the emergency action plans are done
but to to manage Rehabilitation of as we
we increase the hopefully the frequency
of being able to get at the damn work um
I say that right now most of all at work
for the most part other than an
injection of arpa money uh 30 million of
arpa money went into this kind of damn
work other than that it's been all
capital budget
money uh as I mentioned in uh just just
FYI so there was a study commission uh
that that reported out on the
legislative study commission uh on how
do we fix this issue and they are
looking at some kind of legislation for
some kind of uh maintenance fees that
type of thing for those who are on the
water bodies that the dam support uh
another area of where we've asked for
within the um the the budget uh for new
position is for our Solid Waste program
uh this is by the way one of the areas
where we we're certainly seeing Inc
increases uh in public
interest uh right now in our review of
waste facility plans and and and permits
uh we're seeing on average of uh like 65
applications for a year uh and we're
we're seeing a need to because of the
increase in public involvement the
increase in
complexity uh with these we're seeing a
need to to add an engineer there uh
similarly
um our alteration of terrain uh program
so this is uh water runoff issues for
developments that type of thing uh right
now we're very fortunate within that
program uh we have four full-time
Professional Engineers and we need
Professional Engineers because we're
reviewing other Engineers work so these
other Engineers apply their stamp you
need a professional engineer to review a
Professional Engineers work we are
really living off of we have four
full-time Professional Engineers we've
had three
retirements in in the past year and a
half uh we've been very fortunate we've
been able to harden them back is
part-time employees so it's a wonderful
value for the state and that we don't we
get somebody who's fully trained very
good at their jobs and we're not paying
them benefits we're just paying them a
part-time rate I don't you know same so
we feel that's a a good deal but but to
be blunt the program is surviving off of
them being willing to do that at some
point they're going to retire in the
near term for for real for sure without
coming back part-time so what we're
interested in is creating an entry level
position we've had hard time hard time
getting Engineers what we're interested
in is creating an entry-level position
where they can understudy get their PE
and kind of grow into that position
while we still have these these others
so we think that's a very good bang for
the buck for for the agency in the State
uh moving try to move a little bit more
quickly for for you also for dams uh all
the dam work requires permitting in
different levels uh and also need an
environmental scientist uh to to make
sure that we're we're working through
that and we're able to facilitate the
STW workk I've been talking about and
then
finally uh we've put a lot of e effort
uh we've been able to get arpa money
capital budget money uh
for our environmental permitting uh
online environmental permitting so that
that's yielded great results for
efficiencies for our clients our public
uh access are the Consultants that work
in this field uh and the again good news
bad news the more we do online the more
we make available the more demand for
that is and what we found is we we've
fed a again we've fed been able to get
some good arpa money as well as capital
budget money uh but we need somebody to
ongoing to manage that process as we
work to move from paper to electronic
and we need need somebody to help manage
that to make sure that that proceeds
well so uh what I'm going to do now is
hand over to our chief operating uh
officer Susan Carlson and as I mentioned
she's she's those who know her know
she's very good at the budget issues and
and we're trying to present in the
coming slides uh looking at different
ways for the budget to help answer any
questions uh in advance for you so good
afternoon for the record my name is
Susan Carlson and I serve as chief
operations officer for Dees on page um
seven what we have done is I've given
you a pie chart that shows you the
sources of funds um for this department
I've used FY fiscal year
26 um as a benchmark so you can
understand how we do this um from the
start I want to point out that 92% of
the funding for this department comes
from outside sources only 8% of our
budget is is funded with General
funds fees in total account for 48% of
our total operating budget federal funds
are now at 44% of our operating budget
the remain are is General
funds um the two biggest programs for
funding we have is one is our state
revolving loan programs for drinking
water and waste water those two programs
both with the federal component and the
repayment funds account excuse me
account for 43% of our total operating
budget um the drinking water groundwater
trust fund which came out of our Exon
lawsuit accounts for 9% all other fee
sources account for an additional 23% of
our funding those types of fee sources
include oil funds hazardous waste funds
air permits Dam fees Wetland fees
subsurface fees Shoreland fees those
types of arguments excuse me um on the
next slide um I've broken out in a pie
chart the uses of those funds and I will
go into explanation of those in more
detail in the following slide
essentially 68% of our operating budget
goes out in pass through funds either in
Grants reimbursements loans and
contracts only 32% of our budget is for
operating
now the grants are a combination of
numerous programs and cut across all
three funding sources including such
programs as state a grant program which
is General funded Lake restoration which
is Mill foil eradication which is a fee
account the groundwater drink excuse me
the drinking water groundwater trust
goes out in Grants pasas also goes out
in Grants also included our
reimbursements reimbursements relate to
several programs including the oil fund
program they do reimbursements
mtbe is um a big um reimbursement
program and also the past program does
reimbursement um contracts contracts
caught across all of our programs
include um and some of our major
contracts include our circular program
which is our super fund
program um the drinking water srf bill
funding which is new for the budget this
for 26
27 um and our wind emerging contaminant
program um operating expenses are just
what you think they are their current
expenses their
telecommunications um their normal
equipment that kind of bills um Andro
agency transfers which are only 3% of
our operating budget include what we pay
for building rent
Charlie um I know Bargain Basement rate
um doj support doit support um and and
small amounts like EAP which is the
employee assistance program for
HHS salary benefits cover not only our
493 full-time positions they also
include 52 full-time temporary positions
and numerous part-time staff as also
related additional friend
cost and health
benefits as I've said before 68% of our
operating budget is passed back out
through to cities and towns in the form
various
forms on the next slide I've given you a
budget analysis by cost category what
I've done is compare the FY 25 budget to
the 26 and then to the
27 as you can see our overall budget
went from 380 7 million down to $340
million a decrease of 47 million 27 went
down another $25 million excuse me down
to $325 million another $14 million
reduction you can see the single biggest
category of reductions is in
loans what we had in
fy2 with the Advent of the bill money we
had a great deal of supplemental Federal
Loan money come in the door um for this
department what I have what this
department has done is we looked at that
for FY 26 and 27 and we brought that
bill number um loan amounts down from
$79 million to $40
million so we've basically brought our
loan balances down we're seeing because
of the arpa money we're seeing less
request for those Direct loans right
now we also have reduced the groundwater
um Trust Loans from $20 million to $15
million as we've been seeing a decrease
in that um and the P Loan Fund is
nearing our maximum available balance so
we reduce that from 8 million to
6,26 and we reduce that number to zero
in FY
27 um the grants we grants out of 38
different programs in this
department while the net changes from 25
to 26 look small it actually refects
four major offsetting
changes the drinking water srf bill
funding plus the Wastewater s
grants um increased by $1
million I should point out that um when
I get to the next slide you will see a
major increase in and general funds for
this department and I will explain that
to you in detail as what that is going
on now those increases in the Wastewater
bill money were offset by decreases in
the drinking water groundw trust by 3
million by reducing the wind contamin
merging contaminant grant program by
$4.9
million as well as the arm fund which is
um going down by
1.2 the decrease es in 27 reflect
another $1.5 million reduction in the
Wastewater side grants and another 2
million in the groundwater trust fund on
the
reimbursements if you look at
reimbursements you will notice
reimbursements are down that is because
the mtbe program that we received
settlement fund for um is ending so the
funding for reimbursements went from 9.5
million
in 25 did 2.5 million 26 and did
$500,000
27 contracts increased by a small amount
in in 26 we have 77 different programs
with contract funds in there that vary
funding from year to year for FY 26 the
cira federal program in saw an increase
in contracts for $5 million going from1
to $21 million for a large anticipated
increase in Federal Circle
funding we front loaded these contracts
in FY
26 so in order to get the remediation
work done on these super fund sites um
and reduce the FY 27 budget back to $16
million salary and benefits overall
operating cost overall um where within
what we consider normal parameters was
just 2 to
3% if you go to the next
slide I did the same analysis by funding
source
fy2 shows a general fund appropriation
of 18.5 million FY 26 shows a 29.4 s
million um million appropriation for
General
funds what's driving this increase
essentially what is driving this
increase is the Wastewater state aid
grant program we received funding in FY
203 to cover the FY 24 and the fy2
funding for this
program James was kind enough to let us
put this funding back in the operating
budget for
2627 for the last four fiscal years the
SAG program has been funded out of hb2
and not out of the operating budget
prior to that this program was always in
the operating
budget so while it looks a bit deceiving
we are actually not essentially
increasing our general fund
Appropriations or use of General funds
from 25 to
26 um the changes in the other funding
sources like the federal funds srf um
mirror our changes in expenditures
obviously if we drop our federal loan
programs the federal srf funds drop by
the same amount of money as we've noted
the drinking water ground weather trust
fund um we are nearing the end of our
current funding balance for that so that
is showing
decreases and we are also um adjusting
all our other funds downwards um for
changes in other
programs now I'm going to turn it back
over to the commissioner so may maybe we
for interest of time we'll just skip
slide slide 11 and go right to slide 12
I mentioned prioritize needs uh I'll the
first one I'll mentioned I I'm well
aware there's likely a need to do
further Cuts uh not the other way around
but should there be uh additional
funding available uh we have a position
request uh and I'll I'll start with
uh we we've had great success uh
embedding uh attorneys in some of our
larger programs and in one case our land
manage management resource program so
that that includes Wetlands alteration
train Shoreland and septic and what
that's done is allowed us to as we look
at uh you know under Governor sonuna
we've been spending a lot of time trying
to look at ways to streamline our
permitting processes uh usually what you
really need to do is start with what the
LW says and then work backwards so we
have a lot of historical rules that have
kind of morphed over time frame and
we've had a lot of success having an
embedded uh attorney in the program work
with the staff on starting with what is
what is the law says what is what's the
got to do here and then trying to cut
call out things from there uh as I
mention also uh we have a lot more
public involvement which means uh a a
lot more review of things like 91a
requests uh and inquiries and appeals
are happening more so that's all driving
more legal work so we've had good
success in our Water Division or our
land resource management Bureau doing
that what I'd like to do should we be
able to have that kind of uh funding
available is to do the same thing for
our Waste Management division so that's
the the the first item the the largest
issue you see for prioritized needs has
to do with um the lawsuit uh the
Attorney General's office has with the
with 3m and Dupont for drink Drinking
Water Systems related to past
contamination so that lawsuit uh is is
in settlement uh the settlements uh the
money's not have been have not been uh
uh sent out yet to the States but the
formula has been
established uh by which we will be
receiving money uh the Attorney
General's office and our staff at Dees
have spent a lot lot of time uh
ultimately representing the Water
Systems in our in our state uh we will
I'll say two things on that briefly uh
we'll beginning not nearly as much as
the state deserves for the for the money
and the Water Systems have been impacted
but proportional to other states I
believe we're getting a lot more
actually um so that settlement monies we
think will start to flow in the New Year
we're not exactly sure when uh we
believe it will be at least $55 million
that will funnel through the drinking
water ground water trust fund we've
already gone to the trust fund and they
are going to then have the agency
Dees proportionally for those impacted
Water
Systems will be able to be reimbursed
proportionally out of that fund so we
expect that we we we are very sure we'll
be getting that type of money in the New
Year we're asking to put that in
prioritized
needs uh that's our largest and then
then uh
I assume mentioned the Charlie I think
uh we do have prioritized needs passrs
from other agencies we our main office
at Hazen Drive is is uh you know admin
Services doeses the maintenance and and
all the work on that building so our
portion of that payment is there uh we
also doit is in the same building they
have the same type of thing their pass
through subsequently to us is included
in this as well as the Department of
Justice uh they have a new new new digs
which is great for them uh but all that
comes M maintaining buildings cost money
and and so that portion for the
environmental Bureau that we support uh
that prioritized need is here also so so
with that uh hopefully we didn't take
too much time I didn't pay attention to
the clock but we certainly obviously can
answer any
questions thank you um New Hampshire
clearly has a p fast problem and while
we've devoted a significant amount of
money to it one of the things I've been
trying to I think probably failed to
completely understand is is the scope of
that problem so I'll ask my question
this way if I could write you a you have
a blank check and write you an amount
how much money would I have to write for
you to say New Hampshire no longer has a
past
problem a lot of pieces to that I I
would say if you're willing to write a
billion dollar check perhaps but it
depends on what you mean by a problem I
guess but p is UB quitous in in the
world but certainly in the State uh the
southern part of New Hampshire uh is is
greatly
impacted uh so we've been focusing on
people's drinking water uh as a primary
issue the settlement agreement we were
talking about with the 3M focuses on
Public Water Systems uh there we are
also spending a lot of time on people's
private Wells so we run a rebate program
Etc so it's a very large problem per se
uh but but again I I want to remind
everybody p is not the only contaminant
that we deal with
so Senator gr um as I understand it
there's a whole lot of
plal chemicals out there some have been
identified as problems and to go to his
question is that some of those others
may be identified as problems in the
future and that's why it
is a mountain you can't climb right now
you you can't get an
estimate I agree that there's over
4,000 of these type of
compounds we only regulate uh gosh I
forget four of them and I think epa's
suggesting they're only going to
regulate six of them and the reason for
that certainly I can speak for our state
standards is because this is developing
science as we go so there is not data on
all those other uh compounds so which is
very frustrating for the public you know
to hear that we don't know but that's
reality I um I restarted my heart after
I heard James say if I could write you a
blank check hoping to God he doesn't say
that again when HHS is here um or anyone
else um I'm teasing um
92% of your budget is non-general funds
which is great for you um compared to
those of us who are the other way around
um it means that you have lots and lots
of different
funds and lots and lots of funds which
have balances and uh it's I'm thinking
in the back of my head of uh
periodically an agency will have a
program that's funded by a
fund and um the fund has a Surplus
that's slowly diminishing and two or 3
years later we get a frantic phone call
from that agency saying yeah when we set
this up in 2007 we had lot of money for
this and that doesn't raise any money
anymore and I wonder if you have a have
some kind of report internally about
like what are your B what are your fund
balances for your for like how many
different funds do you have like 40 or
50 um we have over 40 different um
dedicated fee accounts
and actually we report out to you every
year and as of June 30th what the fund
balances are in our dedicated fund
report um obviously we have two
funds um the srf drinking water and
waste water that make up the majority of
our dedicated fund balances they are our
big ones um after that um it ranges from
a few million dollars all the way down
to tons of thousands of dollars we try
to manage every one of those funds so
that we do not have to come running to
Evan Services saying we're out of
money and I um and and I appreciate that
and I actually been reviewing a copy of
the dedicated funds report last week um
are there any of those funds and because
I didn't review it that carefully
because it's not quite as long as the
budget but close um are there anywh you
see a diminishing balance where where
the because some of them support
operations right yes some of them are
more like loan funds where you loan less
money next year if you don't have enough
money and all of that but some of them
support operations the majority of the
number of our funds support operations
and and do you see any of them where
where sort of the annual the annual in
and the annual out are are starting to
get
sketchy not sketchy but I'm taking in
180 Grand this year and we spent 204 yes
we do have some that we need to revisit
um essentially either the the revenue
side or the expenditure side of the
house we're always constantly watching
those um balances to make sure that we
stay within our funding sources and most
of your fee increases are done through
through the budget or do you have
Authority or legislation it would
require us going for legislation for fee
increases you don't have any fees that
you directly just control you can raise
if you have cause we have very
few okay good thank you very
much oh and you're not going to have to
fund the prioritized need for das CU
pretty sure we're getting less not
more um yeah and that's one of the
reasons we put um those pass through
prioritized needs in a single accounting
unit so that when a final decision is
made we can adjust our budget for any
anything that is accepted or rejected
represent W thank you as I recall we
used to call these State resolving State
revolving loan funds and they were
supposed to re the the towns and cities
and water systems were supposed to repay
them we
forgave a major portion of that loan how
much do we forgive on the loan
payments um in the srf program um we
have um required principal forgiveness
on um dollar amounts on the various
Federal programs so for instance on the
drinking water um Federal program EPA
will tell us that for your FY 24 program
you have to
forgive $4.5 million in principal
forgiveness for that Federal program for
that Grant year um so it varies by the
federal year and how much we are being
told that we have to
forgive but we try not my personal
opinion is I try not to forgive any
loans but we do forgive portions alone
and um it's tiered under our
administrative rules the most
disadvantaged programs get the highest
um um principle forgiveness so we don't
have any way to say we're not going to
forgive as much and have them pay
more again it's controll it's controlled
by federal rules thank
you okay thank you very much for your
testimony e
we got most of the budget I would like
to invite Health and Human Health and
Human Services up for their Bud a
presentation I'd like to welcome
representative Edwards to our
hearing good afternoon good afternoon
commissioner good afternoon governor
elect aot and committee thank you for
the opportunity to present our $3.5
billion budget in 45 minutes uh will be
a challenge um I have uh Nathan white
here today with me as a CFO um and we're
going to walk you through the slide deck
I think that that you have in front of
you um I did have to ask myself if there
was a strategy that we were last was it
that you saved the best for last last or
um just the biggest for last um so we'll
do our best here I know that you've all
been here for three long days and that
we're the last of the bunch here to go
so we'll get started um on the agenda
how we've sort of decided to parse out
for you presentation of our budget is
really on the agenda slide of doing an
overview of the department talking a
little bit about our road map which is
our strategic priorities for
2425 a little bit about the department
overview some staffing and then we'll
get into the budgets uh by
agency so moving on to slide three in
terms of uh our vision mission and
values basically who we are as a
department our vision is is pretty
simple Optimal Health and well-being for
all and we have our mission statement as
well as our values and our values are
operating principles that we as a
Workforce in the department um focus on
is prevention people focused integrity
and community oriented oriented excuse
me on slide four really what is the
responsibility of the department
everyone says the department is so big
what do you do um at its I Tred to to
cons to keep it concise we deliver
services to clients um which is a big
part of our work so we do that through
some of our case management systems and
we do that internally but we also
through our partners and uh providers in
the community a big bulk of the work
that we do do is Contracting that work
out and having our providers carry that
work out for us we also do Direct Care
Services through New Hampshire hospital
Glen Cliff home Hamstead hospital and
the Youth Development Center so those
are our 247 facilities where actual
Direct Care is being delivered uh we
also responsible for protection so when
we think about child protection and
adult protection uh we think about food
service protection uh disease prevention
surveillance housing supports uh for
looking at those becoming or who may at
risk of becoming um homeless um as well
as regulatory oversight so we have
health facilities which is a lot of our
nursing facilities we have child care
facilities food service and food
protection and then also Public Health
disease prevention so that's sort of in
a nutshell in terms of the functions of
the department if you flip to the next
slide on Slide Five I wanted to talk
with you a little bit about our road map
and why this is important when I became
interim commissioner in
22 uh we I didn't know how long I was
going to last at that point so I said
let's do a road map for a year uh what
goals can we set what can we achieve and
set a direction we were successful with
that road map so in going into a budget
year uh looking at again redetermining
what those priorities were lifting some
of the work that had not yet been
completed in that prior road map working
with our stakeholders and our partners
and putting that into our road map for
24 25 um it's
really laying out you know what is our
desired outcome what is our charge what
is our mission what are our requirements
what do the law requir us to do how are
we going to do that when and when are we
going to do that and how much money we
need to do that um which is what we're
here to talk a little bit about today
there's three major components to it and
I have it down here in the three Circles
of culture community and service so
culture is really about investing in
people and culture if I don't have a
Workforce at the department
can car can carry forth the charge that
I I can't be effect we can't be
effective as a department so that isn't
just Recruitment and Retention you know
it's Workforce Development making sure
that we have the right people in the
right jobs specialized positions
carrying out some pretty um intense uh
tasks that we have to do because we have
the gamut all the way from um
administrative work down to direct care
and working in hospitals and and um Glen
Cliff as well uh Community promote
thriving communities that's commitment
number two that's the bulk of where our
policy and program lies so you'll find
things in there like Behavioral Health
children system of care um our healthy
system of care for aging uh maternal
Health uh developmental disability uh
strengthening and some of you may have
heard about Mission zero which is uh our
concerted effort to end Ed boarding all
of that lies in there and becomes part
of our Focus uh moving forward I just
want to point out as well that it's it
says road map 2425
but really some of these goals are
short-term some of them are midterm and
some of them are longer term so we will
lift some of them in subsequent years um
the last bubble there is imp improving
customer service so we have internal
customers and we have external customers
at the department we have a significant
Reliance on our provider Community to do
business with us so if it's hard to do
business with the state we're not going
to be successful at that so part of our
commitment and pledge here is to try to
make it easier um to uh get contracts
provide the service get quality outcomes
and quality measurements um as well as
those that we serve so it's not just the
partners and the providers it's the
clients um and we have a a whole uh
section on just basically being able to
make it easier if you're receiving
services from the Department who to call
when to call how to call um it's it's
difficult in a large organization and we
want to make that easy for folks that
are trying to get help um so this has
this has become um a big part of our
budget development as I was talking with
some folks earlier in terms of tying
some of what we're doing here to our
budget priorities which you'll
see uh flipping to the next page is
really I'm just going to warn you this
is not an org chart uh by any means it's
it's really meant to show the breadth
and the depth of the department and its
entirety and sort of an easy way to
digest HHS so if you're really look at
the blue columns are sort of the the the
main streams of population health Human
Services and Behavioral Health and then
our operations we have seven major
divisions within the department um so
you can see that we have the division of
public health Medicaid children youth
and families economic stability
Behavioral Health long-term supports and
services and the division of finance
that blue on the far right is really our
operation support everything that
supports the the two columns on the left
so we obviously have an infrastructure
uh with it and with HR and with
facilities
but we also have program quality
Integrity which is monitoring all of
those providers and making sure that
they're delivering what they're supposed
to be delivering and that we're getting
the return on the investment um and we
also have the employee assistance Pro
program is housed within HHS some people
may not know that serves all of the
state agencies but um we we house that
program host it um within the
department and then the last box is not
not the least but the last box is the
247 facilities as well
so flipping to the next slide I just a
little bit of context in terms of where
do we sit where does the Department of
Health and Human Services budgets sit
within the bigger picture uh as many of
you know it's uh more than half of the
state budget um and we represent about a
fourth of all state employees so I don't
know Charlie what the latest is on the
total of thousands of employees that we
have uh but we're about about a quarter
of that um and then our staffing cost
just just to put this in perspective a
little bit our staffing is really about
11% of our budget so when we look at
things like trying to save money through
Staffing and personnel there isn't a lot
of return on that um because it's only
11% of our budget and I actually it's a
good segue to the next slid really
talking about Staffing so I've been with
the Department about 27 years and I've
been in different roles um when I first
started I believe we had over
3,400 positions and so you'll see here
that we're at
3248 but really I I I I actually only
have about 2,800 filled I have a
legislative cap of 3,000 um so I can't
go above that um but what I want to
point out is back in 2020 we had hiring
frees with covid so we didn't fill a lot
of positions that spilled over into back
of the budget cuts for 22 and 23 where
we gave 22.4 million back in Personnel
costs so we weren't filling all of those
positions and then back in uh December
of
22 uh our vacancy rate was at
22% so that that's a hit for the
Department that's significant it's hard
for us to get the work done and and have
folks satisfied that are receiving
services with us when we're down part of
the pledge in the road map at that time
was to get that vacancy rate down and
today it's at
14.9% so that's that's actually a great
gain but the difference in 24 we did
give back uh money but we were not
restricted to keep it within Personnel
lines so that really helped us a lot to
be able to meet the back of the budget
cut at that point of 23.6 million
without having to cut into Personnel so
it's made a difference so I I I say that
because I don't I don't think there's a
lot of fluff there and when we look at
um our Direct Care Facilities cutting
positions in those facilities means less
Revenue because we have less beds filled
so it's really it's really a delicate B
um and balance of of meeting all of that
so I think with that I'm going to turn
it over to uh Chief Financial Officer
Nathan white to talk about the details
of some of the numbers thank you
commissioner good afternoon governor
elect aot members of the committee my
name is naan white Chief Financial
Officer and before we dig into the
numbers uh one thing that I just want to
acknowledge about the dhh budg budget is
its complexity is it is large but it is
explainable and there's a graph in front
of you and you'll see three three
bubbles there the budget cost allocation
and the actual and so when we prepare
our budget we prepared this budget back
in August we make certain assumptions
about the number of clients that we will
serve and the and the costs resulting
there from we also have the advantage um
we have a a public assistance cost
allocation system and we have over a 100
Federal funding sources and we use that
system to try to leverage Federal funds
as much as possible and we recently
implemented a uh a budget system to
allow us to better identify federal
funds and so some of some of the members
on the committee probably remember in
years past we've uh lapsed sign
significant amounts of federal funds
that we were unable to suspend to spend
uh that did not happen this past year
partly as a result of our ability to
better identify track and budget for um
the federal revenue and we've we've
prepared this budget in accordance with
that and to try to maximize the federal
dollars that we have available and and
decrease the general fund needs um I
think it we also have a number of other
Revenue sources which is a little unique
to the department as the commissioner
indicated we have a number of 247
facilities where we generate Medicaid
and third party insurance at New
Hampshire hospital and uh Hamstead
hospital and residential treatment
facility and we make assumptions in our
budget for those as uh you know as well
is in the Medicaid Program which is an
Actuarial based estimate and the reason
that I that I want to point this out is
because I I I want to uh just commit to
working with the house the Senate the
governor and everyone here as far as
revising those numbers as we move
through this process because we set we
set our projections back in August and
things will change throughout the year
and I just kind of want to recognize the
complexity of that uh and make a
commitment to everyone in the room uh as
far as our our commitment to work with
anyone everyone on
that moving on to the next slide on
slide 10 so this is a very high level
budget overview and the way that we're
going to be going through this today is
we're be going we're going to be going
through the budget at the agency level
just given the brevity of time that we
have available um and below the below
each agency you'll have an activity as
well as accounts and we have uh hundreds
of accounts and we certainly don't have
all the time in the world today to go
over that but if you if you draw your
attention uh to the top box there on
page 10 um the efficiency Target budget
in state fiscal year 26 and 27 uh those
were the targets that were provided to
us uh from the governor's office um
which we have achieved here we've also
submitted which I'll be touching
touching on about1 171 and $234 million
of prioritized needs requests some of
those requests are coming as a result of
some federal changes some of those are
resulting from uh legislatively directed
rate studies as well just to put a
little bit of context on those requests
the total number of positions in the
chart below there uh has remained flat
you will see that there's a shift in
unclassified to classified that's the
result of some of the hb2 provisions
from this past session where DCF
attorneys and several Medicaid positions
were converted from classified to
unclassified positions based on
directives from the division or direct
or conversations with the division of
Personnel in the Attorney General's
office so rather than talking about the
summary I'd like to move to slide 11 to
start to dig into some of the details so
agency 42 which is the division for
children youth and families is the first
area um to talk about here and just to
just to orient uh everyone here relative
to what we're looking at the second row
you'll see General General funds as a
percentage of the budget General funds
obviously being the most critical uh
here we we put that in there just to
give everybody more of a visual
perspective on what we're dealing with
and what we're talking about and as I
was referencing um in the opening slide
of my section of the presentation many
of our positions uh are funded by
multiple funding sources some are 100%
General funds and dcyf is an area where
we do have more generally funded
positions in other areas that you'll see
such as the office of the commissioner
we have positions that are funded
through over a 100 different funding
sources and so it's just important to
remember as we move forward with this
process that um sometimes it's it's not
a one: one it's sometimes a more of a
1/3 to 2/3 ratio depending on the
position and the contract or expense
that we're looking at so in the general
fund row there you will see an increase
and this the the increase here is the
result of a couple of different
things number one the syc
spend in state fiscal year 24 and the
current trends exceeded the existing
budget and through the department-wide
transfers we we do about three a year
through the fiscal committee process um
we did have to move several million
dollars over to syc to cover costs to
provide um the the services at that
facility um accounting unit 2958 uh
relative to to child protection for uh
children in the care of the state um we
have also experienc increased cost
relative to the services uh and
treatment needed for those children
which is sort of another significant
increase driver within that class
line we we did submit uh related to that
we did submit several prioritized needs
um two of which are related to the
system of care and some of the ongoing
upgrades um and modifications to the
existing system of care we we will
experience a loss of Medicaid funds for
children that are in residential
facility uh centers of about more than
16 beds come beginning in the state
fiscal year 27 right now we're
projecting that to be about 188 about an
$18 million impact um we've also
included a request uh for rate increases
for the residential treatment providers
as well of about approximately 9.1
million um total funds and and that's
about 66% General funds remainder being
um federal
dollars there were a number of pieces of
legislation that came out of the state
fiscal year 24 legislative session and
we have included prioritized needs
request here you will not see the
prioritized needs um the positions
included in this document here so it
reflects the agency budget request and
part of that is is the fact that the
legislation passed and we did not have
time to establish those positions so
those do not show up here but s SP 463
relative to court appointed uh Council
um that that established 14 uh child
protective Ser service worker positions
s SP
417 uh relative to Child Protection
expanded the requirements and
established an additional uh 12
positions as well and then uh HP
1598 uh special education expansion that
expanded the age of special education
from 21 to 22 uh the legislation had
appropriated funds from the from the
education trust fund account in the
amount of $3 million we've continued
that that practice here in our agency
budget submission uh just to remain
consistent with the original leg
legislation moving on to page 12 this is
agency 45 this is the division of
economic stability um the division of
economic stability provides a number of
of key critical Services uh Child Care
is included um within agency
45 as well as um our eligibility uh team
and our our family support
Specialists
and excuse me you will see that that
overall the general funds compared to
the adjusted authorized of 2025 are
going down and part of that is due to
cash assistance we we have been seeing a
slow downward Trend in the amount of
cash assistance um and as a result uh
you you're you're seeing that reflected
in the budget there related to
eligibility uh we do have a number of
requests to try to continue to enhance
the operational efficiencies of the
department and improve customer service
and this is really important because it
impacts anybody seeking uh to to qualify
for Medicaid it impacts our nursing
facilities and our other providers where
when we have pending Medicaid claims and
so we have a request to modernize
eligibility Services as well as uh some
improvements to multilanguage
support the first prioritize need there
at the top um during this past
legislative session the budget included
approximately a million dollar um to
cover costs for an income eligibility
system that the federal government is
retiring and so those costs are now now
need to be borne by the state uh and so
we've we've submitted a request to
continue that we've also submitted a
request to continue the summer EBT that
was approv that was acted into law via S
SP
499 and then uh consistent with the
current banial um bium funding for the
childcare Workforce fund we have
included a total request of $15 million
General funds uh for that purpose and
that that's the same funding level uh
consistent with the current
bium the division of Medicaid services
is on page 47 this is is agency
47 um this this area is approximately
it's a little over onethird of the
entire budget um within the Medicaid
Program uh we are able to leverage uh
federal funds often referred to as as
fmap um and and typically the the
minimum amount is 50% however for chip
and some other uh clients were able to
leverage 65% or or other amounts
um you will see a decrease in the
general funds in this line and we we
budgeted Medicaid based on the
assumption that enrollment would
continue around
182,000 so uh many of you remember the
um unwind process that we went through
over the past couple of years that has
been pretty much complete and over the
uh ensuing months we've seen a
relatively steady enrollment around
182,000 which is what we base this on
now you will see an increase in the
other funds and the reason that you're
seeing that is that that's uh as a
result of the existing law and the
directives that the department has been
given relative to the U met dish um
situation previously the distribution
was approximately 91% we set this budget
at 80% based on the existing law and the
directives that we have uh received so
far so that that is what you are seeing
reflected within the Medicaid
Budget on page 14 uh moving on to the
vision of long-term supports and
services this is agcy 48 I just want to
make a note that uh the vision of
long-term supports and services shows up
in both agency 48 uh as well as agency
92 in a few slides what you're looking
at here um the services that are
primarily provided that are provided out
of this agency are the choices for
Independence waiver program as well as
the the nursing facility Medicaid
payments those are those are two big um
drivers here um both both of which come
out of accounting unit 2152 which is
certainly one of our larger accounting
units um relative to the nursing
facility payments the the department has
experienced a significant increase in uh
costs resulting from a number of
different factors and we've had we
transferred about $14.5 Million last
year with fiscal committee approval uh
we do have an item on the November on
tomorrow's agenda to transfer an
additional 10 million we anticipate
additional millions of dollars being
transferred for that purpose uh over the
coming months and uh what you see here
reflected in the Department's budget is
just a recognition of those costs that
have been pushed um that that the state
is now picking up and we're having to
transfer funds from other programs in
order to continue those costs um we also
do have an increase in the General funds
there but we did assume approximately
about a 7% utilization increase in
nursing facility uh Medicaid payments
and some of the challenges that we have
experienced over this bium are the
changes in ownership uh of the nursing
facilities which have caused some
instability as well as some back billing
also resulting from that instability in
the amount of I believe it was about $13
million in the prior year and we are
currently trending uh at a similar
projection for this year if not
higher um there was a required rate
study and we've included a prioritized
need here for that for choices for
Independence and um that that's
estimating about 8.5 and $8.6 million
85% General funds uh for each year of
the bium based off that legislative
directed rat study um we have also
included a request for congregate
housing uh which was included in the
current hb2 to continue that program as
well on page 15 we move to the division
of Public Health Services I think what's
really important to understand about
division of Public Health Services is
there are a lot of little grants um that
public health not little by any means
but many grants that Public Health
Services manages and so as a result of
that you see a significantly lower
amount of General funds the the $3
million increase that you're actually
seeing in the general funds there is is
partly the result of us moving a $3
million um Family Resource Center
contract from DCF into the division of
Public Health Services um which which
explains uh a significant portion of of
that increase that you do see there um
the warehouse lease prioritized need we
are in the process of consolidating the
warehouse um which and we did not have
this information uh fully vetted and
available at the time that we submitted
our agency budget and prepared it back
in August but we do expect that to be
uh at least at least about half of that
amount um Bas based on the current work
that that we are performing um you'll
also see there are a variety of other
funds here within the division of Public
Health we have pharmaceutical rebates
newborn screening
radiological uh fees and vaccine insur
income as well that that's reflected
there moving on to slide 16 uh this is
agency 91 this is the Glen Cliff home
Glen Cliffe uh is located in the
northern part of the state and provides
geriatric and
psychiatric um in inpatient
Services um the a majority of Glen
Cliff's budget is primarily Personnel
it's about $18 million of personnel out
of $21
million um there are no prioritized
needs requests here uh for this
budget the division for Behavioral
Health Agency 92 on page 17 um you will
see it's it's approximately 50 55%
General funds in both years of the
efficiency budget um we have we have
included a number of prioritized needs
requests here as well the first of which
is $5 million of General funds each year
for the Community Mental Health Centers
um to address some of the uh
uncompensated care costs that they that
they um continue to incur for the UN and
underinsured uh We've also included a
prioritized needs request for shelter
care rates so SB um excuse me I can't
remember the exact number uh chapter 290
from the current banum uh appropriated
$2.5 million uh for shelter care rates
this if this were approved in each year
it would continue uh that enhancement
that the legislature approved this past
session we've also included uh request
for $500,000 for a 14 bed use shelter
program in
Manchester um and as well we've also
included a uh a request for an increase
to Guardianship Services um for those
rates as
well on page 18 uh this is the the
vision for longterm long-term supports
and Services I apologize I misspoke
earlier I said agency 92 it's
93 within this accounting unit um or
excuse me within this agency you have
some of our larg accounting units
relative to the to the DD services that
we provide um accounting unit 7100 is a
significant accounting unit um which
accounts for a bulk of the cost that you
do see within this area we prepared our
budget to continue services to the
individuals that uh within the DD
Community the acquired brain disorder
and inhome supports for children uh to
continue those services today we've also
prioritized needs
requests um for DD ABD and IHS to uh
project what the increased need would be
for new individuals that would come into
the system um and that's the current
those were the current projections as of
August again this is another area where
we'd want to continue to work with
everyone to refine those as needed to
avoid uh a wa a waiting uh
list and it is um it is a 50% match here
it's 50% federal funds and 50% General
funds the first prioritized need uh at
the top of the uh lower table there uh
there was a legislatively required rate
study and the amount included here it's
50/50 it would be 17.2 in state fiscal
year 26 and $47 million in state fiscal
year 27 and again it's
5050 um if that were approved um
relatedly there was legislation passed
this past session that appropriated
$500,000 for recreational activities um
for individuals uh in the DD Community
um we included a prioritized need here
to continue that funding at at the same
level the next slide uh on page 19 this
is New Hampshire hospital agency 94 um
New Hampshire hospital provides uh
Psychiatric Services for individuals um
in Mental Health crisis
uh New Hampshire hospital as I mentioned
earlier uh it has a combination of
general and other funds the other funds
are uh billable services that the that
the department receives we make certain
assumptions based on historical uh
census data and the revenue that we've
been able to generate um when we
prepared our budget here what is unique
about this particular year or this
particular bium is uh as many of you
know we have been constructing and it is
currently undergoing construction uh the
addition of a high security unit uh
typically historically we've referred to
this as the forensic unit that is being
built um as part of New Hampshire
hospital and we prepare this budget with
anticipating and planning for an opening
date in the spring of State fiscal year
27 so the amounts that you see in the
prioritized need column second column
from the right it's approximately 10 .4
and approximately 120 positions there's
one unclassified position included there
um based on that opening date and that
would allow us to hire staff in advance
and train on uh train staff on the new
policies and procedures relative to the
high security
unit okay moving on to slide 20 this is
the office of the commissioner ageny 95
as the commissioner was indicating
earlier the office of the commissioner
uh really encompass
uh are legal are legal and Regulatory
facilities Finance our contract team um
our human
resources uh as as well as some other
supporting functions of the
department uh as well as Information
Services
um the there is there there is some
there is some increase in the general
fund needs here some of this is
resulting from my and a lot of this is
resulting uh from the N from the 10 and
2% increase as well as the increase in
benefits uh that the state has
experienced many of these positions are
funded from a multitude of funding
sources because they are Central because
they are Central to the department and
support all of our divisions we're often
able to take advantage of you know TF
title 4E or whatever particular area um
these these individuals and these
positions uh may be working on there you
will see an increase from the state
fiscal year 25 to State fiscal year 26
in the total FTE authorized position
count two of those positions are the
result of the hp2 language that was
converting positions it it converted to
full-time temporary positions uh that
would otherwise not show up here and
then there was an additional movement of
one classified position into the office
of the
commissioner there are uh several
prioritized needs requests in this area
the first is SB resulting from s SP 463
that established five new attorney
positions uh we are requesting that we
receive funding to continue
those the second is continued support
for some of our key it operational
systems this include things like
DocuSign that have improved um both the
the internal processing as well as
external processing and um speed and
efficiency as well as a number of of
other systems and then finally a
replacement for the existing laptops and
accessories is also included there the
final slide is agency 48 this is
Hamstead Hospital Residential Treatment
Facility as many of you um recall back
in June of 22 uh the department and
state acquired Hamstead hospital and
residential treatment facility when we
prepared our budget for the current bium
we did not have uh a significant amount
of data to work from to make those
projections what we have experienced
ended up being different than what our
initial projections were and we've had
to use other funds to supplant or not to
supplant to support the facility um for
the prior for the prior year and we will
need to do so for this year as well
based on the census numbers similar to
New Hampshire hospital Hamstead
generates revenue from third party
paays and
that that accounts for the significant
increase that you do see there in the
general funds and this this is this
assumes that there's a
35 um a 35 um individual census however
we did recently enter into a new
contract with a new provider in July and
we are um we will continue to monitor
what we expect the census to be so far
things are looking good and we're hoping
to generate more Revenue to offset that
need and this is just another one of
those areas where I just want to
continue to work with everybody here as
we move forward uh through the budget
process um there is uh there are two
prioritized needs requests that I just
want to call attention to the first
being a payment to the town of Hamstead
uh we have made a payment to the town of
Hamstead for the um past several State
fiscal years as a result of the loss of
property tax revenue that the town has
experienced um we have also submitted a
request for funding for a kitchen
upgrade the YDC the future YDC is being
built adjacent on the same property at
Hamstead and this would be upgrades to
that kitchen to allowed for shared
services out of one facility rather than
duplicate uh kitchens in both facilities
that are uh adjacent to each other so
with that um I will pause there for
questions
thank
you HHS has a significant number of of
contracts that I'm guessing are worth
hundreds of millions of dollars over a
banum how do you know what sort of
return you're getting on those contracts
uh what what metrics do you use to
measure them I mean do you do after
action reports like here's what we spent
here's what we were looking for here's
what we got and is there anything you
can share on those contracts with with
the governor's office and the transition
team
so I would draw your attention back to
that slide uh in the operations section
I have a whole division of quality
improvement integrity and part of their
job is we look especially at the
high-risk contracts as well so want to
make sure that they can sustain but
always on the return on investment and
the quality of care that we're getting
so we do that uh through we have
contract management we have contract
monitoring are we getting what we paid
for are we getting that outcome that we
set out to get um so there's a lot of um
there's a lot of uh eyes on the total uh
number of contracts that are going
forward so from inception that the time
that they're created through the time
that they're going and then through the
time that they're up for Renewal or for
an amendment to do it again we go back
to that data so though that particular
progam uh division works with the
program areas to look at different
reports different measurements so we
have over a thousand contracts I mean I
I could inundate the governor's office
with that um if you wanted or we could
parse that out if you wanted to look at
the biggest contracts like you look at
our MCO contracts obviously our biggest
contracts we have a lot of quality
control on that as well yeah I think
that would be something we're interested
in and I I would start with the biggest
contracts then we can move down until we
give up yeah so okay my my next question
um I I saw an additional prioritized
need for the Community Mental Health
Centers and I know we uh allocated some
arpa money for those and and it was my
understanding that the idea that was it
was a a bridge financing uh after the
state of emergency ended and the
Medicaid roles were were purged that the
Community Mental Health Centers among
others having a difficult time because a
lot of people who were getting Medicaid
no longer were but they still had to
treat them but my understanding was it
was just that bridge loan and they would
not be coming back for additional money
is that no longer the case they're we're
coming back I I think the issue of
uncompensated care remains so that that
was a one time to fill that Gap but when
we look at um their mandate and their
requirement is to serve all so they
can't necessarily turn anybody away so
when we look at the numbers of
utilization it's still pretty high so we
based our prioritized need on what we
had given them it's not even going to
come close to what their actual need is
but we base it off of what we had given
them thank you
yes you may uh thank you um so good
seeing you both on on uh page 11 I I is
the
YDC uh included somehow on page 11 uh
and and if it is um I I I think I've
seen some preliminary numbers that
suggest that going from about 13 million
a year historically at the sununu Youth
Development Center that you you all are
projecting a $19
million uh requirement and and part of
our thinking when we built the new
facility was we were going to reduce
operating costs not double them or
increase them by 50% could could you
talk about that a little
sure on page 11 um within the division
of children youth and families um s
youth service Center is included in that
total
agency uh 42 that you're looking at
there um the and and you are correct in
the the numbers that you were providing
the reason there's there's kind of a
couple of reasons for why you're seeing
that
increase as many of you recall there was
legislation previously to close uh
syc that legislation included uh an
assum
budget that that provided for the
closure for this current bium and
through the last budget process uh we
did not um based on our initial request
we did not receive sufficient funding to
cover the operating costs so as a result
of that you've seen at fiscal committee
a couple of Department wide transfer
where we've had to move money over
initially it was to cover a lot of the
overtime costs CU we we lost I think
we're 33 or more perent vacant for our
youth counselors at the facility so we
went through a period of
stabilization um currently we are moving
towards hiring more and more youth
counselors at the facility and providing
better um care and services to stabilize
that now for the next state fiscal year
26 and 27 it would be in the second year
that we'd be moving in towards that
transition there is a team a project
team that uh of probably well over a
dozen people that have been working on
those trans ition numbers uh to kind of
to to determine and understand what the
new facility operations would will look
like um when we submitted our budget
back in August all of those details had
not yet been sorted out so we wanted to
make sure that we take a conservative
approach initially until we make until
we're able to make a deter an accurate
and reliable determination on what those
new needs would be so I'll pause there
commissioner I if have anything okay
okay so in a thank you for that in in a
similar vein um on page 19 dealing with
the uh secure forensic hospital and the
Staffing that's required in the uh
second year you've got that listed as a
prioritized need and and that's probably
some budgetary guideline that you had to
follow to to to carry it as a
prioritized need but but but shouldn't
shouldn't we be viewing that as as a
required amount of spend because if we
build this new facility we will have to
staff it and train it and and so having
it dangle as a prioritized need doesn't
really represent it accurately does
it so the way that we prepared this
budget uh was based on our
interpretation of RSA 94 which provides
for the efficiency expenditure requests
which is the cost to continue to provide
services uh as they are today and then
the prioritized needs and additional
problematic needs I believe this house
defined in statute is things above and
beyond that so that that's why we
prepare it the way um we did based on
our our interpretation of of the law and
the
guidelines
May um
hi um thanks for being at the end um
you're like to boo um in a nice way um
DD weight list um am I right in assuming
there's no DD weight list right now or
essentially none did you say Ed weight
list I'm sorry DD developmental disab DD
weight list those are two different
things yes there's no weight list um and
with your with your current in the
efficiency budget if we just said the
efficiency budget hey go ahead um not
enough to fund there would be a weight
list how big
I'm looking behind you actually I'm
watching her nod her head and bounce it
back and
forth I know you I know you probably
can't say exactly but yeah um this is
Chris sanella associate commissioner um
I I would say
approximately 2 to 500 adult
I don't have that number but I can get
that number for you that's how many
would end up on a wait list what are we
how many are we serving today ballpark
there's about um 4,000 people ballpark
on the waiver on the DD waiver and so
and and
go RSA
171a requires the department um to put
in our budget the cost to fully support
the DD weight list and then there's a
clause in there that says and then the
legislature shall fund that it's 171 a18
I
believe um I can get you those exact no
I'm aware of the law yeah so um okay I
just in in our head I wanted to so the
funding that's in efficiency is
essentially funding for the people who
are currently on the list roughly 4,000
is that is that population
that that needs the
service um is the growth fairly
consistent is it is it is it what's it
doing it's not exponentially growing is
it slowing down bit no it doesn't slow
down it consistently grows as um
children age out of the system and
people with disabilities do live longer
um there also is and Nathan maybe you
can talk about this we look at the DD
numbers really closely cuz when we get
to about um April may we do have the
ability to carry forward dollars um to
help with that but we don't know what
that carry forward will be today um and
we won't know that until later in the
budget process and on once somebody once
somebody starts receiving Services it's
rarely PR rated right when you yes what
how we figure the budget for the new
Services is we PR rate it based on when
they either turn 22 or when it's
anticipated that they will need
Services okay great um thank you thank
you for indulging me I appreciate that
um I want to ask two questions one one
is about laps and one is broader
philosophically um your laps is uh you
know the last couple years and the the
way we budgeted we budget astronomical
numbers for lapses um because we've been
like during Co they were crazy high and
and they're coming back down to earth
like in the most recent budget and yours
in particular which is obviously the
biggest part of the lap
um fair to say that that certainly with
with this budget if it were to go
forward but generally you're closer to
not much of a lapse than than you were
in say 21 22
23 sure so there's a couple I I I I
think just almost backing up from a
historical perspective so you know 10 12
years ago um you you you probably saw
larger lapses from the department and
have been a number of legislative
changes within our budget over the years
uh when it comes to the accounting unit
2152 for the nursing facility payments
you know there used to be a decent
amount of money that could have lapsed
out of there but now there is a class
note that requires those funds to be
paid out within the DD accounts that we
were just talking about 7100 being the
largest uh now RSA
171a carries those funds forward so
those funds would no longer laps uh in
addition to the federal um the federal
revenue projections that uh that we have
been doing based on the new system that
we've implemented we're Cur we're
curtailing the the lapsing of federal
revenue that we earn but we just didn't
apply because now we have the better
ability to identify earn it and apply it
to better utilize General funds but you
are correct this past year uh we you
know net lapsed about $13.5 million
um which which is very different from
the historical
experience and and in the first year I
think I'm right about this in the first
year some enormous percentage of your
budget can't lapse right is it like half
um I don't think it's half the Medicaid
budget had a u has Provisions within it
to carry forward those dollars New
Hampshire hospital and Hamstead have
some footnotes to allow certain
operational class lines to carry forward
uh but but I it's certainly um for most
areas DD as well right and and and DD as
well but DD never lapses that continues
from bium to bium as a result of that
statute um thank you for that the the
just something that as we develop a
budget and if somebody like puts in a
plug for HHS laps and gobs of money
we're all in trouble
um it a broader context issue um as the
commissioner pointed out at the
beginning of this you more than half the
budget and we spent something like a
thous minutes talking about the other
half of the budget and we're going to
spend 45 talking about this half of the
budget 17 hours versus less than an hour
or something like that and it it's worth
noting that you know I asked an agency
yesterday or maybe it was Tuesday I
don't know anymore about a $100,000
increase in a class line on a page of
their budget
and the odds of me doing that to you are
zero right and it's and it it's hard and
it's hard for Budget writers and you
know the legislature is going to have an
entire division that's going to spend
weeks going through your budget line by
line and the poor governor elect has to
have a budget where the numbers stop
moving by like 10 days after she sworn
in um and and I say this this isn't news
to anybody right but um I remember so
eight years ago I was in a similar POS
position where there were different
governors in the two phases um and you
know we came in and it was a nightmare
and I remember sitting down and and you
know very sitting down with very nice
people to try to explain and give me a
multi- hundred page binder to simplify
the HHS budget so the simplification
document was 150 Pages um I think this
is just me saying this to you that for
decision
makers how you sort that out is going to
be I mean we sat there I remember the
the governor-elect at that time doesn't
matter what his name was and I met with
with I think Jeff Myers was commissioner
and the and the CFO at the time and it
was overwhelming and my my giant
takeaway from the meeting was wow the
commissioner has a bathroom um because
you try to focus on the things you can
understand and um and we ended up having
multiple meetings and and at one point
you know so Sher Rockburn was the CFO
people know that who's now my assistant
commissioner and and I said this to her
at some point I said we have to make
decisions and I don't know how the hell
to make them he has some vague sense of
what he wants not vague sense he has a
sense of what he wants to do but it's I
can't talk to you about class 45 and
class 62 and all of that and she you
know in Sherry's Sherry's way and she
couldn't be here today but in Sherry's
way she waves her arms wildly and talks
really fast and then produces a document
with arrows and boxes and things going
all over the place and it was a decision
making document and it it it's it's
similar to this but it was more like all
right here's the 14 decisions you have
to make and getting us there and
unfortunately that year we were cutting
we were cutting hhs's numbers and it was
really hard to do um particularly
because there were some things the
governor governor wanted to do a
significant DD increase for example
quite large one and we were simplifying
other things and and this is just me
saying to you
45 minutes for half the budget and a th
for the other half um a lot of people
who were on the transition team and and
probably their boss are going to need a
lot of help from you in in helping
translate budgets into English and all
that thanks may I respond please I meant
it in a nice way no I and I appreciate
that I think it is a challenge and I I
tried to Ice Break in the beginning
about about that about how hard it was
to present our budget in 45 minutes um I
you know we are an agency that serves
our most vulnerable in the state that's
the challenge we're a service agency
we're not making you know product or
widgets and we can't shut down wings um
there's consequences to to budget cuts
and we take that extremely seriously so
we want to work with the the governor
elect team uh and and others to make
sure that we make the right choices and
the responsible choices and that we're
not causing causing any harm and that
the um
the things that might seem obvious the
reason I bring up Personnel is because
the juice isn't worth the squeeze on
that one um as I would say um you know
there are probably other ways that we
could look to do some cost savings
without causing harm but I I it it's
going to be challenging and it we've
been saying that we've been talking with
our partners we recognize that we're in
different times it's not the co time so
I just want to acknowledge that and the
bathroom was an inside droke for those
of you that didn't
know I think ter and it's not you it's
Terry Morton built a bathroom off the
commissioner's office just seem seems
weird you're getting new bathrooms too I
am that thank you very much and with
that I'd like to thank uh governor elect
aot uh the rest of my committee members
and for all the uh Commissioners and
their teams that have presented over the
last three days it was very very
beneficial thank you and this is just
obviously the beginning of the
conversation so thank you very much we
are now
adjourned
e e